LIKE TO CALL -- THE BUDGET IN
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER TWO ON RESOURCES
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION.
ENERGY AND TRANSPORTATION TO
ORDER.
WE WILL GO TO PART BE.
VERSUS I WAIT TAKE ESTABLISH A
QUORUM AND ASK CAL EPA TO PLEASE
COME FORWARD -- UNDER DISCUSSION
ONLY WILL HOLD OFF ON THE VOTE
ONLY THIS IS PART BE UNDER
DISCUSSION ONLY AND THE MAGIC
NUMBER.
IS.
ISSUE.
TWENTY THREE MR SECRETARY GOOD
AFTERNOON SORRY FOR THE DELAY.
PLEASE PROCEED RIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M AND THANK YOU
MEMBERS IN CHAD I'M I THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY.
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
REFLECTS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING OUR
MOST PRESSING ENVIRONMENTAL
CHALLENGES WHILE CONTINUING TO
KEEP OUR ECONOMY THRIVING IN
THIS BUDGET.
KELLY P. A REQUEST SIX POSITIONS
FOR CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT
WITHIN OUR AGENCY THESE
POSITIONS COVER TO TJ PLANNING
LEAN SIX SIGMA TRAINING INTERNAL
COMMUNICATIONS.
CONTRACT IN LABOR LAW AND
ENFORCEMENT COORDINATION.
OUR GOAL IS TO BUILD A COUNTY PA
THAT IS TRANSPARENT EFFECTIVE
AND FISCALLY PRUDENT.
I BELIEVE IN GOVERNMENT'S
ABILITY TO HELP CONFRONT
CALIFORNIA'S MOST PRESSING
ENVIRONMENTAL SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC CHALLENGES.
AT THE SAME TIME CAL EPA CAN DO
MORE TO IMPROVE OPERATIONS AND
MAINTAIN PUBLIC TRUST.
ESTABLISHING CONNECTIONS BETWEEN
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
BOARDS DEPARTMENTS AND OFFICES
IS A TOP PRIORITY.
SO WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR AND ARE
KIND OF GO THROUGH THE PRESENT
POSITION THE FEST RELATES TO
STRATEGIC PLANNING. ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT ACTIVITIES NEEDED
TO SHAPE ORGANIZATIONAL THINKING
A LINE PRIORITIES REFOCUS ENERGY
AND RESOURCES AND STRENGTHENING
OPERATIONS IS DEVELOP.
A STRATEGIC PLANNING CULTURE AND
PRACTICE FOR THE AGENCY THIS
LEVEL OF PLANNING AND CRITICAL
THINKING WILL ENSURE THAT THE
AGENCY IS WORKING TOWARDS COMMON
GOALS.
AND HOLDING US ACCOUNTABLE FOR
OUTCOMES AND RESULTS.
THIS POSITION WILL ASSIST IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A NEW AGENCY
WHITES GIGI PLANNING PROCESS OUR
FOCUS WILL BE ON PERFORMANCE
MANAGEMENT.
AND THE INTEGRATION AND
COORDINATION BETWEEN AND AMONG
SIDEBOARDS DEPARTMENTS AND
OFFICES.
THE ENVIRONMENT DOES NOT ADHERE
TO STRICT STOVE PIPES AND NORTH
NEITHER SHOULD WE THE SECOND
RELATES TO LEAN SIX SIGMA.
WE WANT TO CREATE A CULTURE OF
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT FOR
CALLIE PA AND THE BDO'S BUILT
UPON A PLATFORM USING.
LEAN PRINCIPLES AND TOOLS. ONE
OF OUR MAIN OBJECTIVES
OBJECTIVES IS IMPROVING HOW
CALIBRATE OPERATES AS AN AGENCY.
AND I PLAN TO DO THIS BY
CREATING A CULTURE OF CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT.
USING IT LEAN SIX SIGMA.
I VISION SECTOR-LIMóN ALSO STOP
YOU THERE BECAUSE I REALIZE THAT
YOU WERE IN CHARGE OF THE
CATHOLIC CLIMATE ACTION TEAM AND
THE SECRETARY HAS BEEN IN CHARGE
OF THE CLIMATE ACTION TEAM. FOR
EIGHT YEARS DO YOU BEEN WORKING
NOT ONLY INTERNALLY BUT
EXTERNALLY ACROSS DIFFERENT.
DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN ORDER TO
PLAN STRATEGICALLY.
ISN'T SOME OF THAT WORK ALREADY
DONE THAT YOU'VE DONE AT LEAST
IN THE CLIMATE.
ADAPTATION RESILIENCY OF MEDIUM
THAT THAT.
YOU WOULD HAVE A GUY I THINK
YOU'VE BEEN DOING THAT OR YOUR
PREDECESSORS DID YOU AT THE
OFFICE HAS BEEN DOING THAT. FOR
THE LAST THE LAST EIGHT YEARS
WHAT WOULD BE DIFFERENT THAN
THIS AT THIS.
SUPERVISOR WOULD BE DOING OUR
THAT.
YOU HAVE IN THE APARTMENT HAS
HAVE YOU ALREADY THAT.
COMING IN THE DOOR I'M
ESPECIALLY WITH THE CONTEXT OF
OF A PREVIOUS EXPERIENCE IN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT -- I THINK WE
DO DO A REALLY GOOD JOB.
AT CAL EPA OF COORDINATING WITH
OTHER AGENCIES OTHER DEPARTMENTS
EVEN EXTERNAL STAKEHOLDERS WE DO
A MUCH LESS GOOD JOB OF
COORDINATING INTERNALLY.
THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT OUR OWN
STRATEGIC PLANS I'M BOTH IN
TERMS OF THE KEY PERFORMANCE
INDICATORS STRATEGIC METRICS OF
SUCCESS.
HOW WAY COMMUNICATING TO OUR
PUBLICS ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING
AND HOW WE'RE DOING IT IS VERY
LITTLE COORDINATION INTERNALLY
SO THIS WOULD BE?
A PASS AND THAT SIX THOUSAND
PEOPLE WITHIN CALLIE PA'S BOARDS
APARTMENT OFFICES.
I'M I'M HAVE STRATEGIC PLANS OF
A LAST ON IN. TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT I'M NOT A MORE RECENT NONE
OF THEM COORDINATE AND AND WORK
TOGETHER. TO MAKE SURE ALL WE
ARE PROVIDING SERVICES TO ALL
OUR PUBLICS AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
WE HAVE RATING TOGETHER
INTERNALLY SO THIS IS REALLY.
I'M I WANNA MAKE SHOW ON OUR
WEBSITE THAT YOU CAN LOOK AT ANY
ISSUE RELATED TO CALLIE PA AND
WATER METRICS OF SUCCESS ARE
WHERE WE ARE AGAINST THEM.
AND ALSO CHAT REALLY THIS
RELATES TO PERFORMANCE
MANAGEMENT I WANT TO MAKE SURE
ALL OUR STAFF.
I'M HAVE CLEAR GOALS THAT RELATE
TO CLEAR STRATEGIC PLANS.
THAT SUCCESS IS DRIVEN BY A
HOLISTIC FRAME WORKING CURRENTLY
IT'S VERY PIECEMEAL AND AD HOC
WITHIN THE AGENCY.
AND AND REALLY I GUESS IS GOES
TO SOMETHING THAT I I COULD HAVE
PREFACED I WANT TO BE.
I'M COGNIZANT OF THE OF THE TIME
THAT YOU HAVE TODAY.
REALLY HOURS SORRY I'LL GOAL
CHAT IS. TO REALLY.
THINK OF CAL EPA AS THE
COORDINATING AND I'M.
THE THE ENTITY THAT CAN HELP
BRING THE TV PLANNING SKILLS CAN
HELP BRING LEAN SIX SIGMA TO
CREATE EFFICIENCY.
AND HELP BRING COORDINATION ON
ENFORCEMENT I'M.
AND CAN HELP TO INTERNAL
COMMUNICATION SO THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING REAL VALUE TO THE
PEOPLE IN THE BUILDING BUT ALSO
TO EXTERNAL AUDIENCES SO ALL.
OF THESE POSITIONS REALLY COMING
IN THE DOOR.
I'M AYE I RECOGNIZE THAT IN
ORDER TO BE EFFECTIVE AND SERVE
YOU AND THE PUBLIC WELL WE NEED
A BETTER JOB IN COORDINATING
SOME OF THESE FUNCTIONS WHICH AT
THE MOMENT.
ARE COMPLETELY AND YOU THINK IS
IS THE IS THE BECAUSE I SEE THE
CAT WORKING HORIZONTALLY WITH
STATE GOVERNMENT YOU'RE TALKING
A MORE VERTICAL -- AN INTERNAL I
GUESS INTERNAL -- PLAN AND THEN
MEASURED OUTCOMES RIGHT ASSEMBLY
WE'RE GONNA HAVE MEASURED
OUTCOMES FROM THIS.
STRATEGIC PLAN RIGHT YES SAYS.
I'M NOT TO PUT TOO FINE A POINT
AYE BUT THERE'S A THERE'S A
GREAT DEAL OF AND AND IMPORTANT
FOCUS I'M.
HISTORICALLY ON CLIMATE CHANGE
AND I AND I THINK WITHIN THE THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD THERE IS A
FOCUS ON THOSE BUT WHEN IT COMES
TO ALL THE OTHER BOARDS AND
DEPARTMENTS.
I'M VETOED LATER IN THE DAY
YOU'LL BE TALKING ABOUT
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL -- CARRY CYCLE MAKING
SURE THAT -- FOR INSTANCE ON
EMERGENCY PLANNING AND RESPONSE
THAT OR LIBEL DEPARTMENTS ARE
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY WITH --
YES AND THE OTHER AGENCIES --
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED WE NEED
TO DO IN ORDER TO DO THAT WE
KIND OF I'M FOR INSTANCE ONE OF
THESE POSITIONS IS TO IS TO ASK.
FOR A SINGLE PERSON TO DO
TRAINING.
EVERYTHING FROM ETHICS TRAINING
TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT TRAINING TO
LEADERSHIP TRAINING.
I'M TO SKILLS COMPETENCY AND
ASSESSMENT TO CLOSING THE SKILLS
GAP.
I'M THROUGH TARGETED TRAINING
THAT CURRENTLY ISN'T HAPPENING
AND SO.
WITH AN ORGANIZATION REACHES A
CERTAIN SIZE AND MAGNITUDE TO TO
HAVE THOSE.
ABSENT REALLY PREVENTS US FROM
REACHING OUR GOALS I'M SO THAT
THE NOT A LOT OF POSITIONS AS
ONE FOR EACH OF THESE.
DISCIPLINES.
ANOTHER DOES BRING UP IS LEGAL
SUPPORT SO.
I'M.
YOU KNOW I I HAVE A BACKGROUND
AS AN ATTORNEY BUT WHEN IT COMES.
TO SOMEONE TO REVIEW LARGE
CONTRACTS BEFORE THEY GO OUT THE
DOOR.
I WANNA MAKE SURE SOMEONE IN OUR
OFFICE IS DOING THAT I'M AS
YOU'LL HEAR CARRY CYCLE LET A
BILLION DOLLAR CONTRACT AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS YEAR.
I WANNA MAKE SURE WE HAVE THE
OVERSIGHT AND ABILITY TO MAKE
SURE ALL THAT ALL THE I'S DOTTED
ANTES ACROSS BEFORE CONTRACTS OF
THAT MAGNITUDE GO OUT.
THE SAME IS TRUE I'M.
I'M WITH ISSUES LIKE INTERNAL
COMMUNICATIONS WHICH IS ANOTHER
ONE I'M.
OFF DON'T KNOW ACROSS PROGRAMS
WHAT'S HAPPENING THERE'S NO
INTERNAL.
NEWSLETTER OF MANY OF THE
AGENCIES HAVE THE ABILITY TO
COMMUNICATE WHAT'S HAPPENING
AMONGST IN BETWEEN SO THESE ARE
ALL KIND OF NOT WILL NOT NOT A
LARGE BUDGET REQUEST BUT IT
REALLY DOES GO TO THE POINT THAT.
WE CAN DO IS SIGNIFICANTLY
BETTER JOB HELPING OUT STAFF I'M
HELPING COORDINATE THE FINAL ONE
I'M THAT I'LL JUST BRING YOUR
ATTENTION TO IS ENFORCEMENT
COORDINATION [inaudible]
I'M.
AND THIS IS ONE PARTICULARLY --
THAT I'VE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
FOR FOCUSED ON YOU KNOW IN ORDER
TO DO THAT LACK OF TARGETING
ENFORCEMENT.
MAKING SURE WE KNOW.
I'M.
ACROSS THE ENTIRE BOARD OF
CALLIE PA HOW WE'RE DOING IT.
I'M WHO WAS HAVING.
WHAT THE DOC IT LOOKS LIKE YOU
NEED SOMEONE TO COORDINATE
ENFORCEMENT?
I'M AT AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF
THESE POSITIONS ALL REALLY GO.
TO THE TO THAT GOAL OF OF
BRINGING PEOPLE TOGETHER.
CREATING EFFICIENCIES THROUGH
TRAINING THROUGH LEAN SIX SIGMA
I'M WE CAN DO A BETTER JOB.
HELPING DELIVER PROGRAMS ARE
CUSTOM AS OF WE DO IT IN A MORE
EFFICIENT MANNER.
WITHOUT REDUCING THE PROTECTIONS
THAT THE PUBLIC [inaudible]
REQUIRE.
LA -- YOU HAVE A COMMENT IS JOHN
MY WITH LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE MEANING WITHIN BROADLY
THAT THE PROPOSAL'S LITTLE HAS
MERIT THE GOALS IN THE PROPOSAL
A MATCH.
WHEN WE READ THROUGH IT THERE
ARE NO DETAILED DESCRIPTION OF
THE ACTIVITIES THAT WOULD BE
UNDERTAKEN?
pCALLIE PA WAS THE INTENSE TO
ACHIEVE SO FOR EXAMPLE THE
PROPOSAL REQUEST A POSITION TO
PROVIDE LEADERSHIP FOR TRAINING
PROGRAM BUT IT DOESN'T IDENTIFY
THE TYPES OF TRAINING.
ALTHOUGH THE SECRETARY JUST
IDENTIFIED A FEW OF THEM -- THAT
WOULD BE PROVIDED THE NUMBER
STATE EMPLOYEES THAT WOULD
RECEIVE THE SPECIFIC TRAINING OR
THE TIME FRAME FOR WHEN THE
TRAINING WOULD BE STARTED AND
COMPLETED.
SO BEFORE BUT APPROVING THE
PROPOSAL AND WE RECOMMEND THAT
CALLIE PA TESTIFY PROVIDE MORE
DETAILS ON THE EXISTING
SHORTCOMINGS BEEN ADDRESSED TO
THINK THE SECRETARY HAS.
DONE SOME BAD MAN HERE AND AT
THAT MEASURE WILL OUTCOMES THAT
WOULD BE ESTABLISHED FOR EACH OF
THE COMPONENTS OF THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD BE SUPPORTIVE OF THAT --
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT LANGUAGE
RECOMMENDED BY THE STAFF RIGHT
WE WERE ASKING FOR AT SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY FROM THE AGENCY
AND AND THE STRATEGIC PLANNING
AND THE I'M.
OBVIOUSLY IN THE TEST ONE WAS
HELPFUL MEMBERS WHO HAVE
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
RIGHT I'M.
LET'S OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING
IS THE ONLY THING I HAVE FOR CAL
EPA OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT ARE HERE THIS IS THE SIX
POSITIONS.
NINE HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND RIGHT LET'S CLOSE IT
THEIR STAFF RECOMMENDATION.
BRUCE BUT REQUIRED.
FROM REPORTING LANGUAGE IN
ADDITION TO WHAT WE HAD TODAY
[inaudible]
WHAT?
LET ME ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND
THEN I WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MY COUNTY HERE DOWN [inaudible]
MONNING.
A QUORUM IS ESTABLISH.
IN A MOVE THE PROPOSAL LAST
MODIFIED IN.
THIS CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
I CAN'T [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MONEY.
THE MEASURE IS THREE ONE WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OF FROM FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME AND TESTIFYING
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible] ONE TWO WHAT
PERCENT.
I JUST WISH [inaudible]
WE THE VOTE ONLY.
OKAY.
LET'S GO BACK TO TOP THE
CALENDAR -- WE WILL HAVE.
VOTE ONLY MOTIONS AND APPROVE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION SERVICE SET
FORTH IN THE AGENDA.
THE LET'S WE'RE GONNA DEAL WITH
PART A IS SET FORTH IN THE TELL
DOES THAT SOUND [inaudible]
WE A MOTION UNDER PART A THIS TO
BE ISSUES ONE THROUGH.
SEVEN IS THERE A MOTION TO
APPROVE THOSE.
HER STAFF RECOMMENDATION THERE'S
A MOTION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I CASKEY I DON'T [inaudible]
YOU ARE [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
STERN.
WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ON MOTION NUMBER TWO WOULD BE
ISSUES EIGHT THROUGH.
ELEVEN OUR MOTION IS A MOTION BY
SENATE MCGUIRE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MY CASTING I DON'T.
REQUIRE.
MONNING.
STERN.
THE MATTER HAS FOUR VOTES WILL
GIVE THE ROLL OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS NOW MOVING THE
PART BE.
CAROLINE ATTEND A MOTION FOR
ISSUES ONE INTO. FOR THROUGH
FIFTH [inaudible]
THROUGH.
FOURTEEN AND IN NINETEEN THROUGH.
TWENTY ONE IS THERE A MOTION.
MOTION BY CENTER MURDER MONNING
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MY COUNTY I OWNS.
MCGUIRE.
MONNING.
TURN.
BEFORE VOTES WILL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AND
SECOND MOTION THIS TO BE ISSUES
TWO ONE THREE AND ISSUES FIFTEEN
THROUGH EIGHTEEN IS OUR MOTION.
MOTION BY SENATE MCGUIRE PLEASE
CALL ROLL.
CASKEY.
I JONES.
I HAVE [inaudible]
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN OKAY [inaudible]
ABSTAINED [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
MONNING AYE STERN.
AT THAT MATTERS THREE VOTES TO
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO PART EIGHT
THIS IS A CALIFORNIA P. YOU SEE
LET'S DO THE WILDFIRES.
ISSUE FIRST IS TO BE ISSUE
NUMBER [inaudible] THIRTEEN PART
A CALIFORNIA ENERGIES FUTURE
SIXTEEN POSITIONS. FORTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS.
THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER.
THIRTEEN GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS
PROPOSES SIXTEEN POSITIONS FORTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS -- IN THIS
YEAR.
THE CHAIRMAN AND SENATE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS BERNARD AS A VETO.
AND THE ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
TODAY WE HAVE THE P. C.
REPRESENTATIVES HERE TO ADDRESS
ISSUES.
THIRTEEN AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
HEARING THIS MOTION FIRST.
AND NUMBER TWELVE LATER WE'RE
HERE TO ANSWER ANY OF YOUR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
OKAY -- HE HAS SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE SWAT TEAM.
CONCERNS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ROSS BROWN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
JUST BY WAY OF BACKGROUND THIS
PROPOSAL HAS KIND OF THREE
DISTINCT COMPONENTS ONE IS
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
CONTRACT. TO CONTRACT WITH AN
OUTSIDE ENTITY TO HELP WITH
ENFORCEMENT OF WILDFIRE
MEDICATIONS PLANS FOR ONE YEAR.
THIRTEEN MILLION AGAIN ONE TIME
CONTRACTING RESOURCES TO HELP
THE COMMISSION -- IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF KIND OF THEIR
WIRES WILD FIRE MITIGATION
POLICY DEVELOPMENT WHILE FOR ME
TO GET SOME PLANS AND A LONG
TERM VISION FOR THOSE PLANS.
AND THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
ADDITIONAL STAFF RESOURCES THAT
WOULD WORK ON ACTIVITIES RELATED.
TO A POWER SHUT OFFS AS WELL AS
CAN OF REFORMS TO INTERNAL
PROCESSES OF THE PC.
SO IN CONCEPT WE THINK THAT
THESE ACTIVITIES HAVE MERIT AS
PART OF THE STATE'S OVERALL
APPROACH TO REDUCING WILDFIRE
RISK -- HOWEVER THERE'S NO CLEAR
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN FOR THE
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES OR
ESTIMATES OF OUTCOMES THAT YOU
SEE EXPECTS TO ACHIEVE BUT THOSE
RESOURCES.
AND IT'S UNCLEAR HOW YOU SEE
WILL USE THAT X. IS EXPERIENCE
WITH THESE ONE TIME RESOURCES TO
INFORMANTS LONG TERM WILD FIRE
MITIGATION ENFORCEMENT.
STRATEGY SO RECOMMENDING THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPT AS ARE ALL
REQUIRING THE PC TO REPORT BY
APRIL OF NEXT YEAR.
ON HOW MUCH FUNDING -- IT IS
SPENT. FOR THE ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES WHAT OUTCOMES IT HAS
ACHIEVED AND HOW THE X..
THIS WILL HELP IN ENHANCE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OVER THE
WILD FIRE MITIGATION PLAN
ENFORCEMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION.
SO FINANCE ARE WHAT DO YOU HAVE
TO ADD YOU KNOW TYPICALLY WE
THINK OF THE YOU SEE YOU'VE GOT
TO ESTABLISH INTERVENOR AS OF
THE HIGH STATUS THEN YOU COME IN.
IT'S NOT THE WILDFIRE MITIGATION
PLANNING.
I AGENCY I GUESS IS GENERALLY
WOULD SAY WHAT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK I SEE ABOUT
THE ALEJO'S OBSERVATIONS I MEAN
MARTIN DEPARTMENT FINANCE?
I'M.
WE ARE -- INTEND TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION REQUESTED BY YOUR
STAFF AND BY THE LA -- PLAYED BY
THE END OF TODAY -- IF IN IN
TERMS OF HOW SOME OF THESE IN
THIS INFORMATION.
CONTACTED HIM ABOUT WE DON'T
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE SUB MODEL
COURTING LANGUAGE BUT PART OF
THE IDEA BEHIND THIS IS.
THAT YOU KNOW IF YOU SEE IS JUST
UNDERGONE THEIR FIRST ROUND OF
WELFARE MEDICATION PLANTS THEY
ARE REVIEWING -- AND APPROVING
WHAT WAS GIVEN TO THEM.
THESE RESOURCES.
ARE THESE RESOURCE SAID WOULD BE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
STRUCTURING THESE PLANS CORRECT
IS THE FIRST TIME THIS HAS BEEN
DONE AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT.
WE'RE NOT JUST REACTING TO WHAT
ARE IN THE PLANS BUT DIRECTING
EVEN MORE STRONGLY.
THESE ARE COMPONENTS WE EXPECT
TO SEE IN THEM FURTHERMORE --
THIS.
PLEASE RESOURCES WOULD HELP HOW
TO CLOSE THE GAP IN.
CERTAIN AREAS LIKE
INFRASTRUCTURE HARDENING WHERE
THERE IS NOT CONSENSUS ABOUT
WHAT CONSTITUTES I'M WITHIN.
THE UTILITIES OR SOMETHING
SACRAMENTO THIS WOULD HELP
YOU'RE GOING TO BRING THAT
TOGETHER -- AND SO -- WE THINK
THAT THESE RESOURCES WILL HELP
MOVE FORWARD.
I'M STRONGER WATER MITIGATION
PLAN TO ALSO.
TO HELP WITH.
MAKING SURE THAT WHEN A UTILITY
SAYS IT'S DOING ITS MITIGATION
PLAN SOMEONE GOES ON SAYS YEP
YOU SAY THAT YOU. FOR EXAMPLE
TRIM THE TREES I SEE THAT THE
TREES ARE TRIMMED NOW GRANTED AS
NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA SB NOT A
ONE EXPECT THAT TO HAPPEN IN A
FEW YEARS.
GIVEN THE CLIMATE CHANGE THAT
WERE UNDER AMEND THE VERY --
PAST OF WILD FIRES WE THINK
GETTING SOME GOOD IDEA OF WHAT
THAT SHOULD LOOK LIKE SOONER
RATHER THAN LATER IS APPROPRIATE.
AND THAT CAN ALSO BE USED TO
HELP -- DEVELOP THE CRITERIA
AROUND.
WHAT KIND OF PERSON IS REALLY
GOOD AT DOING THIS AND HOW BIG
IS THE PROBLEM IN TERMS OF
COMPLIANCE RIGHT NOW RATHER THAN
WAITING? FOR A COUPLE YEARS WHEN
THAT GOES INTO EFFECT.
IT IS.
THAT IS GOOD QUESTION OF WHAT'S
THE PERSON ARE.
IT'S REALLY GOOD ABOUT DOING
THIS I LOVE THE P. YOU SEE WITH
ALL RESPECT IS I KNOW I KNOW
THAT NINE A ONE PUT IT THERE.
AND AS I READ THROUGH THE STAFF
REPORT AND I LOOK AT WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO AND I LOOK AT THIS.
THE CHECK. FIVE PART PLAN I'M
THINKING [inaudible]
MAYBE WE PUT THIS IN THE WRONG
AGENCY BE GOING ABOUT.
MOVING THESE PLANS GIVING THE
RECEIVE THOROUGHNESS THAT MOST
OF THESE HEARINGS GO THROUGH TO
GET TO A DECISION.
IT MAY BE TOO LONG WE MAY BE
SITTING HERE IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE WAITING FOR THE PLAN TO BE
APPROVED I KNOW I DON'T THINK WE
EXPECT WITH.
YOU THAT.
I GET A GET A PHONE CALL AFTER I
SAID THAT -- MEMBERS
[inaudible]
CENTER MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
WE SHOULD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LOOK AT THIS THERE'S COM. THREE
MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST FOR ON
GOING ADDITIONAL STAFF TO HELP
OVERSEE UTILITY POWER SHUT OFFS
AND REFORM.
INTERNAL CPUC PROCESSES.
CAN YOU SHARE A LITTLE BIT HOW
THAT THREE MILLION GETS
ALLOCATED RELATED TO THE THE
UTILITY WANTS TO SHUT OFF POWER --
IN A HIGH RISK FIRE AREA DO WE
KNOW HOW HOW MANY POSITIONS IS
THIS AND ARE THEY OUT IN THE
FIELD IS THE UTILITY.
HAVE TO COORDINATE WITH KEY YOU
SEEN.
STAFF PERSON BEFORE THE POWER
GET SHUT OFF.
ANYONE ADDRESS SENT -- EMILY'S
IF YOU'RE MOTION COME THE DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION FOR SAFETY AND
ENFORCEMENT POLICY.
ALL WE'RE ASKING FOR SIX OF
POSITIONS RELATED TO THE WELL.
OUR SHUT OFF -- PROGRAM --
CURRENTLY WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
DEDICATED STAFF OF FOUR FOUR D.
IMAGES ATION.
AND THE EXPERIENCE ALL OF LAST
YEAR ALL MEN AND THE WORK THAT'S
BEEN GOING ON SINCE THEN TO HALL
OF THE UTIITIES ESTABLISH THIS
PROGRAM.
IS INDICATING TO US THAT WE
REALLY NEED DEDICATED STAFF.
OUT WITH THE STAFF WOULD BE
DOING IS THAT THE ABLE TO BE
EXPERTS IN UTILITY BELT
PROCESSES AND PROCEDURES FOR D.
ENERGIES LACE RUN.
OUT WHEN UTILITIES ARE
ACTIVATING -- IT DID DURING
WEATHER CONDITIONS OF THOSE
STAFF WOULD BE LAUNCHING UTILITY
ACTIVITIES.
AND OVERSEEING -- HOW?
THE UTILITIES ARE MAKING
DECISIONS RIGHT NOW THE THE WAY
THAT THE THE PROGRAM WORKS IS
THAT. FOR A PUBLIC UTILITIES
CODE THE UTILITIES HOW THE RATE
TO SHUT OFF POWER IF THEY
BELIEVE THE CANNOT OPERATE THEIR
SYSTEM SAFELY.
SO WE DID NOT THAT THIS POINTS
EXPECT THAT.
THE STATE -- WOULD BE MAKING
THAT DECISION BUT WE WANT TO
PROVIDE VERY THOROUGH OVERSIGHT
AND ESPECIALLY WITH WHAT WE'RE
INSISTS THE P. EATING.
OUT WTH THE POWER SHUT OFF
PROGRAMS WITH UTILITIES PROBABLY
USING THEM A LOT MORE FREQUENTLY
ESPECIALLY UP NORTH.
HELP WITH THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE THAT
STAFF.
TO OVERSEE WHAT THE UTILITIES
ARE DOING AND THEN ALSO PERFORM
AFTER ACTION.
REVIEWS AND REPORTS -- THE STAFF
WOULD ALSO BE.
COORDINATING WITH OTHER STATE
AGENCIES PARTICULARLY WITH
CALLAWAY YES ANTICIPATED THE
WOULD BE.
PHYSICALLY PRESENT IN THE EOC
WHEN HOME.
WHEN IT'S ACTIVATED ELEMENT AND
WOULD ALSO HELP WITH OF THE KING
OF COORDINATION BETWEEN
UTILITIES STATES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS?
DURING THE AND RELATIONS.
THANK YOU THAT'S HELPFUL SO.
UTILITIES HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
MAKE THAT DECISION ON THEIR OWN.
ARE THEY OBLIGATED TO ALERT THE
PC IF THEY EXERCISE THAT
AUTHORITY.
YES THEY ARE THERE IS AN
EXTENSIVE -- PROTOCOL DEVELOPED
FOR NOTIFICATION ALL OF US.
AGENCIES INCLUDING PC AND CAL WE
****.
A NOTIFICATIONS TO LOCAL
EMERGENCY RESPONSE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND TO THE PUBLIC AS
WELL.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT.
THE GAME MORE QUESTIONS CAN ON
THE POLICY SIDE SOMEONE TRYING.
TO THE BUDGET. TWENTY FIVE
MILLION FOR THESE THIRD PARTY
FOLKS IS THERE SOME SORT OF A
LIST OF PEOPLE THAT.
YOU GET A YOU WORK WITH BECAUSE
I KNOW THAT CAL FIRE WE WANT TO
CAL FIRE TO GET AS MANY PEOPLE.
OUT THERE DOING THE WORK NOT
CONFIRMING THAT THEY DID WORK WE
KEEP.
HAMMERING THE I'LL USED TO GET
OUT AND TO WORK AS THEY'VE BEEN
DOING MORE -- WE'VE GOT TO SEE
IT CAN'T CONSERVATION CORPS WERE
GIVING THEM MORE MONEY TO DO THE
WORK SO.
WHERE DO WE NEED YOU GUYS HAVE A
LIST OF PEOLE TO GET IT CHECKED
FOR COMPLIANCE THAT THE I. O.
U.'S ARE DOING IT?
OMIT SO L..
CURRENTLY THERE ARE BILL
INDEPENDENCE WE'RE STATE.
INSPECTORS DID GO OUT THERE AND
INSPECT UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE
SO THE WAY THAT THE THE SORT OF
THE THE SAFETY PARADIGMS WORK TO
DATE.
IS THAT THE P. YOU SEE SAFETY
FUNCTIONS TO PERFORM AUDITS SO
IT'S A MOSTLY A RECORD.
AUDIT THE DO YOU.
PERFORM WORKING PLANS WITH THE
COMMISSION'S GENERAL ORDERS WE
DID NOT GO OUT AND PATROL ALSO
NEED THE CAL FIRE DOES NOT
WORKING WITH THE P. YOU SEE AND
THERE CURRENTLY ARE NO
INDEPENDENT THIRD PARTIES AS
ENVISIONED BY SB NINE OH ONE
THAT HASN'T.
PROCESS HASN'T BEEN SET UP YET.
SO WHERE THE THIS CONTRACT WOULD
DEAL IS.
IN THE INTERIM WHILE WE CAN OF
WORK ON THE LONG TERM SOLUTION
IS BRING ON AT LEAST SOME
INSTANCE SPECTER STAFF SO WE CAN
SEND START SENDING OUT PEOPLE IN
THE FIELD TO VERIFY.
THE CONDITIONS.
ON THE GROUND ALL THE MOST
SIMILAR WORK TO THIS THAT'S BEEN
DONE BY THE COMMISSION WAS A
CONTRACT THAT WE ENTERED INTO
AFTER SEEM BRUNO PIPELINE
EXPLOSION WHERE THE PACIFIC GAS
AND ELECTRIC WAS DIRECTED.
HELLO.
TO HELP PUT IN PLACE BY PLANE
SAFETY ENHANCEMENT PLANS THAT
WAS TESTING OR REPLACING --
TRANSMISSION PIPELINES AND WE
HAD A TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
CONTRACT OF THE TWENTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR CONTRACT THAT THE
P. YOU SEE SIGNED AFTER THAT THE
BUREAU VERITAS.
HOME TO GO OUT IN THE GOVERNMENT
THE P. YOU SEE STAFF -- TO
VERIFY THE WORK THE P. JEANNIE
WAS DOING OUT IN THE FIELD.
AND ELM BE REVERED SIZE ALSO
DOES SIMILAR WORK FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
AROUND POWER PLANTS SO THEY
GENERALLY KIND OF DO THIS TYPE
OF CONTRACTS WITH THE WITH THE
STATE'S AND ELHAM.
AT WORLDWIDE FOR DIFFERENT
REGULATORY AGENCIES TO THE HOW
THE CAPACITY TO ELM -- TO HIRE --
LINEMAN JOURNEYMEN FOR EXAMPLE
AND TRAIN THEM UP TO GO OUT IN
THE FIELD AND DO THIS TYPE OF
ACTION SO THAT'S AN EXAMPLE OF
ONE COMPANY THAT DOES THAT TYPE
OF WORK THERE ARE OTHERS.
ALL MY THAT HOW OF OF BEEN
CONTACTING.
ME WITH RESPECT TO THIS KIND OF
WORK SO I THINK WHEN WE PUT IT
OUT TO COMPETITIVE BID WE WILL
HELP.
YOU KNOW SEVERAL OPTIONS TO
CHOOSE FROM BUT THAT'S JUST AN
EXAMPLE.
FOR HOW IT'S BEEN DONE IN
SIMILAR CASES.
YEAH I JUST HAVE I JUST HAVE
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTIONS I KNOW
THAT WE RUSHED OUT AND WE DID
LEGISLATION WE RUSHED OUT WE STE
[inaudible]
ESTABLISH THIS.
QUICK REPORT THAT WE'RE GOING TO
GET INTO IT AND I'M JUST SITTING
HERE.
SAYING WHY IS THE P. YOU SEE
COULD LEAD THE WAY.
ON ARE THESE THE THE STRIKE TEAM
ON THE AFFECTS OF DESTABILIZING
HOW THE WIRE FIRES HAVE WE'RE
IT'S NOT MY IDEA I I KNOW IT'S
BIGGER PEOPLE UP THERE I'M JUST
WONDERING HOW WE GAVE YOU GUYS
THIS CHARGE.
AND YOU'RE GOING.
TO CREATE A STRIKE TEAM OUT OF
YOU KNOW AT THIS TO SOME LONG
TERM STRATEGIC PLANNING AND AND
BUILD UP SOME STAFF AND THINKING.
WHAT MADE US THINK THAT IT
SHOULD BE?
UNDER YOUR ROOF.
I MEAN I SEE THAT YOU YOU YOU
GET YOU GOT A JOB THEY ASK YOU
TO DO IT SO YOU'RE GOING TO DO
THE BEST JOB YOU CAN'T BUT
THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU GUYS DO.
ELEMENT A THING THE THE HELPING
A LARGE IN THE FIELD INSPECTION
THE WORKFORCE IS ELM.
DEFINITELY WOULD BE E. L..
A DIFFERENT FUNCTION FOR THE
COMMISSION WOULD GENERALLY A
REGULATORY BODY IN THE POLICY
MAKING BODY LOTS OF BOOTS ON THE
GROUND ITS SCALE KIND OF BODY.
ARMOR I THINK THE CAN OF OVER
OLD.
YOU KNOW IF IF I WAS TO
SPECULATE ELM IT'S BECAUSE OF
YOU SEE HOUSING -- OVERALL
AUTHORITY OVER UTILITIES.
AND EVERYTHING TO DO WITH
UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY
AND RELIABILITY OF AND COSTS AND
SO BECAUSE THIS INFRASTRUCTURE
IS UTILITY OWNED GOES FALLS OF
THE PC. TO WORK THROUGH ALL OF
THE ISSUES.
RELATED TO THIS CHALLENGE WHERE.
IN THE UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE.
I THINK LONG TERM YOU KNOW WE
THEY CAN BE THIS CONVERSATIONS
HOW TO WHAT IS A LONG TERM
STRATEGY FOR IT AND IF THE PC IS
THE BEST THE AGENCY TO DO
CERTAIN FIELD WORK AS AN EXAMPLE.
BUT AGAIN I THINK THE THOUGHT
BEHIND THE CONTRACT AND WHY IT'S
OF IN THE SHORT TERM BETTER TO
DO IT THIS WAY IS BECAUSE IT
GIVE STATES FLEXIBILITY.
TO COME UP WITH THE LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS OF MAY AND MAY NOT
INVOLVE THE P. YOU SEE DOING IT
BUT I THINK WE BECAUSE WE HAVE
SUCH A CRITICAL RISK LEVEL RIGHT
NOW I THINK THIS A GENERAL.
DESIRE BY BY THE PUBLIC AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO JUST HAVE
SOMEBODY GOING OUT DOING PATROLS
ALL WHILE WE ARE SORT OF
DISCUSSING LONG TERM SOLANO I
DON'T I DON'T DISAGREE WITH
SOMEBODY SHOULD OUT.
CONTROLS I JUST SAY YOU KNOW
NORMALLY WE THINK OF YOU GUYS
AND THAT -- THE ADVOCATE WHAT'S
THE HOW THE REPAIRS BEING
AFFECTED AND THAT'S NOT THE
SKILL SET THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
WITH THIS TASK RIGHT HERE.
FINANCE YOU WANT TO ADD
SOMETHING THAT.
BECAUSE IT IS ONE TIME OVER
THREE YEARS -- THERE IS THE
OPPORTUNITY WHEN THAT'S UP TO
CLEAN EVERYTHING WAS COME FROM
AND MAKE THAT POLICY
DETERMINATION WHETHER P. YOU SEE
LONG TERM SHOULD BE DOING THIS
OR WHETHER ANOTHER ENTITY SHOULD.
AND WE WOULD THEN HAVE THE DATA
AND EXPERIENCE.
TO GET A A GOOD SENSE OF WHERE
THEY SHOULD BE I MEAN I JUST.
THE THE A NEW REPORT TALK OF A A
MORE EFFECTIVE CPUC THE WORD
SENATOR THINKING NOT EXPAND I
LEAST I WASN'T.
MISTER BROWN CAN YOU ARE HELPING
I I MEAN I'M JUST JUST TO
REITERATE I THINK THAT I THINK
IS IS EVEN MORE IMPORTANT SORT
OF HIGHLIGHTS THE IMPORTANCE OF
KIND OF HAVING GOOD INFORMATION
AVAILABLE TO YOU AND KIND OF YOU
KNOW HAVING THEM REPORT BACK ON
WHAT OUTCOMES HAVE.
BEEN SHE'D HOW EFFECTIVE THEY
THEN AND IN A WAY THAT CAN
INFORM THESE TYPES OF BROADER --
DISCUSSIONS GOING FORWARD ABOUT
KIND OF HOW TO IMPLEMENT THESE
ACTIVITIES IN THE MOSTEFFECTIVE
WAY AND WE'RE WE'RE TO PUT THEM.
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THE MATTER SO I
CAN GET TWENTY FOUR HOURS TO
THINK ABOUT IT.
ENTER MCGUIRE HAVE QUESTION
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR I'M GONNA FOCUSING
ON THE THREE MILLION FOR ONGOING.
DISTRUST AFTER OVERSEE THAT
UTILITY POWER SHUT OFF.
NO THE PC'S REACTING TO WHAT THE
DIRECTION HAS BEEN AND JUST
BEING VERY CANDID ABOUT THIS.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S BEEN ANY
COUNTING THE CITY CALIFORNIA'S
BEEN IMPACTED BY THE BATTERY
POWER SHUT OFF.
MORE THAN THE COUNTY OF LAKE
[inaudible]
IN.
ALL DUE RESPECT TO NOT AT ALL
TRYING TO THROW STONES THE YOU
SEE THE LAST.
ORGANIZATION AN EMERGENCY
OFFICIALS.
HOW TRAINS ARE GOING TO CALL
ABOUT CHALLENGESWITH POWER SHUT
OFF TO THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION?
THE FIRST CALL WENT TO THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES IT
IS BEEN A HOT MESS.
ARE ALL LAST YEAR WHEN WE SAW
TWO SIGNIFICANT.
SHOT OFF BY P. JEANNIE LAKE
COUNTY.
THERE WAS ABSOLUTELY NO PLANNING.
THERE WAS NO PLAN FOR SIX
HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS ARE WHO WERE
ON MY SUPPORT.
N. WITHIN HOURS OF THE POWER
BEING SHUT OFF.
THE GENIE REQUIRED THE SHERIFF'S
OFFICE.
I DO GO CONSULTER TURNING TO BE
ABLE TO GET THE HEALTH RECORDS
OF THOSE SIX INTERNET VIGILS
THAT WERE SOON GONNA LOSE THEIR
POWER.
SO.
I OFFICE EMERGENCY SERVICES.
IT WAS THE ONE THAT THEY CALLED
TO BE ABLE TO ASSIST.
IN WHO ARE STAFF.
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN SO IF THIS IS
AN ISSUE OF OVERSIGHT AND
UTILITIES.
OKAY.
BUT WHERE I HAVE CONCERNS IS IN
THAT REAL TIME ISSUE AND WHY
WERE PUT IN THIS MONEY.
INTO THE PUBLIC UTILITIES.
THERE IS GOING TO NEED TO BE.
FOCUS ON THAT REAL TIME ISSUE I
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT WERE GOING
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT AND I
COULD HEAR FROM DEPARTMENT
FINANCE AND IF YOU.
DO YOU SEE ON THIS AS WELL.
IF I MAY M..
JUST ADD SOMETHING OF WHEN THIS
HAPPENED LAST YEAR IN FULL HOME.
I FLEW TO SACRAMENTO ON THE
SUNDAY AND WAS AT YES AT THE
REQUEST BECAUSE OVER YES DOES
NOT HALL OF IN DEPTH EXPERTISE
ON UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE.
HOME AND THEY WANTED THE LIAISON
IN THE WE ELSE THAT CAN WORK
WITH UTILITIES AND HOLD ON
ANALYZE THE INFORMATION THAT THE
UTILITIES WERE GIVING.
THE FOR EXAMPLE THE UTILITIES
WOULD ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHAT DATED THE HELP OR DON'T
HELP OR CANNOT CANNOT SHARE.
AND WHERE THE PC ROLE COMES IN
IS THAT WE CAN EFFECTIVELY L.
ENGAGE IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS AND
MAYBE.
EL.
SUPPORT WE US WHEN THE TRYING TO
GET CERTAIN INFORMATION OR
PROVIDE THEM INFORMATION ABOUT.
HOW THE UTILITY PROGRAM WAS
SUPPOSED TO WORK HOME SO?
IN MY EXPERIENCE.
IS THAT WE S. ONCE THE PC
PRESENCE IN THERE AND RIGHT NOW
WE ARE HOME WE HAVE BEEN MEETING
VERY REGULARLY WITH THE BUT ALL
OF THAT WORK IS BEING DONE BY
MYSELF ANOTHER PROGRAM MANAGERS.
AS THE SORT OF IN ADDITION TO
OUR JOB FUNCTIONS AND THEN IN
JUST MY EXPERIENCE IT'S NOT
SUSTAINABLE ESPECIALLY IF WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO BE PRESENT THERE
FOR EVERY TIME THERE'S A P. S.
P. S. EVENTS.
SO I'M WORRIED THAT WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL STAFF FOR THE P. C.
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY
ENGAGE WITH -- YES ALTHOUGH I
ALSO SUPPORT HUMMING GIVING THEM
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR THIS
WORK.
WHERE THE CASE -- WOULD.
I FIT IN IN THE DISCUSSIONS WITH --
E. S. AND YOU SEE AN THE
CALIFORNIA BEFORE AT THIS IN THE
IN WHAT INFORMATION DO THEY
BRING THAT YOU DON'T HAVE AS FAR
AS YOU KNOW.
WEIRD THE BALLOT HOW THE
BALANCING IS WORKING IF THEY
TURN OFF THIS SECTION OF IT NOW
THEY RESTORE THAT WITH.
THEY CAN SEE SEEM AYE.
I UNDERSTAND THEY HAVE EXPERTISE
IN THIS THEY'RE IN CHARGE OF
THAT.
I'M SORRY WERE YOU ASKING ABOUT
THE ROLE OF THE CHI SO RIGHT THE
ROLE THE CHI SO -- COULD
CERTAINLY ENGAGES IN THE IN
WHERE IT'S IMPACTING
TRANSMISSION AND GRID
RELIABILITY SO MOST OF THESE
EVENTS OF THESE TO DATES.
EVEN THOUGH THEY HAVE A LARGE
IMPACT ON CUSTOMERS IT'S THE
DISTRIBUTION LEVEL SO IT
ACTUALLY DOESN'T INVOLVE THE CHI
SO.
ALL MY SO SO.
YOU KNOW WE'RE WE HAVE BEEN
ENGAGING WITH KAISER TO TALK
ABOUT SITUATIONS WHERE.
YOU ME HOW DO YOU ENERGY
SOLUTION EVENTS AT SCALE THAT
IMPACT TRANSMISSION BUT THAT
HASN'T BEEN EXPERIENCED YET I
MEAN WE WOULD STILL AS THE P.
YOU SEE ABOUT POINTS.
OUT NEED TO WORK WITH THE CHI SO
AND THE OF THE STATE PARTNERS
LIKE OR WE ASK TO SORT OF MANAGE
THE ODDS EL EVENTS.
OF BUT AGAIN IN THE MOST
SITUATIONS THE WITH TALKING
ABOUT WOULD YOU ENERGY STATION
CASE WAS ACTUALLY NOT IN ANY WAY
INVOLVED BECAUSE IT'S BELOW
TRANSMISSION.
OKAY AND YOU HAVE THE AS THE
STING PUSH FROM THE UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE IN GENERAL RIGHT
YOU JUST HAVE THE TRANSMISSION.
YES THE BECAUSE HE'S JUST THE IT
IT'S MANAGING THE GRADE LEVEL
RELIABILITY OF THE TRANSMISSION
LEVEL VERSES THE DISTRIBUTION
WIRES THAT ARE KIND OF DIRECTLY
TO CUSTOMER HOMES WHICH IS ON-THE UTILITY.
OPERATION THANK YOU CENTER MIGHT
REQUIRE INTERRUPTED.
JUST.
AND YOU I I KNOW IF YOU WANT TO
MENTION THAT I HAVE ONE LAST
QUESTION ON THIS ISSUE PLEASE.
THIS NOVEMBER THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET DOESN'T HAVE A GOOD
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION -- FOR YEAH
SO THIS IS THIS IS A A
COORDINATED -- EVERGLADES RELATE
TO POWER SHUT DOWN AND ALSO AS
SHE MENTIONED YOU SEE IS THERE
WITH -- YES WHEN THESE WHEN
THESE EVENTS ARE HAPPENING AND
HAS TO FILL THAT ROLE AS REGULAR
OF THE UTILITIES RELATED TO
INFORMATION.
I'M OF THE TOYS MAY HAVE IN
TERMS OF WHO IS ON PROGRAMS THAT
MIGHT INDICATE THAT THEY'RE ON
LIFE SUPPORT OR THIS KIND OF
THING SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT REGULATORY FUNCTION.
STILL CONTINUES AND WE ARE
SUCCESSFUL IN OUR POWER SHUT OFF
TO GET TO THE IN THE DISK IT'S
DOWN TO A LITTLE BIT OF A DEEPER
DIVE AND YOU ALL DON'T MIND.
BUT JUST OKAY I JUST CONFIRM.
SO.
PC WOULD BE THERE FOR SUPPORT.
BUT WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT IS
TH AT THE TIME OF THE EVENT SO
FOR EXAMPLE.
NO ONE THAT CALTRANS NOW.
THAT ALL THE STOP LIGHTS CAN BE
TURNED OFF.
ON HIGHWAY -- TWENTY THAT WAS.
ANOTHER.
HE SAID A HOT MESS THAT WE HAD.
SO I'M JUST TRYING TO LOOK FOR
WHO IS THE COORDINATING AGENCY.
AT THAT TIME AND THE THE ANSWER
NOW RIGHT.
THAT WE'RE GOING INTO THIS NEW
ISSUE OF THE ENERGY DE ENERGIZE
ATION.
DURING RED FLAG EVENTS I JUST
WHO'S GONNA BE COR NAME TO MY
UNDERSTANDING.
YOU SEE WOULD BE IN THE MORNING
CENTER AT THAT TIME.
INDOOR -- ROUTE PROVIDING
INSULATION PORT ON THE UTILITY
SIDE.
BY -- YES WOULD STILL BE THE ONE
THAT WOULD BE OVERSEEN -- ISSUES
THAT TIME UP.
EVEN BEN'S WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I ALSO ACTUALLY HAVE --
YES IN MY SAME AREA AND THE
ISSUE WILL BE HEARD IN SUB FIVE
IN SOME LEVEL OF DETAIL IN THE
NEXT COUPLE DAYS HERE BUT YES --
YES WILL BE THE ONE COORDINATING
AND THEY'LL HAVE YOU SEE A
NUMBER OF OTHERS OF COURSE IN
THE COMMAND CENTER TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT AND IMPORTANT THINGS
LIKE THAT BUT BUT ESTAS
COORDINATE THAT IN THE SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION -- IS GONNA BE
PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON TRYING TO
IDENTIFY WHERE WE HAVE GAPS IN
CRITICAL STATE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND NEED TO DO THINGS LIKE.
MAKE SURE I MEAN FOR EXAMPLE A
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA'S FIRE
STATIONS DON'T HAVE BACKUP POWER.
YEAH SO WE'RE GONNA BE ASSESSING
THAT KIND OF THERE'S A NUMBER OF
THINGS JUST LOOKING AT YEAH
POTENTIAL GRANTS TO LOCAL.
EMERGENCY RESPONSE COORDINATORS
FOR TAKING CARE OF ME WE WE TALK
ABOUT NATIONAL NEWSPAPER
ARTICLES ABOUT.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE CRITICAL OF
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT IN THEIR HOMES
AND STUFF AND WHAT WE WHAT WE DO
TO SUPPORT THAT KIND OF STUFF
AND YOU KNOW.
THAT AB THERE'S SOME SPACE THERE
NINETY HERE AND I THINK THAT'S
THE PIECE THAT WE NEED TO BE A
TO GET OUT IN FRONT OF THAT WE
SIMPLY ART AND I AM.
CONCERNED AS WE GO INTO THIS
SEASON WE'RE STILL NOT IN FRONT
OF IT AS THIS IS RELATIVELY NEW.
ESPECIALLY ON THOSE FOLKS WHO
ARE LIKE READING DEVICES THAT ON
THIS USE THE ISSUE WITHIN THE
AREA.
TAKE CENTER FOLKS HAD READING
DEVICES.
WITHIN LAKE AND THERE WAS NO
WARNING RIGHT TRYING TO BE A TO
GET IN FRONT OF THAT AND IF
THERE IS I A SENIOR CENTER THAT
IS ALSO BACK TUITION SENATORS
HAVE BACKUP POWER.
WHAT HAPPENED THAT'S JUST THAT
THE PEACE I APPRECIATE THE
CLARIFICATION THAT IS WHAT IT --
YES WORKING ON BOARDING AND
SCREEN WHAT IS ONE OF THE I. O.
U.'S DOING WATER YOU KNOW
DIFFERENT SHE'S GOING TO WEAR
THE GAPS AND YES A LOT OF
COORDINATION ON WORK GOING ON
RIGHT NOW TO TALK THEIR SPONSOR.
PARTY'S BIGGER OUT HOW WE GET
AHEAD OF THIS AND YES WE CAN IT
IS A FAIRLY NEW THING IN TERMS
OF THE SCALE THAT WE'RE GONNA.
HAVE TO APPRECIATE COVERAGE
THANK YOU SO MUCH IT'S ONE OF
THOSE BUDGET MYSTERY WHY.
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE DOESN'T HAVE --
YES BUT WE HAVE THE HIGHER TROLL
YES.
BUT ANOTHER.
THERE ARE CERTAIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN SORRY
FOR MISSING THE BEGINNING YOUR
PRESENTATION.
BUT WE WATCHED YOU ON THE
INTERNET AND PEOPLE ARE WATCHING
WITH RAPT ATTENTION.
THANK -- THIS WAS ONCE A ONE KEY
ISSUE AND NOW IT'S VERY REAL SO
I JUST WANT TO GET A SENSE.
FROM THE TWO ISSUES ON I'M SORRY
IF I MISSED IT BUT ON THE
ENFORCEMENT SIDE.
A LITTLE BETTER SENSE OF BUT THE
P. UC'S PLANNING ANOTHER.
LOOKING AT THIRD PARTY.
ENFORCEMENT FRAMEWORK SOME OF
THOSE POSITIONS  JUST WANTED TO
GET A LITTLE BETTER SENSE OF
WHAT. NINE OH ONE ENFORCEMENT IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO LOOK LIKE WHAT
YOU'RE PLANNING FOR THAT.
W. M. P. A FORTUNE PROCESS AND
THEN ALSO ON THIS.
YES P. S. BACKUP POWER ISSUE WE
DONE A NEEDS ASSESSMENT.
A WIDE O WHAT THE TOTAL.
NEED IS FOR QUOTE ON QUOTE
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE HOW ARE
WE DEFINING AND I GUESS.
HOW FAR ALONG HIS SEVENTY FIVE
GET US?
AND WE'RE ALSO GONNA FIND THE
REST.
JUST MAYBE THIRTY THAT FIRST AND
THEN COME BACK TO THE
ENFORCEMENT ONE WE DOING.
YEAH NO I THINK I'D EVEN
CANDIDLY -- THIS IS A RELATIVELY
NEW IN IN BIG THING AND SO I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE HAVE ALL OF
THAT.
OUT YET -- AND A BIG PART OF
THIS EFFORT IS GONNA BE FIGURING
OUT WHAT ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT
GAPS BILL AND I THINK SOME OF IT
IS FIGURING OUT WHICH AREAS
WHICH REGIONS TO THINK YOU'RE
GOING TO BE.
THE MOST HIT BY IT.
I MEAN SURELY. THIRTY FIVE
MILLION IS NOT GONNA GO PROBABLY
GO YOU KNOW TO FILL LITERALLY
EVERY SINGLE GAP WE CAN
IDENTIFIES WITH THE OBVIOUSLY
WE'RE GONNA BE TARGETING KIND OF
PRIORITIES AND THINGS LIKE THAT
AND I I THINK JUST CANDIDLY
SPEAKING WE'RE WE'RE STILL
FIGURING OUT.
YOU KNOW SOME OF OF WHERE THIS
NEEDS TO GET FOCUSED THIS IS IN
PART OF THAT THAT THIRD PRONG
THE THIRTEEN MILLION THAT VISION
THING THAT.
UC'S COULD BE DOING ON YOUR ROAD
MAP IS THAT BECAUSE HE'S TALKING
ABOUT [inaudible]
THE PLAN.
IS THAT THE THERE'S THREE PARTS
HERE. TWENTY FIVE THIRTEEN AND
THREE SAID THIRTEEN IS FOR THIS.
THE VISION YOU SEE VISION.
I THINK ALL THOSE PARTS ARE
DEFINITELY RELATED THE THIRTY
MILLION IS FOR THE TWO ONE
DEVELOPING THE VISION FOR HOW WE
GOING TO SYSTEMATICALLY REDUCE.
THE RISK OF WILDFIRE FROM
ELECTRIC INFRASTRUCTURE AND THEN
THE FALL OF THE AN EVALUATION
FRAMEWORK FOR WELFARE MITIGATION
PLANS AS WELL AS CLOSE SOME OUT
GAPS THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE IN
STANDARDS AND BEST PRACTICES.
THANK THE ENERGY SOLUTION CAN BE
PART OF ITS -- BECAUSE IT IS ONE
OF THE TOOLS THE UTILITIES ARE
USING I THINK WE WERE GOING INTO
THE POLICY QUESTION AS TO HOW
MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES MORE
RESILIENCE.
AND HOW MUCH IS THE STATE'S WE
SHOULD BE BASICALLY INVESTING IN
SO ALLOWING THEM TO ALL RIGHT
OUT.
LOSS OF POWER WHETHER IT'S A
PROACTIVE POWER SHUT OFF WERE --
OTHER EVENTS I THINK THAT IS
PROBABLY IT ABOVE AND BEYOND THE
SCOPE OF THE THIRTEEN MILLION
THAT LEAST AS ENVISIONED IN THIS
MAY.
REVISE AND YOU KNOW THE ONLY
THING I'D SAY ON THAT IS THAT
THE STAFFING THAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR THE P. YOU SEE.
IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE NEED
STAFF TO BE WORKING ON THOSE
QUESTIONS TO BE WORKING WITH --
WE ELSE OUGHT TO COME UP WITH
HOW DO WE THINK ABOUT THIS FROM
A POLICY PERSPECTIVE AND HOW DO
WE SIZE THE COST OF THIS AND HOW
YOU PRIORITIZE IT AND UNLESS WE
HAVE STAFF CAN BE DEDICATED TO
AT HOME.
IT'S GOING TO BE VERY DIFFICULT
TO MAKE.
GET ANSWERS TO THOSE TO THOSE
QUESTIONS.
WHEN I WHO WE SAW IN THIS FIRST
ROUNDOF WILD FIRE MITIGATION
PLANS IT JUST CAME FORWARD?
WAS VERY LIGHT.
ON D. E. R. ON DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY RESOURCES I MEAN WE SAW A
LOT OF VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
WHICH WILL WILL TALK ABOUT LATER
BUT VERY LITTLE ON SHOWING UP
NOT JUST EVEN CAL FIRE STATIONS
RIGHT BUT CRITICAL CIRCUITS OR
SENIOR CENTERS OR STOP LIGHTS OR
WATER PUMPS.
YOU WATER DISTRICTS THE THINGS
THAT.
SO.
WHAT DO YOU AND ARE THERE OTHER
TOOLS THAT WE HAVE IN OUR TOOL
KIT THAT?
THAT ARE JUST.
FROM THE GENERAL FUND THAT WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT HERE IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO TACKLE THIS
[inaudible]
YEAH.
YES I THINK THAT THE KING OF
GOES TO THE THE REQUESTED THE
CONSULTING SUPPORT. FOR THE THE
OVERALL VISION AND THE THE
EVALUATION FRAMEWORK FOR WELFARE
MITIGATION PLANS BECAUSE WE'RE
IN A LITTLE BIT OF THE L. EITHER
BRING THE IRAQ EXERCISE WITH
UTILITIES RIGHT NOW IS BE NINE A
ONE DAY A DAY OUT WE GET THE SET
A REALLY GOOD FOUNDATION WITH
DIRECTING.
UTILITIES TO HOW WHILE FIRE
MITIGATION PLANS BUT IT DIDN'T
SAY YOU KNOW.
HOW WITH THE STATE'S PRIORITIES
FOR MITIGATING WILDFIRES IN
THERE A LOT OF DIFFERENT OPTIONS
THERE'S ON THE GROUNDING THESE
USING CODED CONDUCTORS THERE'S
USING THE IMAGES ASIAN AND
PRODUCTS BUT WERE SHOT OFF IS A
RESOURCE?
IS MAKING COMMUNITIES MORE
RESILIENT DEPENDING ON
MICROGRAMS IS A LOT OF DIFFERENT
IDEAS OUT THERE AND WE CURRENTLY
COLLECTIVELY THE WEED THE STATE.
OF CALIFORNIA DOES NOT ACTUALLY
HOW OF A WAY TO SAY WHAT IS THE
RIGHT MIX AT THE STATE WHAT
LEVEL OF HOW MUCH WE SHOULD BE
INVESTING IN COMMUNITIES IN
TERMS OF DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
RESOURCES AND BUILDING MORE
MICRO GRIDS OR UNDER GROUNDING.
WERE YOU KNOW VARIOUS OTHER
THINGS SO MY VISION FOR WHAT WE
WOULD DO WITH WITH THE
CONSULTANT IS TRY TO EXCEL.
THE POLICY MAKING ASPECTS OF
THIS SO THAT WE CAN HAVE A
LITTLE BIT MORE OF A FRAMEWORK
AND HOW THE ABILITY TO SAY HOW
DO WE FIGURE OUT THE BALANCE OF
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE MAKING
ALL OF YOU KNOW ON THE GROUNDING
VERSES MORE DISTRIBUTED
GENERATION FOR EXAMPLE -- AND SO
AS ALL OF YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW I
THINK IT IS VERY DIFFICULT.
TO HANDLE OF PUSH EVEN BACK ON
THE UTILITY AND SAY YOU NEED TO
BE DOING SOMETHING MORE ALL OF
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THOSE
GOALS SET AS A STATE YET.
BEFORE I WRAP YOUR LA -- DID YOU
GUYS HAVE A GOOD JOB OF COMMON
JUST ON THE SCOPE OF NEED.
TRY TO GET YOUR HEADS WRAPPED
UNDER EVEN GIVING US.
I'M INSIDE ON EVEN DEFINING WHAT
IT WHAT IS A CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE.
HOW TO EVEN SCOPE THAT EVERY ALL
THOUGHT ABOUT?
I MEAN AT I GUESS I DON'T HAVE
THE A MINUTE WE I DON'T THINK
WE'VE DONE THAT TYPE OF ANALYSIS
I MEAN I I THINK IT'S A IT'S A
GREAT QUESTION IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU KNOW IT'S SOMETHING KIND OF
THE THE ADMINISTRATION IS
CONTINUING TO THINK ABOUT I MEAN.
I THINK I I GENERALLY AGREE WITH
SORT OF THE COMMENTS AND AND THE
NEED.
FOR THE WILDFIRE MITIGATION
PLANS THINKING THROUGH YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT ARE THE BEST OPTIONS
OUT THERE WHAT WHICH OPTIONS ARE
ACTUALLY REDUCING THEM THE
GREATEST AMOUNT OF RISK AT THE
LOWEST POSSIBLE COST AND THAT'S
LIKELY GOING TO BE A DIFFERENT
ANSWER AND DIFFERENT SCENARIO SO
SORT OF YOU KNOW.
TRYING TO KIND OF HAVE A HAVE A
MORE KIND OF FEDERAL FRAMEWORK
FOR A KIND OF THINKING THROUGH
THOSE QUESTIONS IN EVALUATING
THOSE QUESTIONS WHICH CAN THEN
KIND OF INFORM.
JUST.
YOU KNOW ENHANCED OVERSIGHT OVER
WHAT UTILITIES ARE PROPOSING
ENHANCE GUIDANCE FOR THAT
THERE'S STILL A CHANCE TO EVEN
AMEND THE CURRENT LEASE
SUBMITTED W. MPS IS THAT CORRECT
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN APPROVED YET.
ALL THE PROPOSED DECISION HAS
MAILED WHERE RECEIVING COMMENTS
RIGHT NOW AND THE ALL THREE FOR
FOR ALL FOR ALL SIX YES THE
THREE MAJOR IN A SMALL AS WELL
AS OKAY.
SO NOT JUST THE THE THREE DAYS
OKAY YEAH.
EL ALL THERE'S A THEIR PROPOSED
DECISIONS OUT.
THE PROPOSED DECISION IS OUT OF
THE COMMISSION ANTICIPATES
ADOPTION BY THE END OF MAY.
ELEMENT THE MAIN THING THAT WERE
ABLE TO ACHIEVE A THING WITH
THIS FIRST ROUND OF WELFARE
MITIGATION PLAN TO SEND THE
REALLY GOOD BASELINE.
ALL IN ONE OF THE THINGS OF THE
COMMISSION IS DIRECTING
UTILITIES TO DO IS TO PUT
PERFORMANCE MEASUREMENTS IN
PLACE.
SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY START
GETTING A LOT BETTER DATA ABOUT
HOW EFFECTIVE THE DIFFERENCE ALL
PERFORMANCE MEASURES ARE BECAUSE
IF I WAS TO KIND OF SUM UP WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THIS FIRST ROUNDER
WELFARE MITIGATION PLANS.
SO IT IS JUST THROUGH EVERYTHING
AND THE KITCHEN SINK IN THERE
YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE ANY ANYTHING
THAT THEY COULD THINK OF TO
MAYBE GET WILDFIRES AS PART OF
THIS PLAN.
ALL UNITS DIFFERENT YOU KNOW THE
ROLE DIFFERENT BUT IT'S SORT OF
EVERYTHING IS IN THERE AND YOU
DON'T REALLY HAVE ANY WAY TO
EVALUATE YOU KNOW WHAT IS YOU
KNOW WHAT IS REALLY A GOOD MIX
OF THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS
HAVE A BASELINE FROM THIS FIRST.
YEAR AND GET WILL REALLY MUCH
BETTER AT MEASURING PERFORMANCE
AND THEN MY HOPE IS THAT WE CAN
WITH SOME SUPPORT FROM
CONSULTANTS.
ARE TALKING ABOUT THE WHAT LONG
TERM ROADMAP ENVISIONED START
DEVELOPING BETTER VALUATION
FRAMEWORKS THEY'RE GIVING MORE
DIRECTION SO UTILITIES WILL
REALLY DRIVING THE BUSES THE
STATE AND NOT JUST REACTING. TO
THEIR PROPOSALS AND THEN CAME OF
IT A RATE THE RULE AND AND HOW
OF GIVE THE MORE DIRECTION OF
WHAT WE THINK WE WANT THEM TO DO
FOR NEXT YEAR AS YOU CAN TELL BY
THE DISCUSSION THAT WE'VE HAD TO
SING THIS LITTLE.
ITALY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE THAT
IT REALLY BEGS THE QUESTION THAT
THIS IS AN INTERDISCIPLINARY.
COLLABORATION AMENDED TO SAY
THAT P. C. P. YU SEE.
THIS COULD BECOME A MORE
EFFECTIVE CPU.
YOU SEE AND DO THIS YOU GOT CAL
FIRE YOU GOT OH YES WE'VE GOT
ALL THE OTHER PEOPLE THERE AND
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
WHAT OUR WAREHOUSES?
A SYMPHONY GOING ON WHAT IS WHAT
IS CAL FIRE JUNE WHAT'S THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOING HOW
DOES ALL THAT.
ARE WILDLIFE MITIGATION WHAT ARE
THE COUNTY IS DOING A CITY SAID
IN FORCE THESE YOU KNOW
PARDONING OF OF THEIR THEIR
PLACES HOW DOES THAT GO AND I
AGAIN.
IF EVERYBODY GETS INTERVENOR
STATUS AND THEY CAN BILL BEFORE
THE CPUC THEY'LL WORK OUT I GOT
SOME CONCERNS WITH ALL WE'VE
WE'VE RAISE THEM -- IT ALLOWS
YOU TO SAY IS I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THE TIME ON AN APPROVAL
BECAUSE EVEN IF YOU APPROVE IT
AND GREAT TO GO AND DO A BUNCH
OF VEGETATION MANAGEMENT FIND.
THE LIGHTS GO OFF FOR A WEEK ON
END IN VARIOUS COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE STATE FOR THE REST OF
THE YEAR.
AND WHILE WE'RE DEVELOPING HIS
VISION.
YEAH WE'RE GONNA HAVE A SERIOUS
PROBLEM ON OUR HANDS SO HOW HOW
DO WE EXECUTE COMING IN THIS
BUDGET DOES IT NEED A PAUSED WE
ACTUALLY TO WAIT TO GET IT RIGHT.
YEAH I I DON'T SEE THE WHOLE
KITCHEN SINK IN THOSE PLANS
ACTUALLY SEE.
JUST A LACK OF VISION THE YOU
KNOW WITH.
AND THAT'S NOT THE SHOWN YOU
THAT WE WE NEED SOMETHING
COHERENT BUT BUT WE WE CANNOT
GET THROUGH ANOTHER SEASON -- IN
THE DARK HERE SO.
I'M WE'RE GAME TO AUTHORIZE MORE
STORY I MEAN I I I'M I'M
STANDING WILLING LIKE I KNOW
THAT MALIBU FOR INSTANCE WHO CAN
AFFORD TO PAY MORE.
WILL PAY A LOT MORE. TO GET
THROUGH P. S. P. S. SO CALABASAS
INTEGRATE ALL THESE THERE IS THE
CAN AFFORD IT ALSO THE LAKE
COUNTY LAWYERS CAN'T AFFORD.
RIGHT SO TO HOW TO TACKLE THAT
BUT IN POWER THOSE WITH
FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO GO OUT
PROTECT THEMSELVES AND I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S TERRACE DESIGNS
BUT THAT'S OTHER EXPEDITED
APPROVALS ON INTERCONNECTION OF
SPORT DR RESOURCES.
IS RUN IN A BUNCH OF DIESEL FUEL
THE BACK OF FRIENDS PICK UP
TRUCK TO GET TRY TO GET THE
URGENT CARE CENTER BACK ONLINE
SO I CAN GET MY FRIEND A TETANUS
pFIRES LIKE.
THAT IN A GOOD PLAN FOR FOR
DOING THIS POLICY SO LIKE
THERE'S WE CAN DO THIS THIS YEAR
WELL YOU DEVELOP THAT VISION SO
WE WANT TO WORK WITH YOU GUYS ON
THAT AND REALLY DIG IN HERE BUT
I THINK.
IT'S WE DON'T WANT TO OVER
SUBSIDIZE ALSO THOSE WHO CAN
AFFORD IT BUT IF YOU WE HAVE ONE
RATE STRUCTURE STATE WHAT RIGHT
SO IT'S IT'S SORT OF AN AWKWARD --
ANY ARE THANK YOU FOR THE IN
THOSE MISTER CHAIR LT'S OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC HEARING THIS IS A
MATTER THAT WE'RE GONNA HOLD
OPEN OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
AND ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN PART A
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
TEEN THEN WILL CLOSE.
WE'LL CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING.
SOME WORK TO DO HERE LOCAL WELL
WE'RE ALL STAFF RECOMMENDATION
HOLDEN MATTER OPEN.
NOW LET'S LOOK OVER HIS LIFELINE
PROGRAM THIS IS.
ISSUE A WITH THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION
[inaudible]
THIS IS.
HOW DID YOU GUYS GET THIS
LIFELINE PROGRAM?
WHY IS THIS LIFELINE PROGRAM IN
THE C. P. U. C.?
BUT GO AHEAD YOU HAVE A
PRESENTATION.
GOOD GOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M HERE TO
PRESENT THE REQUEST FOR FISCAL
YEAR. TWENTY NINETEEN FOR
FUNDING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LIFELINE PROGRAM.
AND I CAN EITHER PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW WE CAN MOVE DIRECTLY TO
QUESTIONS WHICH IS YOUR
PREFERENCE.
UNDER AN OVERVIEW.
SEEKING FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FOUR MILLION FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLAR PROCREATION FOR THE
LIFELINE PROGRAM FOR FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AN
INCREASE OF SIXTEEN POINT 4% ON
THE APPROPRIATION APPROVED IN
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT.
IN COMPARING THE MAY REVISION TO
THE NOVEMBER ESTIMATE.
LOCAL ASSISTANCE ESTIMATE
INCREASES BY EIGHTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS BECAUSE OF TWO
FACTORS GROWTH AND PARTICIPATION.
IN ADDITION A PILOTS OF THE
COMMISSION RECENTLY APPROVED.
THE STATE OPERATIONS ESTIMATE
INCREASES BY APPROXIMATELY FOUR
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS.
IS DRIVEN BY OUR REGION MARKING
THE ELEMENTS OF THE PILOTS THAT
WILL BE OCCURRING IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY LA -- DO
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON THIS
PROPOSAL OR THE MORE.
UNIVERSAL TELEPHONE SERVICE ACT
OF NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR HELP US
OUT.
OF IF IT'S OKAY WITH THE CHAIR
MIGHT OFFER JUST A FEW COMMENTS
WE ACTUALLY ISSUED A REPORT
RELATED TO THIS PROGRAM EARLY
LAST MONTH.
TALK QUICKLY JUST KIND OF RUN
THROUGH SOME OF THE KEY ISSUES
SO THAT THE REPORT WAS.
INCLUDED AS ESTARá LAST YEAR
REQUIRING OUR OFFICE TO LOOK AT
A COUPLE ASPECTS OF THE PROGRAM
ONE IS JUST THE BUDGETING AND
THE FORECASTS FOR THE BUDGET
GOING FRWARD AND SO.
ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE FOUND IS NOW
IN THE PAST THERE'S BEEN QUITE A
FEW CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH
FORECAST IN THE BUDGET FOR THIS
PROGRAM.
LARGELY RELATED TO THE EXPANSION
TO INCLUDE THE WIRELESS AND A
LOT OF THE UNCERTAINTY RELATED
TO HOW MANY PROVIDERS ARE
PARTICIPATING WHAT CASELOAD IS --
IN THE END WHAT WE THINK THE
ESTIMATES ARE IMPROVING IN THAT
TO YOU SEE HAS BEEN DOING A MUCH
BETTER JOB RECENTLY BUT THERE
CONTINUES TO BE A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY AROUND THE
SUSTENANCE AND SO.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THE ESTIMATES THAT ARE INCLUDED
IN THIS BUDGET BUT JUST WANTED
TO THE FLAG THAT AND THAT ISSUE
FOR YOU AND THERE'S CONTINUE
UNCERTAINTY AND THERE IS SOME
LANGUAGE IN THERE THAT PROVIDES
THE ADMINISTRATION SOME
FLEXIBILITY TO ADJUST IF.
IF COSTS -- INCREASE BEYOND THE
ESTIMATED AMOUNT.
THE OTHER ISSUE WITH -- WE WERE
ASKED TO LOOK AT WAS JUST THE
GENERAL ENROLLMENT PROCESS AND
POTENTIAL PROBLEMS AND GETTING
ELIGIBLE HOUSEHOLDS TO ENROLL IN
THE PROGRAM.
AND JUST FOR CONTEXT RIGHT NOW --
ROUGHLY 40% OF THE ESTIMATED
ELIGIBLE POPULATION ISN'T IS
ACTUALLY ENROLLED IN THE PROGRAM --
AND WHAT WE FOUND IS THERE'S A
WIDE VARIETY OF POTENTIAL
REASONS FOR THAT -- INCLUDING
ONE THAT.
HOUSEHOLD MIGHT JUST BE UNAWARE
THAT THEY ARE ACTUALLY ELIGIBLE
FOR THE PROGRAM AT THE PROGRAM
EXISTS. TO THEY MIGHT PER -- FOR
SOME OTHER KERRIER PLAN -- ONE
THAT'S NOT PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM AND THEN THREE THERE
MIGHT BE.
AREAS CHALLENGES RELATED TO IF
THAT EVEN IF THEY KNOW THE
PROGRAM ACCESS AND WANT TO
ENROLL A GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF IN ROMAN AND RENEWALS --
UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S NOT A LOT
OF GREAT INFORMATION ABOUT WHICH
OF THESE FACTORS ARE KIND OF THE
PRIMARY DRIVER AND THE CURRENT
ENROLLMENT RATES AND SO WE WOULD
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE DIRECT
THE PC TO CONDUCT.
AN EVALUATION ESSENTIALLY KIND
OF A SURVEY OF ELIGIBLE
HOUSEHOLDS TO GET A BETTER SENSE
OF WHAT THE PRIMARY BARRIERS ARE
TO ACTUALLY ENROLL IN THE
PROGRAM.
IN THE MEANTIME THE THE
LEGISLATURE MY ONE DIRECT YOU
SEE ONE OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
WAS DIRECT THEM TO CONDUCT SOME
PILOTS AND KIND OF EXPLORING
SOME OF THE SOME POTENTIAL
CHANGES THAT MIGHT ADDRESS SOME
OF THE PROBLEMS.
THIS PROPOSAL DOES INCLUDE SOME
FUNDING FOR A PILOT THAT HAS
BEEN ADOPTED BY THE COMMISSION
AND WE THINK THAT'S GENERALLY A
STEP IN ASK THE COMMISSION ABOUT
HOW IT PLANS TO EVALUATE THAT.
PILOT IN ORDER TO KINDA ATTAIN
INFORMATION THAT CAN CAN HELP
INFORM YOUR YOUR DECISIONS ABOUT
ANY CHANGES GOING FORWARD TO TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE SOME OF THE
POTENTIAL PROBLEMS.
YOU SEE HOW DO YOU PLAN TO
EVALUATE THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE OHIO.
WE HAVE A CURRENT PROCEEDING
BEFORE THE COMMISSION AND MANY
OF THE ISSUES THAT THE OTHER WAS
RAISED ARE ALSO OCCURRING IN
THAT ARE BEING DISCUSSED IN THE
PRECEDING.
WITH REGARDS TO THE PILOTS WERE
EXPLORING TWO OUT OF TWO
DIFFERENT PILOTS HAS BEEN
APPROVED AND THREE MORE PILOTS
THAT ARE UNDER EVALUATION.
AND THE TOTAL OF THE UNIVERSE OF
PILOTS LOOKS AT MANY OF THE
ISSUES THAT HAS BEEN RAISED BY
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WE'RE LOOKING AT STREAMLINING
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATION
PROCESS OF SIGNING UP FOR THE
PROGRAM WE'RE LOOKING AT
IMPROVING THE RENEWAL PROCESS.
WERE LOOKING AT REACHING
UNSERVED OR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES.
ARE ALSO LOOKING AT ATTRACTING
OF PARTICIPANTS SERVICE
PROVIDERS IN THE PROGRAM WHICH
MAY HAVE MORE RECOGNITION.
WITH PARTICIPANTS IN THE PROGRAM
SO IT MAY BE MORE DESIRABLE
MAYBE THAT IS A MORE DESIRABLE
OPTION. TO THOSE OF THE MAIN
FACTORS THAT WERE ADJUSTING T
REPEL IT'S IN THE PRECEDING WERE
ALSO LOOKING AT OVERALL.
HOW DO STREAMLINED THE
ELIGIBILITY RENEWAL PROCESS?
HOW DO YOU DEAL WITH THEM THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE?
BEEN CANCELED FROM THERE --
SERVICE PROVIDER YOU KNOW THAT
NOT THE PEOPLE THAT JUST QUIT
THE PEOPLE THAT SAY IN A GIVEN
PAGER T. MOBILE OUR METRO OR
SPRINT BILL THEY DROP.
YOU GUYS GO CONTACT THOSE PEOPLE
AND FIND OUT IF THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE THIS LOWER PROGRAM I
MEANI'M JUST THINKING OF THE
UNIVERSE OF PEOPLE PEOPLE WHO.
AREN'T AREN'T SOME FORMER JUST
DEDICATED ON PETER FROM DON'T
GOT IT BUT SOME PEOPLE JUST MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO AFFORD IT IS THAT.
AN IDEA THAT YOU GUYS KICK
AROUND AT THE CPUC.
THAT'S NONE IDEA WEAVER OR
DIRECT EXPLAINED OR HAPPY TO
EXPLORE THAT.
BECAUSE THEY LOSE THEIR SERVICE
I MEAN THEY'RE THEY'RE GAY THEY
GOT THEY CAN'T PAY THEIR BILL
AND THAT WOULD BE.
AT THE LEAST YOU THINK MAYBE
THEY NEED LIFELINE.
ALL RIGHT -- THIS IS.
CENTER JONES QUESTION.
YOU HAVE THE NUMBERS ON HI HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE CURRENTLY ON THE
PROGRAM.
AND IF YOU GET THE APPROVED
ALLOCATION HOW MANY EXPECT -- TO
IT TO A TO EXPAND.
TO WE CURRENTLY HAVE
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS PER
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM.
AND THE TWO PILOTS TOGETHER WILL
ADDED APPROXIMATELY UP TO
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
HOUSEHOLDS.
SO JUST SLIGHTLY OVER TWO
MILLION BUT NEVER TONIGHT YES
OKAY THANK YOU.
THIS IS THE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO BE APPROVED
AS BUDGETED WITH AN EYE TOWARDS
THE PREVIOUS MEASURE OF LOOKING
FOR A MORE EFFECTIVE C..
P. UC WELL WITH THE TOOLS TO
MANAGE A CHANGING UNTIL THE
MARKET SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT YOUR
CHARGE WE'RE ALL COULD BE
LOOKING AT IT NOW.
LET'S OPEN THE PUBLIC HEARING
ANYBODY HAS A COMMENT ON
LIFELINE.
PROGRAM CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING
CAROLINE RETAINER.
MOTION THERE'S A MOTION BY
SENATOR MINING TO APPROVED --
THE REQUESTED BUDGET PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
BY KELSEY HI JONES.
WIRE MONNING.
STERN.
I WILL KEEP THAT MATTER OPEN --
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT THANK YOU FOR
THAT CONVERSATION WITH THAT.
THE P. YOU SEE ON THE BUDGET
REQUEST.
AT NOW LET'S GO.
OKAY NOW LET'S GO BACK TO THE OF
VOTE ONLY MATTERS AND THIS WOULD
BE ON PART A MOTION NUMBER ONE
THIS IS ISSUES ONE THROUGH.
SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE DAM
[inaudible]
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
STERN.
I CLOSE ROTELLA THE BOATS THE
EYES HAVE A FOUR TO ONE NOW
LET'S GO BACK TO MOTION NUMBER
TWO THIS IS IN PART A ISSUES
EIGHT THROUGH ELEVEN PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
STERN.
CLOSE ROLE TELLY VOTE THE AYES
HAVE IT.
FIVE ZERO NOW PART.
B. THIS IS MOTION NUMBER ONE
ISSUES ONE AND TWO FOR THROUGH.
FOURTEEN NINE THROUGH TWENTY ONE
CENTER JONES YOU HAVE A COMMENT.
YES I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE -- AT
THERE WAS SOME CONFUSION ON MY
END WHEN WE DID THIS PREVIOUSLY
THAT -- NUMBER TWO WAS REPEATED
IN BOTH MOTIONS I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THE NUMBER TWO IS
INCLUDED IN THE FIRST MOTION
[inaudible]
YES OKAY.
THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD [inaudible]
STANDING ON I'M STAYING ON THREE
CATCHES OUR EYE.
WITH THAT ON PART B. MOTION ONE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
STERN.
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU VOTE I SEVEN
FIVE ONE WITH MOTION NUMBER TWO
WHICH IS ISSUES.
THREE AND FIFTEEN THROUGH
EIGHTEEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS STERN.
ALL RIGHT THAT'S FOUR ZERO ONE
OF STANCHION -- LET'S BRING ON A
CAL FIRE.
THIS IS THIS IS POOR DUMB APART
A WHEN OUR MOVING TO PART BE AND
WE DID CAL EPA SO WITH THIS IS.
HELL FIRE IN THIS IS ISSUE
[inaudible]
NUMBER. TWENTY FOUR THIS IS
PROFESSIONAL FORESTER
REGISTRATION PROGRAM.
WELCOME MISTER PORTER.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR WACO SKI
MEMBERS OF OF THE COMMITTEE --
WELL -- THIS FIRST ITEM IS A
BOARD OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION ITEM -- JUST WANTED
TO SAY THAT.
CALIFORNIA OR IS VERY MUCH A
SUPPORTER OF THE BOARD AND OFTEN
WILL.
WILL EXPRESS SUCH AND IN DOING
SO I AM GOING TO PASS THE MIKE.
TO EXECUTIVE OFFER OFFICER DS.
GOOD AFTERNOON TERRA CASKEY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS MATT DS EXECUTIVE OFFICER WAS
STATE BOARD OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION.
THE BOARD IS A NINE MEMBER
GOVERNOR APPOINTED BOARD THAT
SPAN -- DELEGATE THE AUTHORITY
TO DEAL WITH THE DEVELOPMENT AND
MAINTENANCE OF POLICY REGULATION
AS IT PERTAINS TO FORCE FORESTRY
FORCE PRACTICE -- AS WELL AS
FIRE PROTECTION IN LAND USE
PLANNING ONE OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE -- THAT WILL BE
ADDRESSED TODAY.
HERE FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION IS
THE OFFICE FOR PERSONAL FORCES
REGISTRATION -- THE MATTER OF
CONSIDERATION AS A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR TRANSFER FROM
THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
LICENSE PLATE FINE TO THE OFFICE
OF FOR FOR PROFESSIONAL FORCES
REGISTRATION.
THAT PROGRAM WAS ON THE BOARD IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR LICENSING
REGISTERED PROFESSIONAL FORCES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- THE
REGISTERED PROFESSIONAL FOR SURE
COMMUNITY IS INDEED A LICENSED
PROFESSION VERY SIMILAR TO
SURVEYORS GEOLOGISTS.
ATTORNEYS SOMEONE AND SO FORTH
AND PLAYS A KEY ROLE IN --
PLANNING MITIGATING ASSESSING
ALL TYPES OF PROJECTS THAT OCCUR
WITHIN THE FORCE TO LANDSCAPE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I WAS SURPRISED BY THE STAFF
REPORT THAT THE NUMBERS OF
REGISTERED.
PROFESSIONAL FORESTERS IS
DECLINING GIVEN.
SO MUCH ATTENTION THAT WE KNOW
COMPLETE.
PAID TO CAL FIRE INTO THIS THIS
INDUSTRY CAN YOU HELP ME
UNDERSTAND WHY THAT IS.
ARE THERE IS A LOT OF MOVING
PARTS AS IT RELATES TO THAT ARE
THE PROGRAM'S BEEN EXISTENCE IS
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE AND IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE
APPROXIMATELY SIXTEEN HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS WERE.
GRANDFATHERED IN TO THE PROGRAM
SINCE AFTER TO TALK AND MANY OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WORKED WITH
AND FORCE OF LANDSCAPES THAT ARE
FEDERALLY.
MANAGED.
OVER THE COURSE OF TIME IT'S
BEEN DETERMINED THAT THE LICENSE
DOESN'T REALLY IS NOT A
NECESSITY ON FEDERAL LANDSCAPES
THEREFORE WE HAVE LOST.
SOME OF THE INTEREST AS IT
RELATES TO US FOR SERVICE
EMPLOYEES ONE TO BECOME LICENSED.
WHAT IS INDIVIDUALS OF ALSO
RETIRED AND SO -- ANSWERING AS
THE AS RETIREMENT RATE HAS
INCREASED THE LEVEL OF INTEREST
IS NOT -- HAS NOT KEPT UP WITH
THAT.
CHALLENGE RIGHT NOW WE'RE
LOOKING AT STRATEGIC WAYS TO
COUNTY INCREASE THE LEVEL OF
OUTRAGE THAT WE CAN.
TAX RATE AS A BOARD TO TRY TO
ENGENDER HIGHER RIGHT HIGHER
RATES OF INTEREST IN THE
PROFESSION.
AS SOON AS I MEAN WE'VE WE'VE
DONE THAT AS A COURSE OF ACTION
BUT WE NEED TO REALLY PICK UP
THE PACE WE REALISE ADAM WE PLAN
ON DOING THAT -- HERE SOON BUT
WE NEED TO BE VERY STRATEGIC
ABOUT THE WAY WE GO ABOUT IT.
LA -- YOU HAVE A COMMENT.
OKAY THIS IS A THIS IS PROPOSED
TO BE APPROVED AS OUR THIS IS
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION TO IS
TO APPROVE IT AS PROPOSED LET'S
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING ON
THIS IS.
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE
LICENSE PLATE.
OF FUND FOR THE OFFICE OF
PROFESSIONAL FORESTERS RIGHT
REGISTRATION.
CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING.
SEEING THE QUESTIONS FROM THE
DAY AS THE CAROLINE ARCANA
MOTION.
THERE'S A MOTION BY CENTER
REQUIRE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MY CASKEY I JONES.
MCGUIRE.
MONNING.
STERN.
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU VOTE I SEVEN
FIVE ZERO ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY FIVE THE C. ONE THIRTY
FEDERAL AIR TANKER [inaudible]
TRAINING PLATFORM.
THANK YOU CHAIR WHY KELSEY AGAIN
TOM PORTER -- CAL FIRE DIRECTOR --
THIS IS ENHANCE FIRE PROTECTION
MAY REVISION C. ONE THIRTY AIR
TANKERS [inaudible]
AND OF CAL FIRE IS TO BE IS
REQUESTING FOUR POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS -- EIGHT IN
NINETEEN TWENTY FISCAL YEAR OF
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS -- AS WELL
AS A FOUR POINT SIX IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWO POINT.
TWO IN DOLLARS IN [inaudible]
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO THIS
REQUEST.
HI IS FOR A IS TO FIND THE C.
ONE THIRTIES -- AS A TRIO EIGHT
AC ONE THIRTY AS A TRAINING
PLATFORM -- FOR CRUISE BETWEEN
THE FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY
AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO OF THE
PILOTS WILL COMPLETE THEIR
TRAINING TO FLY THE THE C. ONE
THIRTIES THE SEVENTY ONE THIRTY
IS THAT -- WE ARE ARE GOING TO
START TAKING RECEIPT OF IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO OR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE I'M SORRY -- TO
FISCAL YEAR AND PART OF THE
ISSUE IS -- WE WE DIDN'T EXPECT
THAT WE WERE GOING TO HAVE THIS
PERIOD OF TIME WAITING TIME --
WE EXPECTED WE WERE GONNA HAVE
THE FIRST ONE READY TO FLY AND
NINETEEN TWENTY AND THAT'S GOING
TO TAKE SOME TIME AND THROUGH
THE PROCESS OF OF RECEIVING
THOSE THOSE -- AIR TANKERS FROM
THE AIRFORCE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT -- THEY HAVE TO BE
RETROFITTED TO BE ACTUAL AIR
TANKERS -- RIGHT NOW THEY ARE
THEY DON'T HAVE THE TANK SYSTEM
AND THE AND THE RETURN DELIVERY --
CAPABILITY OF AN AIR TANKER SO
THAT WILL HAVE TO BE DONE BEFORE
WE TAKE RECEIPT OF THOSE -- AND
IN THE INTERIM -- WE ARE SHORT
AND AIR TANKER THAT WE WERE
HOPING TO HAVE -- AS WELL AS WE
ARE SHORT PILOTS TO FLY THOSE
AIRCRAFT ONCE THEY COME ON LINE
IF WE DON'T START TRAINING THEM
NOW.
SO BETWEEN THOSE -- TWO THOSE
TWO NEEDS.
WE ARE ASKING AND AND THAT AND
THAT'S NEW BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
HAVE THE THE KNOWLEDGE THAT WE
WOULDN'T BE GETTING THOSE THOSE
AIR TANKERS WHEN WE WERE WHEN WE
WERE BUILDING OUR BUDGET REQUEST --
LAST FALL FOR THE JANUARY BUDGET.
A COUPLE OF OTHER ITEMS --
RELATED TO TO THIS -- WHAT I'LL
CALL A LARGER TANKER LATT?
WE CAL FIRE DON'T HAVE A LARGE
AIR TANKER IN OUR FLEET --
WITHOUT THIS.
THIS AIR TANKER -- THE SOME OF
THE REASONS THAT THAT'S
IMPORTANT GOING INTO -- THIS
COMING SEASON -- THE HEAVY GRASS
COURT CROP AND THE AS THAT
STARTS TO DRY WERE EXPECTING
THAT THAT WILL INCREASE FIRE
ACTIVITY -- TO AND THEN PASS
INTO THOSE -- BRUSH AND TIMBER
COVERED LANDSCAPES --
PARTICULARLY IN THE THE THE
CENTRAL SIERRA WE HAVE VERY
HEAVY LARGE FUELS THAT REQUIRE A
HEAVIER LOAD OF AIR TANKER.
DROP IN ORDER TO COAT THEM
PROPERLY AND AND REDUCE THE
SPREAD OF FIRE -- WE DO NOT HAVE
A LACK IN OUR ARSENAL OR R. R.
TO BAG OF TOOLS WITHOUT THIS WE
CAN CALL THEM UP FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
BUT OFTEN PARTICULARLY EARLY IN
THE SEASON THOSE AIR TANKERS ARE
IN OTHER PARTS OF OF THE NATION
FIGHTING FIRE.
ANOTHER ITEM THAT WE LEARNED --
JUST THIS MORNING ACTUALLY FROM
FROM -- ADJUTANT GENERAL BALD
ONE IS THAT ONE OF OUR MATHS --
CAPABLE SHIPS AND CREWS OUT OF
CHANNEL ISLANDS -- IS.
NOT A THEIR OUT OF THE OUT OF
COUNTRY ON DEPLOYMENT UNTIL LATE
IN THE SEASON END OF AUGUST IT
SOUNDS LIKE -- BEFORE THEY WILL
BE BACK AND READY TO TRAIN AND
GET THAT SHIP READY TO GO.
SO WE WILL BE DOWN ONE MASS
CAPABLE -- AIRCRAFT IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGH MOST OF THIS
OF THIS SEASON THAT THAT'S
THAT'S BRAND NEW INFORMATION WE
JUST FOUND OUT -- TODAY SO.
WITH THAT -- WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS TOOL IS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
TOOL FOR US THIS SEASON IN
PARTICULAR AND UNTIL WE HAVE.
THE PILOTS ON OUR OWN C. ONE
THIRTIES IN PLACE.
IT WILL SAVE LIVES AND PROPERTY.
WITH THE NEW CAPABILITY THAT
WHAT IT WILL BRING TO US.
ON THE PIECE BEFORE WE GET TO
THE LA L. THERE'S A PIECE THAT
THE TRAINING PIECE AND THEN
THERE'S THE MECHANICS TRAINING
PIECE OF A FOR LEASING.
SOMEBODY ELSE'S AIRPLANE THAT
WERE. FOR A YEAR BECAUSE WE'RE
WE'RE SHORT WE NORMALLY PAY FOR
THE TRAINING ON THE MECHANICS.
ON THAT I MEAN I I IF THEY WERE
OURS I WOULD IMAGINE THAT THAT
WOULD BE THE SAME BUT THE SAD.
IS THAT NORMAL.
I HAVE DEPUTY DIRECTOR -- TYLER
HERE TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY APOLOGIES THAT
I'VE BEEN COUGHING ALL DAY --
JOE TYLER DEPUTY DIRECTOR CAL
FIRE.
SO AT THE PRIMARY BENEFIT OF
HAVING A TRAINING PLATFORM IS
THE ABILITY TO TRAIN -- OUR
CURRENT PILOTS AS WELL AS FUTURE
PILOTS TO BE ABLE TO FLY THE C.
ONE THIRTIES.
AS A SECONDARY BENEFIT OF HAVING
THAT AIRCRAFT IN PLACE IT ALLOWS
THE VENDOR WHO'D BE PROVIDING
THE SOLE C. ONE THIRTY WITH
THEIR MECHANICS TO TRAIN OUR
DYNCORP MECHANICS IN THE
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE.
IT IS A SECONDARY BENEFIT AS
ANOTHER SECONDARY BENEFIT TO AS
DIRECTOR PORTER MENTIONED -- THE
SECOND -- RIP BENEFIT PROVIDES --
AN ACTIVE WILDLAND FIRE FIRE
FIGHTING C. ONE THIRTY TO THE
SYSTEM DROPPING FOUR THOUSAND
GALLONS RETARDED COMPARED TO THE
EIGHT HUNDRED TO TWELVE HUNDRED
GALLONS.
ARE AS TO DROP NOW.
YEAH I EIGHT I JUST GOT A
CONCERN WITH THE PLATFORM I
GUESS ON THE OUT YEARS IF YOU
THINK YOU NEED THREE YEARS TO
TRAIN THE MECHANICS AND THEN
YOU'RE DOING IT THIS YEAR WE'RE
NOT GONNA DO IT IN. TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE RIGHT
BECAUSE THERE'S ORIGINALLY WAS
WE ARE EXPECTING TO DO WITH THIS
AND THREE YEARS AND WORD WITH
DOWN WITH THAT PORTION.
ALEJO YOU HAVE SOME.
INCONCLUSIVE -- OBSERVATIONS --
JUST COMPUTERS AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
JUST TO REMIND THE COMMITTEE OF
THE CONTEXT OF THIS PROPOSAL
THIS IS IN ADDITION -- TO A
JANUARY PER BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT
WAS HEARD I'M ALMOST TWO MONTHS
AGO BY THE COMMITTEE FOR THREE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
THIRTEEN POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN. NINETEEN TWENTY
INCREASING TO FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS AT FULL IMPLEMENTATION FOR
THE ON THE SEVEN C. ONE THIRTY
PROGRAM SAID THIS WOULD BE THE
TRAINING PLATFORM ON TOP OF THAT.
JUST TO REMIND YOU OF THAT
CONTEXT AND THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS IN THE PROPOSAL AND THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ASSERTING THAT.
THIS AND FOUR POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN NINETEEN TWENTY IS
SOMEONE A CAUGHT ABOUT COST
NEUTRAL IN THAT THE DEPARTMENT
WOULD VERY LIKELY AND KERR AND
THE SAME OR EVEN POTENTIALLY
HIGHER COSTS -- TO HAVE A
CONTRACT PLANE BROUGHT ON BOARD
DURING PEAK FIRE SEASON -- WE
DID GET SOME BACK UP DATA FROM
THE DEPARTMENT ON THIS ASSERTION
AND IT'S SOMEONE INCONCLUSIVE ON
IN MANY YEARS IT APPEARS THAT
THE AMOUNT THAT WAS SPENT B THE
DEPARTMENT ON SORT OF A CALL WE
NEED A CONTRACT FOR THE PLANE
WOULD BE AVAILABLE ONLY FOR
THOSE FIRE.
FIGHTING NEEDS ANOTHER TRAINING
NEEDS -- IS GENERALLY LESS THAN
THE AMOUNT THAT SPENT HERE IN
SOME AREAS IT'S IT'S IN THE SAME
BALLPARK IN AND IN A FEW
INSTANCES IT WAS HIGHER -- AND
SO IT'S IT'S NOT ABUNDANTLY
CLEAR HOW MUCH SHE WOULD BE
SAVED AND THAT'S REALLY ALL
GOING TO DEPEND ON AND REALLY
WHAT THE FIRE FIGHTING NEEDS ARE --
IN THE UPCOMING FIRE SEASONS
OVER THE COURSE OF THIS CONTRACT
WHICH NO ONE CAN REALLY PROTECT.
ON BUT IT DOES APPEAR THAT THAT
AND THERE WOULD BE SOME
OFFSETTING SAVINGS I AM JUST
BASED ON WHAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS
INCURRED IN PAST YEARS -- FOR
CONTRACTING FOR THIS PEAK
SERVICES I'M IN TERMS OF USING
THIS AS A TRAINING PLATFORM FOR
THAT THE PILOTS AND THE
MECHANICS.
AND WE JUST THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS GONNA WANT TO
ALIGN YOUR ACTIONS ON THIS
PROPOSAL WITH THE LARGER SEE
WHEN -- THIRTY PROGRAM PROPOSAL
AND AND AND WITH ALL OF THOSE
ENHANCE FIREFIGHTING RESOURCES
IS WEIGHING THAT THE COSTS AND
BENEFITS OF OF THAT APPROACH THE
GOVERNOR'S LAID OUT -- WITH
OTHER OPTIONS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS AND YOU KNOW IN
IN PAST YEARS THE LEGISLATURE'S
WANTED.
TO PUT MORE INTO AND FOREST
HEALTH AND FIRE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES AND AND SO THIS WILL
BE ONE OF THOSE THINGS TO STRIKE
THAT BALANCE BUT YOU'RE YOU'RE
PROBABLY GONNA WANT TO THINK
ABOUT THIS ONE IN THE SAME
CONTEXT AS THE THE LARGER
PROPOSED. FOR FINANCED.
YOU CAME IN IN JANUARY TH WITH
THIRTEEN POINT ONE IF THERE'S A
CHANGE WHY NOT COME WITH THE
PROPOSAL NOW THAT SAYS CAN WE
HAVE AUTHORITY BUDGET AUTHORITY
TO TO ENTER TO USE SOME OF THIS
THIRTEEN POINT. ONE FOUR POINT
SIX TO DO THE LEAST DO THE
TRAINING AND ALL THAT TYPE OF
STUFF AND ON IN THE OUT YEARS ON
THE THIRD YEAR COME BACK FOR THE
THE FINAL.
PURCHASE PRICE OF THE C. ONE
THIRTIES BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
ALREADY WELL NONE OF ALREADY
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
YEAH I CAN I CAN SORT OF SEE TO
THAT -- I'LL SEND YOU A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I JUST
WANT TO NOTE THAT WALL AND
ESSENTIALLY WE ARE RECEIVING
THESE PLANES AND WE ARE PLANNING
ON OPERATING THEM SO I THINK IN
THAT IN THE ASSUMPTION IN TERMS
OF INCLUDING OUT YOUR FUNDING
WE'RE NOT.
ASSUMING THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
BE DOING THAT SO WE HAVE BUILT
IN THE OUT YOU'RE FINDING ON THE
ASSUMPTION THAT WE WILL HAVE THE
SEVEN PLANES THAT THAT YOU KNOW
WE WILL BE ABLE TO IT TO
UTILIZING DEPLOY AS AS I'VE FIRE.
FIRES WELFARE ACTIVITY OCCURS
I'M IN TERMS OF THE THREE YEARS
FOR THIS PARTICULAR EXCLUSIVE
USE CONTRACT THAT BATTLE LINES
UP WITH SORT OF WHEN THE PLANES
ARE GOING TO BE DELIVERED IN THE
NUMBER OF PILOTS THAT WERE
TRAINING EXCITER US SO.
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE IT'S
REASONABLE TO PROVIDE THE THREE
YEARS BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WILL
ULTIMATELY NEED TO TRAIN UP THE
TEN PILOTS WALL WERE RECEIVING
PLANES MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE
READY TO GO INTO OPERATION AND
APPOINT THEM [inaudible]
CENTER JONES.
YOU TELL QUESTIONS -- MAY BE OFF
TOPIC ALL OF IT SO MISTER
CHAIRMAN IF I GO TOO FAR --
EMAILING BACK.
OKAY WELL I WANT TO BE ON THE ON
THE TRAINING AND AND
SPECIFICALLY THE SEVEN TANKERS --
THAT WERE RECEIVING AT WHAT
WHAT'S THE SIZE OF THE FLIGHT
CREW ON THOSE PLANES.
THE TWO OR THREE OR FOUR IT IS A
PILOT COPILOT FLIGHT ENGINEER
OKAY IS THAT TRUE ON THE ISSUES
NOW.
YES TWO FLIES WITH A SINGLE
PILOT OKAY SO WE'RE GOING FROM
ONE PILOT FOR PLANED THREE
PILOTS FOR PLANE SO WE GOT WE
HAVE THREE PLANES.
HOW MANY CRUZ IS THAT IS THAT
FOURTEEN CREWS TWENTY ONE CREWS
AT?
OF THE SEVEN C. ONE THIRTIES UP
FIVE WILL BE IN SERVICE.
OF THOSE FIVE VETERANS SERVICE
KEEP THEM IN SERVICE.
OKAY SIR TO PER PLANE.
YES THEY CITY FLIGHT CREWS
PARKING PER PLANE AND SO TWENTY
PEOPLE.
ARE THAN THIRTY PEOPLE. THIRTY
PILOTS THAT WERE ARE THOSE.
PEOPLE ALREADY IN CALIFORNIA --
ARE WE RECRUITING THOSE THIRTY
PEOPLE WEAR THOSE THIRTY PEOPLE
COMING FROM.
SO IT'LL BE A MIX I CURRENTLY
OUR PROPOSED PLAN IS TO TRAIN
CURRENT AS TO INITIAL ATTACK
RATED PILOTS. TO FLY A C..
ONE THIRTY IN ADDITION TO THAT --
WE'RE HOPING OF THAT WE WILL
FIND -- SEE ONE THIRTY PILOTS
INTO THE FUTURE.
ACCURACY ONE THIRTY PASSES THE
RETIRING OR IN THE RESERVES.
WITH THEIR FORCES AIRFORCE ONLY
ONE THAT FLY SEE ONE THIRTIES
RIGHT NOW IT IS A ARMY NAVY FIND.
I BELIEVE ALL BRANCHES OF THE
MILITARY FLIES SEE ONE THIRTY AT
NOT WELL SOME FLY THE H. MODEL
THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY ASKING FOR
OTHERS ARE CURRENTLY FLYING J.
MODEL AND I WOULD ASSUME.
AND CORRECT ME IF I'M HOURS
FLYING IS C. ONE THIRTY AND FIRE
FIGHTING IS DIFFERENT THAN
FLYING IS C..
ONE THIRTY IN THE MILITARY.
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE A MILITARY
EXPERIENCE.
I CAN'T I CAN'T ANSWER THAT A
PROPERLY OF THE VAN -- FLYING
LOW LEVEL FLIGHTS OVER
VEGETATION IN FIRE CONDITIONS IS
A HIGH RISK -- INITIATIVE SURE
GO IT AYE AYE LET ME TO SAVE A
COUPLE WORDS FOR JOE'S VOICE.
REFER FOR OTHER QUESTIONS -- TOO
BUT WHAT WE ALSO ALREADY DO
TRAIN WITH THE NATIONAL GUARD A
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD
WYOMING -- THE REGULAR AIRFORCE
IN COLORADO AND THEN -- WILL
WITH A MOVED TO NEVADA BUT
ANYWAY THE WHICH WE ALREADY
TRAIN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD TO DO THIS
MISSION SO THEY HAVE SEVERAL OF
FLIGHT CREWS.
THAT HAVE GONE THROUGH THIS
TRAINING I DON'T KNOW THE EXACT
NUMBER -- BUT BUT WE DO HAVE
THAT CAPABILITY AND OUR
EXPECTATION IS AS CAL FIRE HAS
THIS -- PERMANENT WORK FORCE.
OPPORTUNITY THERE WILL BE --
SOME OF THOSE AIR TANKER PILOTS
THAT ARE ALSO MILITARY C. ONE
THIRTY PILOTS -- THAT WILL COME
INTO OUR OUR PILOT PROGRAM --
CAM I'M IMAGINE SEE ONE THIRTIES
OR USE IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY ALREADY FOR FIRE
FIGHTING.
HE THREW IT THROUGH -- CONTRACT
ONLY THAT WE DON'T THERE AREN'T
ANY THAT ARE IN -- GOVERNMENT
SERVICE FOR SUCH AS THAT THAT
I'M AWARE OF NATIONAL GUARD OKAY
FOR THE NATIONAL GUARD YEAH SO
WHEN WHEN DO YOU EXPECT TO HAVE
THE THIRTY PEOPLE IENTIFIED IN
ON THE PAY ROLL IN.
AND FULL TIME WITH CAL FIRE.
SO THERE IS A PHASED IN MULTI
YOUR APPROACH -- BASED ON A
DELIVERY OF THE AIRCRAFT TO TO
BRING THEM HOME AND OVER FACE
PERIOD OKAY.
AND I'LL JUST I'M CLOSE WITH
THIS I AM VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THIS I I YOU KNOW I THINK IS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA
AND AND FOR CAL FIRE AND YOU
pSINGLE ONE OF OUR AREAS HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY.
OUT OF CONTROL -- FOREST FIRES
SO AT AM.
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD AND HAVE
MY FULL SUPPORT ON THIS AND AS I
WAS IN THIS IS THAT ACTION ISSUE
THAT WE NEED TO SPEND MONEY ON
SO THANK YOU.
LEO HOW EXCITED ARE YOUWHAT
JUST JUST TO CLARIFY FOR THE
COMMITTEE SO THE PILOTS WOULD
NOT BE I AM A CAL FIRE EMPLOYEES
THIS WOULD BE THROUGH A CONTRACT
THAT THEY HAVE.
THE PROPOSAL DOES INCLUDE SIME
AND THE ORIGINAL JANUARY
PROPOSAL DOES INCLUDE SOME AND
CAL FIRE STAFF THAT DAY AND ALL
OF THE MINISTRIES AND THAT
FLIGHT CREWS WOULD BE THROUGH A
CONTRACT AND SO THAT WOULD BE
THE MECHANISM BY WHICH THEY
WOULD BE IDENTIFYING THE FLIGHT
CREWS.
JUST MAKE SURE THAT DIDN'T GET
LOST IN TRANSLATION I APPRECIATE
SO EVEN AFTER CALIFORNIA OWNS
THE AIRPLANES AND IS OPERATING
THEM FULL TIME.
THE PILOTS AND CREWS ILL NOT BE
CALIFORNIA BE CALIFORNIA PLEASE
AT CREEK CONSISTENT MAR OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS X. CONSISTENT
WITH THE WAY THAT CALIFORNIA --
AT LEE AND STOPS ITS FLIGHT
CREWS FOR THE EXISTING PLANES
THANK YOU.
HOW FAR? TO CLARIFY OF JESSICA'S
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT ALL OF OUR
ALL OF OUR AIR TANKERS AND MOVIE
TEN AIR TACTICAL PLANES --
PILOTS ARE BEING -- UNDER
CONTRACT CURRENTLY WITH DYING
COR INTERNATIONAL.
ALL OF OUR HELICOPTER PILOTS ARE
CIVIL SERVICE CLASSIFICATIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A QUICK
COMMENT DO APPRECIATE -- THE
DIRECTOR BRINGS FORWARD AND
STRUCTURE THANK YOU I THINK THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS AND I NEVER
WANT TO PUT WORDS IN
CALIFORNIA'S MATH.
BUT WHEN -- OVER THE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN WHEN ALL HELL
BREAKS LOOSE THE FIRES WERE
GOING TO SPEND WHAT IT TAKES OR
IS.
CANDIDLY THERE ISN'T THE BUDGET.
I AND WE'RE GONNA SPEND WHAT IT
TAKES BEEN PUT IT OUT SO THAT
MEANS FOR BRINGING AIR APPARATUS
FROM.
WESTERN STATES OR FROM AROUND
THE UNITED STATES WORKING DOING
MARINA SPEND IT -- AND I THINK
THAT IT IS BEST TO BE A TO
CONTROL OUR OWN DESTINY -- AND
BE ABLE TO HAVE THESE -- AT THE
READY IN A TARGETED AREA
STRATEGIC AREAS ACROSS THE STATE --
SO EVEN THOUGH WE MAY NOT SEE A
CUT OF TOTAL COST SAVINGS
BECAUSE WE IN PLEASE PUSH BACK
IF I'M WRONG ON THIS BUT WE'RE
ABLE.
TO WE GET SOME REIMBURSEMENT
FROM LIKE FOR EXAMPLE -- THE
FEDS WERE ABLE TO PUT THAT
TOWARDS THE COST OF WE NEEDED
FOR RESPONSE.
REGARDLESS OF THAT -- BEING ABLE
TO MOBILIZE THESE THROUGHOUT
STRATEGIC AREAS THIS STATE IS
THE RIGHT THING TO BE ABLE TO DO.
UNDERSTAND WHERE THE CHAIR ALSO
ONCE WE HAVE TO GO WITH JUST.
ONE CORRECT BUT BUT ULTIMATELY
WE'RE GONNA HAVE SEVEN TO BACK
UP FIVE READY TO GO IN STRATEGIC
AREAS ACROSS THE STATE -- IN
OBVIOUSLY -- WITH THE CHAIRS
ALSO BEEN FOCUSES NOT JUST ON
SUPPRESSION BUT THEN ALSO ON
MAKING SURE THAT WERE ABLE TO
GET OUT IN FRONT OF SOME MORE
PROACTIVE.
MEASURES AS WELL BUT AGAIN.
I I SEEN WHAT WE HAVE SEEN ON
THE NORTH COAST.
NOW I TERRIBLE IT HAS BEEN --
AND THEN HAVING TO BE ABLE TO
WAIT BOTH FOR PERSONNEL TO BE A
BRIEF FLOWN IN FROM ACROSS THE
NATION.
AS WELL AS AIR SUPPORT -- IT'S
PAST DUE.
GLAD THAT WE'RE MOVING FORWARD
ON GETTING RID OF THE VIETNAM
THEIR HELICOPTERS IN THIS IS
ALSO THE NEXT STEP -- IS WELL SO
APPRECIATE.
OKAY THIS IS STEP FOR CONDITIONS
TO HOLD OPEN -- WILL HAVE A
PUBLIC HEARING AT THE END OF THE
CAL FIRE -- THE AGENDAS LET'S
MOVE ON TO INNOVATION --
PROCUREMENT SPRINT -- ISSUE
NUMBER -- TWENTY SIX OKAY.
PLEASE INNOVATION PROCUREMENT
SPREAD BCP.
CALPERS REQUESTING A FIFTEEN
POINT.
I'M SORRY JUST FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND -- ONE TIME
IN.
SCHOOL YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY TO
PROCURE -- INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS.
AT A TO COMBAT IT CALVET A
CALIFORNIA'S WILDFIRE --
WILDFIRES UNDER THIS CRISIS THIS
THIS IS -- AN ITEM THAT.
WAS IDENTIFIED BY.
EXECUTIVE ORDER -- AND ZERO FOUR
NINETEEN AND A ONE THAT THEY THE
GOVERNOR ASKED CAL FIRE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY AND
THAT AND GENERAL SERVICES -- TO
WORK THROUGH THIS NEW PROCESS OF
IDENTIFYING A PROBLEM AND THEN --
WORKING THROUGH AN INNOVATIVE
PROCESS TO TO GET IDEAS AND
CONCEPTS THAT WOULD THEN TURN
INTO -- A DEPLOYMENT SCHEDULE
THAT WOULD.
LOOK INTO NEXT YEAR AND THE
FUTURE -- SO -- WHAT WE'VE DONE --
IS WORKED WITH GOOD COLLABORATE
WE WE ARE TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH VENDORS AND
INNOVATORS.
TO OF CONCEPTS DURING THIS --
THIS COMING FIRE SEASON -- WE'RE
LOOKING.
FOR THE BUDGET REQUESTED PIECE
OF THIS IS THE IS FOR FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN STIPENDS FOR
VENDORS -- THIS IS TO INCREASE
SAY MOM AND POP OR INVADERS THAT
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF OF FINANCIAL
RESOURCES. TO BE ABLE TO DEVELOP
THOSE REALLY GOOD IDEAS IF THEY
COME ABOUT.
A AND THEN A REQUEST FOR TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE PROOF OF
CONCEPT PHASE -- THAT WULD --
THEN PUT US INTO -- EVALUATION
OF THOSE CONCEPTS AS THEY ROLL
OUT THROUGH THE FIRE SEASON --
THE LET'S SEE THE DEPARTMENT
EXPECTS THAT THIS -- AGAIN WOULD
BE DEPLOYED NEXT FIRE SEASON ON
A MORE PERMANENT BASIS BUT
CONCEPTS WOULD BE APPROVED
THROUGH THIS SEASON AND INTO THE
THE WINTER PERIOD.
HOWEVER YOU HAS SOME
OBSERVATIONS ON THIS BUDGET
REQUEST THERE ARE SO AND
TYPICALLY EACH MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AS YOU KNOW AND THE
NORMAL PROCESS WOULD BE FOR A
DEPARTMENT.
TO EVALUATE ITS SOLUTIONS TO A
PROBLEM AND AND AND HAVE A
DETAILED EXPLANATION OF WHAT
THEY WANT TO SPEND MONEY ON AND
THEN BRING THAT REQUEST FOR TO
THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THROUGH THIS ALTERNATIVE I'M
PROCUREMENT PROCESS THAT IS
REALLY SORT OF BEING PILOT
TESTED HERE AT CAL FIRE -- IT'S
KIND OF FLIPPING THINGS I AM IN
THE ORDER OF THINGS AND THAT
MAKES IT SO MUCH CHALLENGING FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO BE ABLE TO
EVALUATE YOUR BEING ASKED TO
APPROVE.
MONEY TO DO THINGS THAT WILL
SOLVE A PROBLEM STATEMENT
WITHOUT REALLY KNOWING WHAT
EXACTLY AND THOSE THINGS WOULD
BE AND EXACTLY HOW THE FUNDS
WOULD BE SPENT.
I THAT BEING SAID IN OUR OFFICE
RECOGNIZES THAT POTENTIAL
BENEFITS FROM DOING THINGS IN A
DIFFERENT AND MORE CREATIVE WAY
AT LEAST PILOT TESTING IT OUT
AND SEEING HOW IT GOES AND THIS
FIRST YEAR.
AND AND SO THE OVERALL CONCEPT
AND MAY IS IS SOMEWHAT
REASONABLE IN THAT REGARD AND
THE LANGUAGE HOWEVER THAT IS
PROPOSED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
THE PROVISIONAL BUDGET LANGUAGE --
BUT WE THINK IT DOES NOT REALLY
PROVIDE ENOUGH INFORMATION FOR
THE LEGISLATURE AND AND ENOUGH
AND SORT OF FEEDBACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE BEFORE FINDING IS
SPENT ON SO AND OUR FIRST
CONCERN IS.
THAT THE BUDGET LANGUAGE ALLOWS
BASICALLY UNLIMITED
AUGMENTATIONS THROUGH AND JUST A
NOTIFICATION TO THE G. JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
ON IN SOME CASES THAT'S ONLY A
FIFTEEN DAY NOTIFICATION WHICH
REALLY DOES NOT PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE -- BUT WITH THE VERY
MUCH TIME TO CONSIDER WHAT COULD
BE POTENTIALLY VERY SIGNIFICANT
MID YEAR.
ON BUDGETARY AUGMENTATIONS AND
AND THEN IT'S ONLY GOING THROUGH
JUST THAT MAKE YOUR PROCESS
WHERE THE WHOLE LEGISLATURE'S
NOT HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY IT'S
JUST THROUGH THE JAIL BC.
AND THE SECOND CONCERN THAT WE
HAVE WITH THE LANGUAGE IS THAT
IT DOESN'T REALLY PROVIDE FOR A
WAY FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO BE
KEPT UPDATED AND APPRISED ON THE
PROGRESS.
OF THIS INNOVATIVE PROCUREMENT
APPROACH SO WHAT WE ASK HOW FIRE
ON THE TYPES AS I AM RESPONSES
THAT THEY'VE RECEIVED SINCE
THEY'VE I AM HER IN THE
EVALUATION ROCESS NOW THEY
RECEIVED RESPONSES BACK.
I HAVEN'T THE ANSWER THAT WE
GUIDE AND IS THAT THEY'RE
THEY'RE NOT REALLY ABLE TO SAY
ANYTHING THERE UNDER A
CONFIDENTIALITY AGREEMENTS AND
THEY'RE NOT ABLE.
TO I AM A SHARE INFORMATION ON
AND I'M REALLY IN THE NUMBER OF
RESPONSES THAT THEY'VE RECEIVED
THE TYPES OF PRODUCTS ARE
SOLUTIONS THAT THEY'RE
EVALUATING.
AND TO REALLY GET THE
LEGISLATURE A SENSE OF WHAT
MIGHT YOU BE BUYING FOR THIS
FIFTEEN MILLION ARE FIFTEEN
MILLION CLASS AND SO WE WOULD
RECOMMEND -- IF YOU WANT TO GO
FORWARD WITH THIS I AM REVISING
OF THAT PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE TO
REQUIRE THE ADMINISTRATION TO
REPORT BACK ONCE THEY'RE DONE
WITH THE EVALUATION AND FEES OF
AND THE INITIAL PART BEFORE THEY
START SPENDING MONEY BEFORE
THEY'RE PUTTING I'M FUNDING INTO
ANY OF THESE PROTOTYPES.
SO WHAT THE LEGISLATURE KNOW
WHAT DID THEY FIND WHAT TYPES OF
SOLUTIONS WERE PROPOSED AND
WHICH ONES DO THEY WANT TO GO
FORWARD WITH -- AND THEN ALSO
COMING BACK AND BEFORE FINDING A
SPENT AND AND AND PUTING A CAP
ON THE TOTAL AMOUNT.
OF MAYBE MAKES SENSE TO GIVE
SOME FLEXIBILITY IF IT'S STILL
SORT OF AND CLEAR WHAT TYPES OF
SOLUTIONS MIGHT BE I'M.
PILOT TESTED THROUGH THIS
PROCESS AND AND HOW MUCH THAT
MIGHT COST THAT MIGHT MAKE SENSE
TO PROVIDE SOME FLEXIBILITY IN
THE FUNDING -- BUT WE THINK YOU
WOULD WANT TO CAP IT SAYS THAT
YOU AT LEAST HAVE A SENSE OF
WHAT YOU'RE BUDGETARY COMMITMENT
IS ON THIS.
IS THERE A PROBLEM WITH AT LEAST
PROVIDING THE LEGISLATURE WITH
THE OUTCOMES OF THESE TESTS I
MEAN I GET THAT THE FACT THAT
SOME OF THIS IS PROPRIETARY
INFORMATION OR MIGHT BE IN THIS
IS THESE ARE.
THESE YOUR MOM AND POP
OPERATIONS ARE COMING UP WITH
THESE INNOVATIVE IDEAS BUT AT
LEAST LET US KNOW ONCE YOU
TESTED IT OUT THERE IN THE WE WE
OR WHEREVER YOU'RE TESTING IT
WHAT THE OUTCOMES WOULD BE.
FINANCE OR NO LET'S GO CAL FIRE.
I GET TO FINANCE.
SORRY.
TOMORROW'S GOING TO ANSWER THIS
QUESTION WELL CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS TOMORROW I'M SHOWING THE
CALVARY DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY
AND WITHIN PARTNERING WITH --
CAL FIRE ON THIS THE PROCUREMENT
OF VERY ACTIVELY AND SO CENTER
WITH OUR PRACTICE OF AND
POLICIES THAT WE DO NOT RELEASE
INFORMATION DURING AN ACTIVE
PROCUREMENT WE ARE LEVERAGING A
MODEL ALLOWS US TO NEGOTIATE --
WITH -- BIDDERS AND AND
INNOVATORS DURING THIS PROCESS
AND SO WE WOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY.
TO REVIEW CERTAIN RESULTS OF THE
VARIOUS PROTOTYPES IN AS WE
PROGRESS BOARD WE HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO THE NEGOTIATE
WITH OTHER -- INNOVATORS
DEPENDING UPON THE OUTCOME OF
THOSE PREFERRED CONCEPT --
DEPEND UPON THE NEGOTIATION
PROCESS WE LIKE TO RESERVE ON
THE ABILITY.
TO SHARE OR EXPOSE THE
INNOVATORS UNTIL THE VERY LAST --
PARTICULAR MOMENT THE PROCESS.
BUT NORMALLY WHEN YOU'RE DEALING
WITH THE TECHNOLOGY GUYS I I
REPRESENT PART OF SAN JOSE IN
THAT AREA I KNOW THAT CROWD THIS
IS.
FIELD TESTED STUFF ON THE
WILDFIRES THERE'S THERE'S GOT I
MEAN I GET I GET THAT THEY MAY
HAVE PROPRIETARY INFORMATION BUT
AT LEAST IF THEY'RE ASKING FOR
MORE MONEY.
AS WE'RE GOING THROUGH THIS
PROCESS OF THIS IF -- WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE OUTCOME I DON'T
WANNA KNOW HOW THE GADGET WORKS
I JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT IT
WORKS.
YEAH I KNOW I DON'T KNOW THAT
THERE'S PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
THAT'S INCLUDED THAT PROVIDES
THE NOTIFICATIONS IN THE CASE OF
THE STIPENDS THERE'S A THIRTY
DAY NOTIFICATION IN THE CASE OF
THE ACTUAL PROCUREMENT OF THE
TECHNOLOGY THERE'S A FIFTEEN DAY
NOTIFICATION THOSE TIME LINES
WERE DELIBERATELY CONSTRUCTED
BECAUSE THE ENTIRE.
INTENT HERE IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE GETTING THE SOLUTIONS ON
THE GROUND AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE AND SO THIS IS.
A TO THIS WHOLE PROCESS IN THE
INTENSE AND THE CONSTRUCTION AND
THE TIME LINES INTO AND IF THERE
ARE DELAYS IN THAT IT JUST PUTS
US BACK BECAUSE THE WHOLE GOAL
HERE IS TO GET THE SOLUTIONS ON
THE GROUND IN TIME FOR NEXT FIRE
SEASON AND I'M JUST ASKING.
THAT YOU SHARE WITH THE
LEGISLATOR OF THE LEGISLATURE A
LITTLE BIT AT THE OUTCOME SINCE
THERE IS NO CAP ON THIS THE LA --
CAUGHT THIS IS SAYING THERE'S NO
CAP ON YOUR PROPOSALS ACTUALLY I
THINK THE INTENT IS TO BRING FOR
THAT INFORMATION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE I'M AT THE POINT IN
TIME AND AND SO THE THERE ARE
NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS TO
ALLOW THAT AND TO AND TO ALLOW
FOR THAT ENGAGEMENTS RIGHT FOR
THE LETTER. TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND A
FIFTEEN DAY TURNAROUND DOESN.
IS IT THAT'S THAT.
TECHNICALLY MEETS A LEVEL OF
NOTICE AND AND FOR THE I. T.
PEOPLE THAT MAY BE.
THE CAT'S MEOW IS FAR IS NOT
LETTING US KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
AT ON THE OUTCOMES OF THESE
pOF FOR ALL.
ALLOCATING MONEY TO KNOW.
YES WE'RE GONNA TRY SOMETHING
INNOVATIVE WE'RE GONNA GIVE SOME
MONEY OUT WITH THAT TRY OUT SOME
STUFF BUT JUST.
WE'LL SEND YOU A LETTER IN
FIFTEEN DAYS YOU DON'T CRY IT
AND WE KEEP GOING.
THAT'S A CONCERN.
CENTER MONEY YOU HAVE A QUESTION.
YOU WELL RELATED TO THIS SO I
ASSUME.
REQUEST FOR PROPOSALS GO OUT.
FOR PEOPLE TO BID TO TO BE
CONSIDERED.
AS ONE OF THE VENDORS FOR THIS
INNOVATION IT'S A TWO STAGE
PROCUREMENT PROCESS IS LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT -- IN TERMS OF HOW
IT IS EXECUTED BUT AFTER WE GO
OUT WITH THE AFTER WE COMPLETE
THE PROCONSUL.
THE INNOVATORS THAT WERE CHOSEN
FOR THAT PERFECT CONCEPT ARE THE
INNOVATORS THAT CAN COMPETE ON
IN THE FINAL STAGES FOR CONTRACT
AWARDS SOON INVITING PROPOSALS
HAD A YOU.
FRAME THE PROBLEM THAT YOU'RE
SEEKING PROPOSALS ABOUT.
SURE WE ACTUALLY ISSUED -- THE
WHAT WE WORK WERE CALLING THE
REQUEST -- FOR INNOVATIVE IDEAS --
ON MARCH TWENTY SECOND.
ON SKIS ME ON MARCH TWENTY
SECOND AND SO THAT WOULD -- THAT
WAS THE PROCESS BY WHICH THE
INNOVATORS COULD SUBMIT THEIR
IDEAS -- FOR EVALUATION OF BY
CAL FIRE AND SO THAT IS THE
FIRST STAGE OF THE PROCUREMENT
AND WHICH REALLY QUITE FIGURE
REPLACES THE R. P. I'M PROCESS
THANK YOU THAT'S HELPFUL
[inaudible]
OUR INSTITUTIONAL.
FIRE CENTERS ABLE TO ALSO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS IF THE
PROCESS IS DESIGNED TO ENCOURAGE
INNOVATORS FROM ANY -- SECTOR OR
OR AREA OF THE OF THE STATE --
ARE YOU FROM AN ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS OF LOOSELY FOR
EXAMPLE.
DO WE GIVE PRIORITY TO A
CALIFORNIA BASED VERSES OUT OF
STATE.
NOT AT THIS POINT.
AND I I REALIZE WERE MAYBE NOT
ABLE TO DO THAT IN TERMS OF OPEN
COMPETITION BUT IN IS.
IS THERE ANY.
WHEN THAT PROCESS TO IDENTIFY?
A SMALLER BUSINESS OWNERS
MINORITY BUSINESS OWNERS
ABSOLUTELY YES THE PROCUREMENT
PROCESSES DO ALLOW US TO
IDENTIFY.
ON SMALL BUSINESS AND DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS ENTERPRISE SIX
BETTER INTERNET PROCESS YES.
THANK YOU.
HAITIAN THAT'S WHAT YOU'LL BE
DOING WITH THE FIVE MILLION
STIPEND THAT PORTION OF IT IS
THAT YOU SORT OF IT'S A FIX
UNIVERSE OUT THERE WITH THESE
CLEVER IDEAS AND THE LEASE IN
THIS.
THE FIRE.
FIGHTING OUT WORLD OKAY THIS IS
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS TO
HOLD OPEN MAYBE WE'LL DO SOME
WORD SMITHING ANDREA.
ACTUAL REQUEST -- AND LET'S MOVE
ON THE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
THIS IS THE COMMUNITY -- WILD
FIRE PREVENTION AND MITIGATION
REPORT.
THE VEGETATION TREATMENT PROGRAM.
WELCOME BACK PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
WELCOME BACK -- MATTIAS.
JEREMIH CASSIE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT TIAS BORDER
FORCING FIRE PROTECTION -- THE
MATTER BEFORE YOU FOR
CONSIDERATION AT THIS TIME IS A
700-343-0000 DOLLAR ONE TIME
ALLOCATION TO SUPPORT FINAL
PREPARATION AUTUMN AND
CERTIFICATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
VEGETATION TREATMENT PROGRAM E.
I. R. -- THIS IS A SOMEONE OF A
LONGER PROCESS THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING THROUGH ITS BEEN VERY
TECHNICALLY CHALLENGING IT'S A
SINGLE PROCESS IT'S COVERING
TWENTY POINT. THREE MILLION
ACRES WAS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO BE TRYING.
TO MAKE MORE EFFICIENT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT TREATMENTS FOR
WILDFIRE PREVENTION ACTIVITIES
NAMELY ECOLOGICAL RESTORATION --
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE
TREATMENTS AS WELL AS FUEL
BRAKES -- IT'S A KEY KEY PS I
BELIEVE AND I BELIEVE MANY DO
BELIEVE -- AS WELL IN DISEASE
AND MOVING FORWARD AND TRYING TO
INCREASE THE PACE AND SCALE OF
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT ACTIVITIES
FOR WILDLAND FIRE PREVENTION WAS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IT'S A PROGRAMMATIC E. I. R..
THAT'S COVERING TWENTY THREE
TWENTY POINT THREE MILLION ACRES
THAT IS CORRECT.
SO WE UNDERSTAND HOW THE E. R.
IN THE DIFFERENT REGIONS THE
WORK PROGRAM GO AHEAD YEAH I
WOULD LOVE SOME MORE INSIGHT
INTO THIS BEEN OVER A DECADE IN
THE MAKING HERE -- REPORTER
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS FOR JUST
THE UNIQUE.
NATURE OF CHAPARRAL VERSES BIG
TREE COUNTRY.
THE FIRST FEW MITIGATION PLAN
THAT CAME OUT.
I STILL HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
FORMULA BEING USED THEIR BEING
TO CENTRIC AROUND.
TREES AND NOT ENOUGH ABOUT
PUBLIC SAFETY AND COMMUNITIES IN
SORT OF HITTING THAT THE
GREATEST NUMBER OF PEOPLE
POSSIBLE BUT I WANT TO GET A
SENSE.
A HAVE THE TEARING MIGHT WORK ON
OTHER PROGRAMMATIC YEAH ARE LIKE
HOW HOW TO FIND ARE WE GOING TO
BE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
THEN IS THERE.
ARE YOU ALL SECONDARILY ARE YOU.
ARE THERE OTHER PLANS GOING ON
BESIDES SORT OF PRESCRIBED FIRE
APPROACH TO CHAPARRAL THAT YOU
ANTICIPATE DEPLOYING IN THAT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AREA SO I
DON'T KNOW HOW YOU WANNA TAKE
THE ORDER OF I TAKE THE FIRST
QUESTION.
REPORTER IN TERMS OF HEARING ARE
THERE'S A CHECKLIST IS GOING TO
BE INVOLVED IN I JUST AS A STEP
BACK FOR ONE SECOND IN TERMS OF
TEARING PART OF THE REASON WHY
THEY SAID -- THIS ISSUE WAS
TAKEN SUCH A LONG PERIOD OF TIME --
TO TO MOVE FORWARD IS THAT IT IS
VERY TECHNICAL THERE IS A LOT OF
DIFFERENT VEGETATION TYPES
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
HABITATS THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT SPECIES ASSOCIATED
WITH THOSE HABITATS OF
VEGETATION TYPES ACROSS TWENTY
POINT. TWENTY MILLION ACRES OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO THERE IS A CHECKLIST AND ALSO
ME IS GOING TO BE INCLUDED THAT
A PROJECT PROPONENT LIKE CAL
FIRE.
WHO WOULD BE THE PROPER PRIMARY
PROJECT FOR BONE ABOARD BUT IS
BEING SET UP IN A MANNER WHERE A
MYRIAD OF STAKEHOLDERS WE
ALREADY USE THAT WOULD BE ON A
POLE THAT CHECKLIST OUT?
LOOK TO THE ENVIRONMENTAL
ASSESSMENT HAS BEEN PROVIDED AND
DETERMINE IF THE PROJECT FALLS
WITHIN THE SCOPE OF THE
ENVIRONMENT ANALYSIS PROVIDED.
YOU WOULD LITERALLY GO THROUGH
AND AND LOOK AT EACH INDIVIDUAL
RESOURCE SUBJECT MATTER FROM AIR
QUALITY TO INDIVIDUAL SPECIES --
TO AESTHETICS AND BE ABLE TO
MAKE A DETERMINATION THAT YOU DO
OR DO NOT FALL WITHIN THE SCOPE
OF THE PROGRAM YEAH I ARE. FOR
THEIR PROJECTS BEING ANTICIPATED
IN THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGION THAT [inaudible]
WOULD.
TRY TO DID YOU TRY TO USE THIS
TEARING FOR OR IS IT ALL SORT OF
MOVING ON TO THE EXECUTIVE ORDER
RIGHT NOW IN THE SEQUEL --
WAIVER THERE'S PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WOULD FALL FROM THE
NORTH FROM THE OREGON BORDER TO
THE MEXICAN BORDER THAT WOULD
FALL WITHIN THIS.
YET I I'D LIKE TO ADD A LITTLE
BIT TO THAT SO THE THIRTY FIVE
PROJECTS THAT ARE.
UNDER EXECUTIVE ORDER -- FOR
FIVE NINETEEN THAT IS -- THOSE
ARE PARTICULARLY RELATED TO
EMERGENCY CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE
DETERMINED UNDER THAT FORTY FIVE
DAY REPORT.
AND AND THEN -- WERE WE WERE
ORDERED TO MOVE AHEAD WITH THOSE
UNDER EMERGENCY CIRCUMSTANCES.
SO THOSE ALL NEEDED SOME
EXEMPTION FROM C. C<c.cyan> ALL</c>
TOGETHER -- WE STILL ARE DOING
THE ENVIRONMENTAL ANALYSIS AND
DO AND PRESENTING THAT
INTERNALLY WE ARE DOING THE
PUBLIC FACING PART OF THAT --
AND SO SO WE STILL ARE DOING THE
ENVIRONMENT AND ENVIRONMENTAL
ANALYSIS AND AND MAKING SURE
THAT THE RESOURCES ARE PROTECTED
FOR THOSE THIRTY FIVE PROJECTS.
BUT WHAT'S DIFFERENT ABOUT THIS
FROM THOSE THOSE THIRTY FIVE
PROJECTS ARE ONES THAT WE WOULD
DEEM TO BE NEED TO DO THIS YEAR
WE'RE GOING TO DO THEM THIS YEAR.
THE THIS IS THE BRIDGE OR THAT'S
THE BRIDGE TO GET TO WHERE WE
NEED TO BE FOR THIS OF CALVI T.
P. THE CALIFORNIA VEGETATION
TREATMENT PROGRAMMATIC HE I ARE.
ALL OF THESE TYPES OF PROJECTS
IN THE FUTURE WILL BE FOLDED
UNDER THAT DOCUMENT AND IN FACT
THESE PROJECTS THAT WE'RE DOING.
AS THEY COME UP FOR RENEWAL THE
THE THIRTY FIVE PROJECTS THEY'LL
HAVE TO FALL UNDER THIS DOCUMENT
AS WELL THIS DOCUMENT IS.
THE CORNERSTONE OF OF DOING OUR
VEGETATION TREATMENT IN THE
FUTURE UNDERSTOOD SIR DO YOU
ANTICIPATE.
USING PRESCRIBED FIRE MORE THAN
THIS SORT OF THE SCIENCE BASE
BURN CYCLES THE SORT OF NATURAL
BURN CYCLES IN THE CHAPARRAL ARE
YOU ANTICIPATING DOING MORE
PRESCRIBED FIRE THAN THAT IN THE
CHAPARRAL.
GREAT QUESTION -- AND KNOW WHAT
WE WOULD BE LOOKING FOR IS
RETURNING -- TO WHAT WOULD BE
THE FIRE RETURN THAT THAT'S
SCIENTIFICALLY BASED FIRE RETURN --
INTERVALS THAT OCCUR THROUGHOUT
THE LANDSCAPE -- THERE ARE AREAS
THAT WE WOULD ALSO BE USING THIS
FOR FUEL REDUCTION FOR COMMUNITY
PROTECTION IN SOME CASES FOR
PROTECTION OF WATERSHED IN OTHER
CASES FOR PROTECTION OF
ENDANGERED SPECIES.
SO WE CAN ACTUALLY USE FUEL
REDUCTION.
TO TRY AND KEEP FIRE OUT OF
AREAS WE DON'T WANT TO BURN ANY
MORE FREQUENTLY AS WELL.
SO I'M HERE IN A FIRM COMMITMENT
NOT TO EXCEED SCIENCE BASED FIRE
INTERVALS GOING FORWARD SEE WHAT
IT LOOKS LIKE IN THE CURRENT.
TAKE THE EXPEDITE THE EMERGENCY
PLANNING AND AND IN FACT.
SB NINE A ONE AND A TWELVE SIXTY
POINT TO MAKING SURE THAT WE
DON'T -- CONVERT -- FROM.
A CHAPARRAL LANDSCAPE TO A NON
CHAPARRAL LANDSCAPE YOU GOT I
MEAN YOU HIT ON THE HEAD LOOK AT
LOOK AT A MUSTARD THAT'S TEN
FEET HIGH.
ALL THROUGH THE BURNS AND WE'LL
SEE AND IT'S A BEAST I MEAN WE
HAVE NO IDEA I MEAN I I DON'T I
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM SINGLE PERSON
WHAT TO DO WITH IT I MEAN YOU
KNOW.
YOU TRY TO FIND FUEL BREAKS
MAYBE MAYBE WERE THE YOU KNOW I
MEAN WE CAN'T EVEN PUT.
YOU KNOW A PRESCRIBED FIRE CAN
BE TRICKY IN THOSE AREAS BECAUSE
IT'S SO SENSITIVE ANY AND ANY
INITIAL THING I KNOW A LOT OF
THIS IS KIND OUTSIDE YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY AREA BUT MEAN
WERE.
WE FEEL AT A LOSS FOR SOLUTIONS
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES BECAUSE IT
IS.
YEAH SO IT REALLY JUST RELATED
TO SOME KIND OF THIS THE
CHAPARRAL LANDSCAPE -- FUEL
BREAK STILL DO WORK -- THEY WORK
IN EVERY LANDSCAPE -- THE
CRANSTON FIRE IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY IS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF
WHERE THIS DOCUMENT IN THE
FUTURE WOULD BE USED TO MAINTAIN
THAT FUEL BREAK AROUND THE THE
THE THE COMMUNITY OF IDYLLWILD --
WHICH IS A CHAPARRAL LANDSCAPE
THAT THEN TURNS INTO A PINE
FOREST A LITTLE BIT ABOVE.
AND THE FIRE HIT THE GRANTS AND
FIRE HIT THAT RENT RIPPED UP BE
CANYON HIT THAT AT A GLANCING
ANGLE.
AND WAS DIRECTED AROUND
IDYLLWILD IDYLLWILD COULD HAVE
LOOKED LIKE PORTIONS OF OF
PARADISE OR COFFEE PARK --
EASILY LAST SUMMER AND IT DIDN'T
BECAUSE WE HAD A FUEL BREAK IN
THE RIGHT PLACE.
SO WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT I
FORGET HOW MANY YEAR PROJECTS ON
YOUR LIST AT THIRTY FIVE OR IN
CHAPARRAL AREAS.
ARE THOSE THE KINDS OF PROJECTS
THAT YOU'RE IT IS A MORE FUEL
BREAK ORIENTED LESS PRESCRIBED
FIRE ORIENTED WOULD YOU SAY ON
THE WHOLE.
IT IS IT IS FOR THESE THIRTY
FIVE PROJECTS AND EVEN GOING
FORWARD SIR TO OPEN TO THAT
STRATEGY JUST.
ALL WE HEAR IS THAT EVERY
THEY'RE JUST GOING TO ALL IT'S
GOING TO BE AS PRESCRIBED FIRE
ALL THE TIME AND AND WE SAW JUST.
WHAT COMES BACK IS INVASIVE
SPECIES AND THINGS LIKE THAT SO
WHAT I'M HEARING THAT'S NOT THE
WHICH WOULD NOT BE IN THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL BECAUSE THAT'S
AN EMERGENCY EXEMPTION FOR THE
IDEA UNDER?
COMPLETING THIS E. IR WORK WOULD
ALLOW THOSE UNDER THIS
PROGRAMMATIC ER.
TO THE PROPOSAL'S WHATEVER IT
IT'S CAL FIRE OR COUNTY OR
RIVERS COULD COME IN WOULD HAVE
TO MEET THOSE UNLESS THEY
DECIDED THAT THEY WERE ALL
OUTSIDE THAT PROGRAM AND THEN
THEY WOULD DO.
ADDITIONAL E. I. R. TO JUSTIFY
WHATEVER THAT WHATEVER THAT
ACTION WAS GOING TO BE WHETHER
IT WAS A PRESCRIBED BURN OR A
CHAPARRAL REMOVAL OR SOMETHING
ELSE MY RIGHT.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ARE YOU OKAY WITH MOVING FORWARD.
THE COMMOTION.
OKAY.
THERE IS A SEPARATE CONDITION IS
TO PROVE AS A PROPOSED.
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION
ON THAT ALLEY -- DO YOU HAVE
ANYTHING.
THAT YOU HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
FACE I'M JUST NOTE THAT THIS
WILL HOPEFULLY TAKE THIS ACROSS
THE FINISH LINE AND THEY
EMISSIONS INDICATED THAT THAT
THE AIR SHOULD BE COMPLETED
DECEMBER IF THIS YEAR AND SO
LOOK FOR TO THAT HOPE SPRINGS
ETERNAL HERE IN SEPT.
TWO LET'S OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARING THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY SEVEN THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS TO COMPLETE THE VEGETATION
TREATMENT PROGRAM ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT REPORT.
CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING THERE
IS A MOTION BY.
THE NORTH COAST SENATOR
[inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I CASKEY I JONES [inaudible]
REQUIRED [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
STERN.
I THE MATTERS APPROVED -- FIVE
ZERO LET'S MOVE ON TO THE OFFICE
OF THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL.
AND THIS IS.
THIS IS THE FIRE AND LIFE SAFETY
DIVISION. EIGHTY POST.
A NEW FEE STRUCTURE.
THIS WOULD HAVE ON A FIRE ENGINE
AND PLEASE GO AHEAD -- S. --
ISSUE TWENTY ONE OR TWENTY EIGHT
WE HAVE THAT AS THE LICENSING --
AND CERTIFICATION PROGRAM
[inaudible]
YES RIGHT.
ISSUE TWENTY YES RIGHT
[inaudible]
THE THE THIRD IS AT TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHT THE LIFE SAFETY DIVISION.
OKAY SO TWENTY EIGHT FIRE LIFE
SAFETY.
THAT THE NUMBERS MIXED UP -- TO
CAL FIRES REQUESTING TWO POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
IN FUNDS.
THE IN NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR
EIGHT POSITIONS -- TO SUPPORT
THE OFFICES STATE FIRE MARSHAL --
LIFE AND FIRE LIFE SAFETY
DIVISION INCREASING WORKLOAD
RELATED TO IT'S A REVIEW OF
PLANS CONSTRUCTION INSPECTIONS
AND MANDATED INTERVAL INSPECTION
ACTIVITIES.
THIS REQUEST INCLUDES -- FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS -- A
ONE TIME GENERAL FUNDS -- FOR
THE THE FOR AN ANALYSIS OF THE
DIVISIONS FEE STRUCTURE AND
CONSTRUCT AND CONTRACT WITH THE
THE CAL CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE -- TO ANALYZE
AND PROVIDE CLEAR THE
SPECIFICATIONS STATURE.
SPECIFIC STATUTORY ISSUES
RELATED TO AND HIM THE IMPACT.
TO THE FIRE MARSHAL'S
JURISDICTION.
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
WHEN COMPLETE THE ANALYSIS WILL
INFORM THE WORKLOAD -- AND
DELEGATION OF AUTHORITY NEEDED
FOR THE FIRE MARSHAL.
GOVERNOR'S REQUESTING A TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO HELP TO FROM A
DEFINE.
AND CLARIFY THE DIVISIONS
MISSION AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
THIS ENTIRE REQUEST COMES.
OUT OF IN A COLLABORATION WITH
THE MISSION BASED BUDGETING
PROCESS -- WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THAT IS ON GOING.
THERE'S A THE QUESTIONS RAISED
IN THE STAFF REPORT THAT BAD THE
WHEN YOU'RE.
AS YOU RE DOING YOUR MISSION
BASE -- REVIEW PROCESS WE'RE
MAKING THESE CHANGES AS W'RE
GOING THROUGH WHEN WE WANT TO
WAIT FOR THE THE FINAL ANSWER.
A FAILING PARKER BERMAN FINANCE --
SO THIS REALLY.
REFLECTS THE CULMINATION OF OUR
REVIEW OF THE FIRE LIFE SAFETY
DIVISION OUR APPROACH WITH --
THIS MISSION BASED REVIEW OF
OFFICE THE OFFICE OF THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL HAS BEEN A DIVISION
BY DIVISION APPROACH -- BASED
PRIMARILY ON THE FACT THAT
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF OVERLAP
BETWEEN THESE DIVISIONS IN TERMS
OF THEIR SCOPE READER AT NOW --
SO -- THIS FOLLOWS THE PROPOSAL
FROM LAST YEAR -- AND THIS
REALLY REFLECTS THE CULMINATION
OF OF THAT REVIEW OF THAT
DIVISION.
I'M TO THE POINT OF THE ONGOING
REVIEW -- WE WILL BE MOVING ON
TO OTHER DIVISIONS AND I'VE
ALREADY STARTED SOME OF THAT
WORK -- SO YEAH I HOPE THAT
ADDRESSES YOUR CONCERNS I WILL
HELP US OUT HERE WE GOT TO THEIR
RE DOING THEIR MISSION.
BASED REVIEW PROCESS WITH
FINANCE WE GOT THIS.
SEGREGATED DIVISIONS THAT DON'T
OVER OVERLAP IN WE WANT EIGHT
POSITIONS TO SUPPORT THE
WORKLOAD BECAUSE WE KNOW WHAT'S
GOING TO INCREASE.
FIRST SO AND WE WE DIDN'T HAVE
ANY CONCERNS WHEN WE LOOKED AT
THE PROPOSAL AND IT IT
SPECIFICALLY LOOKING AT THE
POSITIONS ADAM IS THAT WHAT'S
PROPOSED HERE DID SEEM.
TO BE KIND OF MOVING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND MAYBE
ADDRESSING ISSUES THAT WE SORT
OF ANECDOTALLY HEARD OVER THE
YEARS I'M A REGARDING THAT THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL.
AND THAT BEING SAID AND THERE
ISN'T THIS COMING ANIME REVISION
ISN'T A WHOLE LOT OF TIME FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO REALLY DIG
INTO ISSUES YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
SORT OF BASS CORPS PROGRAM
CHANGES.
AND AND AND IN THE PAST NGUYEN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS DâN.
MAYBE NOT CALLED MISSION BASED
REVIEWS BUT PERFORMANCE SPACE
REVIEWS OR OTHER THINGS THERE'S
OFTEN BEEN SOME SORT OF I'M
REPORT THAT KIND USUALLY IN THE
FORM OF A OF A SORT OF A ROBUST
B. C. P. THAT WOULD COME TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND DESCRIBING WHAT WHAT WAS
DIANNE AND THE FINDINGS AND THEN
ANY CHANGES THAT MIGHT BE
PROPOSED FROM THERE AND SO THIS
IS SORT OF A PIECEMEAL APPROACH
AND CERTAINLY IT'S NOT AND
REASONABLE IF THE LEGISLATURE
WANTS TO WAIT UNTIL.
THE WHOLE MISSION BASED REVIEW
IS COMPLETE AND YOU HAVE A MORE
OF A FORMAL AND COMPLETE WORK
REPORT BACK.
AND THAT YOUR STAFF IS AND
RECOMMENDING HERE TO REJECT THE
PROPOSAL WITHOUT PREJUDICE JUST
DUE TO THE I'M SORT OF THE
INTERIM NATURE AS OF THIS TIME
AND AGAIN JUST COMING IN MAY IT
DOESN'T GIVE YOU A WHOLE LOT OF
TIME TO DO AGAIN IF YOU HAVE
OTHER CONCERNS.
ABOUT THE COR I'M PROGRAM AND
WITHIN THE FIRE MARSHAL'S OFFICE
AT THE RESOURCES DID SEEM
REASONABLE TO US IN A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
ON THAT ALSO PERHAPS NOT
TERRIBLY URGENT AND AND SO TO
THE EXTENT THAT YOU WANT MORE
TIME TO LOOK AT THIS AND MAYBE
DAY AGAIN.
TO AND THESE THESE BASED PROGRAM
CHANGES WITHIN THE FIRE MARSHAL
AND GIVE IT GIVE IT DO TIME AND
ATTENTION -- TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT.
AS I'M UNDERSTANDING THE
DIFFERENT DIVISIONS WITHIN FIRE
MARSHALS PROGRAM -- THE
SEPARATING ARE CLARIFYING THAT
DID THE MISSION AND THE
RESPONSIBILITIES.
HOW THE SAID HELP OUT?
THERE'S JUST A CHARGER I GUESS
THERE'S BEEN SOME ROLE IN --
AREAS THAT WE HAVE IDENTIFIED DO
A EXTENSIVE STASHED TRUE REVIEW
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE OFFICE
THAT -- HAVE.
KIND OF BEEN GRAY AREAS IF YOU
WILL -- IN TERMS OF THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES -- BETWEEN
LOCALS AND OTHER JURISDICTIONS
AND THE FOR THE AND THE STATE --
SO REALLY -- THIS ATTEMPT IS TO
CLARIFY AND STREAMLINE AND AND
REALLY SET THE SET THE
BOUNDARIES -- YOU KNOW MORE --
YEAH MORE STRONGLY AND ALSO --
TO YOU KNOW ELIMINATE ANY
DUPLICATIVE WORKLOAD THAT MAY BE --
GOING ON BETWEEN -- THE OFFICES
THE FARMERS AND SOME LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
WITHIN EVERYTHING THAT THE STATE
MARK FIRE MARSHAL DOES OR JUST
WITHIN THE WITH LIFE AND SAFETY
DO WITHIN THE FIRE LIFE SAFETY
DIVISION SO HOW DOES THAT HELP
US OUT ON THE WHOLE FIRE MARSHAL.
STATE FIRE MARSHAL'S OFFICE WITH
THERE MAY BE.
WE GOT ISSUE TWENTY NINE COMING
UP DUPLICATIVE OR PERCEPTIONS OF
DUPLICATIVE ACTIVITY GOING ON
WITH THE CITY FIRE DEPARTMENT
THE COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT AND
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL.
AGAIN THIS PROPOSAL IS REALLY
LOOKING AT THIS DIVISION -- WE
DIDN'T IDENTIFY ANY AREAS WHERE --
OTHER DIVISIONS WITHIN THE FIRE
MARSHAL REALLY OVERLAP WITH THE
PHARMACY DIVISION THEY HAVE A
VERY UNIQUE -- AND TO FIND --
MISSION -- AND THIS OF THE OF
THIS KIND OF IS THE REASON THAT
WE HAVE TAKEN THIS APPROACH --
AND LOOKING AT THIS -- DIVISION
I WILL JUST ALSO ADD THAT -- WE
WOULD REALLY EMPHASIZE THAT IN
YOU KNOW IN OUR ESTIMATION THESE
ARE THESE RECESSES THESE
RESOURCES ARE ACTUALLY VERY
CRITICAL FOR THE STATE RIGHT NOW
IN THIS PROPOSAL REFLECTS -- AN
EXTENSIVE -- REVIEW AND AND
DIALOGUE WITH STAKEHOLDERS --
BOTH YOU KNOW STATE DEPARTMENTS
AND AND OUTSIDE STAKEHOLDERS --
YOU'RE RELATED TO THE WORK OF
THE FIREPLACE A DIVISION IN
TERMS OF AVOIDING PROJECT DELAYS
AND AT YOU KNOW AND COST
OVERRUNS -- SO THIS IS IN OUR
INTERVIEW VERY CRITICAL --
RESOURCES THAT ARE NEEDED FOR
THE DIVISION PROBABLY WOULD HAVE
BEEN A GOOD IDEA TO INVITE THE
LA -- ON THOSE ON THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WE WOULD KNOW ABOUT
IT RIGHT IN A WEEK WITH LEAST
KEPT ON IF THIS IS THE WAY WITH
THE REORGANIZATIONS GOING IN AND
WE'RE GONNA AGAIN.
IT'S MAY FIFTEENTH WHATEVER DAY
IT IS.
MAY FOURTEENTH.
MAY TWELFTH MAY FIFTEENTH ELLIE --
YOU HAVE.
CAN BE HELPFUL HERE.
YEAH I I THINK AND YOU KNOW
AGAIN THE THE THE RESOURCES
PROPOSED I'M TO TAKE ON THE
STAFF SIDE IT'S NOT AN
UNREASONABLE STEP FORWARD AND A
YOU KNOW THESE MISSION BASED
REVIEWS AND WHEN THIS REPORTED
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE IS A
REALLY GOOD OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU --
TODAY AGAIN DO OVERSIGHT
UNDERSTAND THE PROGRAMS I AM YOU
MIGHT THINK THAT YOU YOU KNOW
NEED TO GO FURTHER THAN WHERE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND ON THE
AND A DEPARTMENT LAND IN TERMS
OF THEIR AND YOU KNOW FINDINGS
AND THEIR RECOMMENDED CHANGES
I'M AND SO WHERE YOU'RE REALLY
TALKING.
ABOUT -- WITH THESE MISSION BASE
REVIEWS SORT OF FUNDAMENTAL BASE
PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES -- WHICH
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE --
PARTICULARLY URGENT AND AND SO
WHILE IT DOES SEEM REASONABLE
IT'S ALSO REASONABLE IF THE
LEGISLATURE HAVING NOT BEEN PART
OF THAT STAKEHOLDER PROCESS WITH
YOUR STAFF FOR WITH OUR OFFICE.
I'M YOU KNOW IF YOU WANT MORE
TIME TO LOOK INTO IT THAT'S ALSO
TOTALLY REASONABLE AND AND CAN
REALLY.
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
OVERSIGHT IN THE FUTURE.
JUST TO SIT AT THE MISSION BEACH
REVIEW PROCESS IS NOT JUST A
CRANE FOR THE OFFICE THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL IT'S A CRANE FOR
OTHER DEPARTMENTS AS WELL AS MY
COLLEAGUE CAN SHARE MORE DETAIL
BUT WE HAVE BEEN PROVIDING
REGULAR UPDATES TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND WHEN WE
INITIATED THE PROCESS.
WE ALSO INVITED I'M BOTH THAT
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AS
WELL AS A I COMMITTEE STAFF AND
THE LEGISLATIVE STAFF MORE
BROADLY TO PARTICIPATE BECAUSE
THE GOAL WAS TO BE AS
TRANSPARENT AS POSSIBLE ABOUT
THE PROCESS.
AND SORT OF THE THE TYPES OF
ACTIVITIES WE WOULD UNDERTAKEN
TRYING TO IDENTIFY -- SORT OF
WHERE WE WANTED TO FOCUS
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ARE MADE
CHANGES ETCETERA SO YOU JUST
WANT TO BE CLEAR THE GOAL WAS
ALWAYS TO BE AS TRANSPARENT AS
PROCESS AND PUT FOR IT AS MUCH
DETAIL AS POSSIBLE ON OUR
FINDINGS.
AND THE EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN B. C.
P. TO BE SUPERIOR BROUGHT
FORWARD LAST YEAR IDENTIFIED
THREE VERY SPECIFIC AREAS OF
FOLLOW UP WHICH INCLUDED A
STATUTORY REVIEW -- AS WELL AS
I'M SOME SOME OTHER ASPECTS AND
THE READ THE RECOMMENDATIONS IN
THIS PROPOSAL CLEAVE VERY MUCH
OR OR A LINE VERY MUCH WITH
THOSE SORT OF THREE OUTSTANDING
AREAS THAT WE IDENTIFIED.
ALSO JUST WANT TO NOTE THE
FINALLY SAFETY DIVISION HAS THIS
ROLE AS AS AS YOU MAY ALREADY BE
AWARE IN IN SORT OF THE STATE
CONSTRUCTION PROCESS AND PART OF
WHAT WE'RE TRYING -- TO TO
ACCOMPLISH IN THIS PROPOSAL IS
IS IMPROVE SORT OF THE PLAN
REVIEW ACTIVITIES WHEN PLANS FOR
A AND C. CONSTRUCTION ARE COMING
TO THE APP FAIRLY SAFETY
DIVISION AND MORE WE'RE GOING TO
ADD SOME TECHNICAL EXPERTISE AND
BUILD UP CAPACITY THERE SO THAT.
THAT WILL FACILITATE SORT OF
SOME OF THE DELAYS THAT HAVE
BEEN REPORTED BY STAKEHOLDERS
OVERTIME AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE.
YOUR WORK OWSKI.
MIKE RICH WINE ACTING STATE FIRE
MARSHAL.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO CONCUR WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND IN
THEIR OPINION OF THE CRITICALITY
OF THESE RESOURCES.
OTHER A HUGE COMPLEX A
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS JUST LOOK
AT THE CRANES IN DOWNTOWN
SACRAMENTO HERE THOSE ARE STATE
BUILDINGS ARE GOING UP HIGH RISE
BUILDINGS.
AND WE ARE -- AT A CRITICAL NEED --
FOR PLAN REVIEW AND INSPECTION
SERVICES THAT CAN COME IN AND
HIT THE GROUND RUNNING THAT HAVE
THE EXPERTISE.
A WE'VE BEEN HAVING DIFFICULTY
IN RECRUITING THAT AND WE THINK
THIS IS THE BEST PATH FORWARD.
YEAH EIGHT I GUESS ONE THE
QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE IS THAT.
MY DISTRICT OFFICES IN A
COMMERCIAL BUILDING.
AND JOHN DUTRA WHO COLLECTED
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT MOVED INTO
THAT BUILDINGS SO TECHNICALLY
THE STATE MORE FIRE MARSHAL IS
SUPPOSED TO INSPECT THAT
BUILDING.
EVERY YEAR -- BECAUSE IT'S THE
STATE IS THE STATE OFFICE THE
CIVIC FREMONT MOTORS FOR CITY
THANK THE SEVENTEEN SIXTEENTH
LARGEST THE STATE THEY INSPECTED
IN THE COUNTY OF ALAMEDA
INSPECTS IT.
SO WHAT WOULD.
WHY?
I MEAN OTHER THAN OTHER THAN
IT'S A STATE WHERE YOU'RE STATE
OFFICE WHY WOULD WE HAVE
EVERYBODY INSPECTING IT WHEN
THEY HAVEN'T CHANGED WHEN THEY
DID SOME UPGRADES IN THE
BATHROOM WHICH IS FINE BUT
GENERALLY IT'S THE SAME.
BUILDING.
AND WE HAVE A PHYSICAL
INSPECTION.
ARE THAT IN THAT WOULD HAVE
EIGHT MORE PEOPLE AND MAYBE. TO
TO DO THAT AND AND AND IT SOUNDS
IN THE IN THE ABSTRACT YES THIS
IS THE BUILDING WE WANT TO DO
THIS BUT BUT SOME OF THESE
THINGS WE JUST SORT OF DONE HIM.
FOR EVER AND WE CONTINUE TO DO
IT AND PEOPLE ALWAYS ASKING US
TO GET.
YOU KNOW -- STREAMLINED WORD IS --
CUT AWAY WOULD DUPLICATE
DUPLICATIONS SO DO JUST THAT --
ONE OF OUR TRAILER BILL.
LOW'S IS ESSENTIALLY -- TO TAKE
THE OFFICE OF THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL OUT.
OF OF THE STATE OCCUPIED ARENA --
OTHER THAN A FEW SPECIFIED -- HI
YOU KNOW HI CRITICAL ASSETS LIKE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES BUILDINGS AND
OTHER THINGS BUT PRIMARILY OUT
OF THE BIZ PRIVATELY OWNED.
BUSINESS OFFICE -- OCCUPANCY IS
THAT WE WE LEASES THE STATE --
THE IDEA IS TO ESSENTIALLY LEAVE
THOSE TO THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS --
SO THAT YOU KNOW TO MY EARLIER
POINT THAT IS ONE OF OUR
APPROACHES TO KIND OF
STREAMLINED AND AND REMOVE SOME
THE DUPLICATION.
RIGHT STACK THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO REJECT
WITHOUT PREJUDICE.
JUST WANT TO KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD BE OPPOSED
TO IS IS SORT OF OPPOSED TO THAT
AND WHAT IT WITH THEM I WOULD
WANT TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
PROPOSAL IS SUBMITTED
[inaudible]
OKAY OLD.
THAT WILL BRING IT UP TO THE
FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
I'D LET SOME WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
ACTION THE MOTION IS TO REJECT
WITHOUT PREJUDICE OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT ON ISSUE NUMBER. TWENTY
EIGHT WELL THE LAST TIME THIS
ISSUE WILL COME UP FOR SURE.
ALL RIGHT.
ARM.
CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING CALL THE
ROLL WE CASKEY HI JONES.
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MORNING.
OKAY WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR SENATOR JOHN TO COME BACK.
THANK YOU ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY NINE THIS IS LICENSING
CERTIFICATION.
LAURA MILLER OF BASS THE MIKE
[inaudible]
TO FIRE MARSHALL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AGAIN THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE A CALIFORNIA
REQUEST ONE POINT ONE MILLION
OFFICES DE FOR MARSHALL
LICENSING AND CERTIFICATION
FUNDS.
AND FOR POSITIONS STARTING IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TO
SUPPORT.
OUR OF FIRE ENGINEERING
INVESTIGATION DIVISIONS BUILDING
MATERIAL LISTING AND FLAME
RETARDANT PROGRAM.
THIS PROPOSAL WILL ENABLE THE
TWO PROGRAMS TO SATISFACTORILY
UPHOLD ENFORCE HEALTH AND SAFETY
REGULATIONS TO CONDUCT THE
VALUATIONS.
IMPLEMENT INSPECTIONS AND
EXECUTE ENFORCEMENT OPERATIONS
FOR EXAMPLE FRAUD -- LICENSE AND
PRODUCT FRAUD IN A TIMELY AND
EFFICIENT MANNER.
THE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WILL BE
FUN AT THE REGULATORY FEE
INCREASES OF IN THE TWO PROGRAMS
FEE STRUCTURES.
ADDED THROUGH THIS REQUEST THESE
FEE STRUCTURES HAVE NOT BEEN
UPDATED IN OVER TWO DECADES IN
FAILED TO ADEQUATELY.
REFLECT THE PRESENT DAY WORKLOAD
AND CURRENT OPERATIONAL COSTS OF
EACH PROGRAM.
INDUSTRY STAKEHOLDERS HAVE
VOICED THEIR CONCERNS AND
DESIRES FOR INCREASED CUSTOMER
SERVICE AND ENFORCEMENT.
AND THEY UNDERSTAND THAT THESE
SERVICES WILL COME IN AND
INCREASED COST.
LA OLLA FILE ON THIS.
MEMBERS THIS IS.
SEPARATE CONDITION IS TO PROVE
HIS PROPOSED THIS IS.
A LITTLE OVER MILLION DOLLARS
FOR FOR POSITIONS.
OPEN THE PUBLIC HEARING OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC LIKE TO
ADDRESS US ON THE LICENSING AND
CERTIFICATION FUN.
CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING.
THERE'S A MOTION FOR A
RECOMMENDATION PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL CASKEY HI JONES MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
MORNING [inaudible]
STERN.
RIGHT NOW LET'S OPEN THE PUBLIC
HEARING ON THE MATTERS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE HELD THIS COULD BE --
LET'S MAKE SURE I GET IT RIGHT.
THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY FIVE
ON THE SEE.
ONE FOR THIRTIES ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY SIX ON THE BRENT
[inaudible]
THIS.
INNOVATION ELEVATIONS.
AN ISSUE NUMBER -- THAT'S IT.
THOSE.
TWO MEMBERS THE PUBLIC LIKE TO
US ON THE INNOVATION SPRINT OR
THE S. C. ONE THIRTY TANKERS.
CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING THANK YOU.
WE'LL SEE YOU THANK YOU.
TOMORROW.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT LET'S HAVE PARKS
RECREATION COME UP.
WITH PARKS RECREATION WE HAVE
THREE MATTERS ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTY THIS IS A MAY REVISION
FOR THREE POINT EIGHT SEVEN
THREE MILLION. TO ENHANCE
EMERGENCY RESPONSE EFFORTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- THE
MAY PROVISION PROPOSES THREE
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS THIS
IS ONE TIME GENERAL FUND DOLLARS.
IN ITS TO ENHANCE THE
DEPARTMENT'S EMERGENCY RESPONSE
EFFORTS -- THESE FUNDS WOULD GO
TO PURCHASING EQUIPMENTS
EQUIPMENT -- QUITMAN OKAY MET
WITH HER WITH THE WOULD INCLUDE
UPGRADED MULTI BAND PARTIBLE
RADIOS -- TO INCIDENT COMMAND
TRAILERS WITH TOW VEHICLES TO
INFLATABLE RESCUE BOATS RESCUE
PADDLE BOARDS AND CARGO TRAILER
AND SOME FLAME RETARDANT
CLOTHING -- I WOULD NOTE THAT AS
WE DEVELOP THIS PROPOSAL E WORK
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE STATE'S
CALLAWAY US.
AMERICANIZATION TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS WAS NOT REDUNDANT OF
EXISTING -- STATEWIDE DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS EFFORTS -- I WOULD
ALSO.
NOTE THAT THE NEED -- TO REPLACE
THE CURRENT RADIOS THAT OUR
CURRENT RIVER THE RADIOS ARE
LIMITED -- AND THAT WE CAN
COMMUNICATE WITH THAT WITH EACH
OTHER WITHIN THE ORGANIZATION
BUT IT REALLY LIMITS OUR ABILITY
TO COMMUNICATE OUTSIDE.
OF THE STATE ORGANIZATION WHICH
YOU CAN IMAGINE IS A REAL
CHALLENGE IN THE IN THE MIDDLE
OF WHATEVER THE DISASTROUS.
WE'RE LEARNING TODAY THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO COMMUNICATE WITH
THE YOU SEE ALSO -- LA -- DO YOU
HAVE A RADIO INTER OPERABILITY
COMMENT OR READ WE DON'T HAVE
ANY CONCERNS AT THE PROPOSAL AND
AND IS THAT STAFF REPORT NOTES
THAT THERE HAVE BEEN OTHER
SIMILAR PROPOSALS IN OTHER
DEPARTMENTS RELATED TO INTER
OPERABILITY -- EVERYDAY HEROES
IN THIS TO PROVIDE AND THAT AS
WELL AS OTHER RESOURCES ON TO
PARKS.
ARE DISPOSITION NUMBER THIRTY ON
THE EMERGENCY RESPONSE REQUEST
FROM PARKS AND RECREATION LET'S
OPEN THE PUBLIC HEARING MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC.
CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS.
IS TO PROVE HIS PROPOSED.
PLEASE CALL ROLL MOTION BY
CENTER MINING.
CASKEY HI.
JONES REQUIRE.
MORNING.
I BELIEVE THE ROLLOVER FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND MOVED TO
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY ONE WHICH IS
WILDFIRE REPAIR IN REIMBURSEMENT --
THIS IS SEVEN POINT NINE MILLION
FROM GENERAL FUNDS ONE TIME IN
TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION EVERY
INVERSE THREE FROM THE STATE
PARKS RECREATION FUN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS IS A
TOTAL REQUEST FOR TEN POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS AS YOU
NOTED.
THAT SEVEN POINT NINE MILLION IS
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND IN THE
BALANCE OF TWO POINT EIGHT
MILLION AS REIMBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY -- THESE ARE FUNDS
THAT WOULD BE DESIGNATED TOWARDS
PROJECTS SPECIFICALLY --
ASSISTING WITH THE RECOVERY AND
THE REPAIR OF DAMAGE FACILITIES --
DIRECTLY AS A RESULT OF THE WILL
SEE FIRE DOWN SOUTH SO THE TWO
PARKS THAT YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
REALLY EMPHASIZED HERE'S THE
LEAD OVER CARILLO.
STATE PARK AND THE MALIBU CREEK
STATE PARK -- I WOULD ALSO NOTE
THAT FEMA HAS ANNOUNCED THAT
FEDERAL FUNDS WILL BE AVAILABLE
FOR THESE PROJECTS -- AND THAT'S
WHY YOU SEE AT THE REQUEST FOR
TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
IN REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITIES SO
WE'RE ANTICIPATING THE STATE
BEING REIMBURSED I ALSO WOULD
NOTE THAT THIS IS THE FIRST YEAR
COMING TO YOU AND ASKING YOU FOR
RESOURCES.
WE ANTICIPATE THAT WE WILL BE
BACK BEFORE YOU NEXT YEAR I ALSO
WOULD NOTE THAT -- WE HAVE A
MORE DETAILED LIST OF PROJECTS
THAT WE INTEND TO SHARE WITH
THIS BODY AND ALSO THE LA YOU
KNOW WHICH MAY ADDRESS -- YOUR
NEED FOR SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT
LANGUAGE THAT YOU DISCUSS IN
YOUR STAFF RECOMMENDATION.
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PARKS
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
STRUCTURES -- WHICH COMES FIRST
IS IT BECAUSE I'M I'M THINKING
SOME OF THESE AREAS HAVE BEEN.
YOU KNOW COMPLETELY DESTROYED IN
YOU HAVE CAL FIRES IN THEIR WITH
THEIR EQUIPMENT AND WHO KNOWS
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE PATHWAY AND
AND THE MEADOW AND ALL THAT TYPE
OF STUFF.
IS THE ISTHE PARK SYSTEM DO YOU
LOOK.
TO TO WORK ON THE PAST
STRUCTURES IN THE I WOULD CALL
IN THE NON AMENITIES THE THE
BREAD AND BUTTER OF THE PARK
SYSTEM YOU KNOW PEOPLE THAT WANT
TO GET ON THE PATH WAIT AND GO
OUT THERE VERSUS THE RANGERS
CENTER -- INTERPRETIVE CENTRE
DAT I KNOW THEY'RE BOTH NEED TO
BE DONE BUT IF YOU HAD FIRST
MONEY OUT THE DOOR BECAUSE WHAT
I'M.
CONCERNED WHAT IS THAT OR JUST
WANTED TO ASK YOU SAID IF YOU
HAVE SOMETIMES WE SEE THOSE
SIGNS WITH THE PATH IS CLOSE
BECAUSE THE PARK IS UNDER REPAIR.
NO I CAN'T WE CAN'T GET HERE AND
AND WOOD IS IT YOUR INTENTION TO
GO THROUGH AND DO ALL THAT WORK
OR BUILD THE INTERPRETIVE CENTER.
FIRST SEMESTER CHAIR I THINK
PERHAPS WHAT MIGHT BE HELPFUL IS
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT WE
RECEIVED RELATIVE TO THIS
PROPOSAL IS Y. REFOCUSING ON
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WHEN AROUND
THE SAME TIME WE HAD -- THE FIRE
THAT DEVASTATED THE CAMPFIRE --
IN IN RESPONSE TO THAT WE DIDN'T
REALLY HAVE A LOSS OF FACILITIES
IN THE CAMPFIRE SO YOU SEE THESE
PROJECT DOLLARS FOCUSING ON THE
WILL THE FIRE AREA -- WE ARE
ALREADY ACTUALLY OUT THERE
MAKING SOME REPAIRS WE HAVE BEEN
EXPERIENCING THE AFTER EFFECTS
OF THE WILL SEE FIRE SO FOR
EXAMPLE WITH THE BURNING OF THE
VEGETATION IN THE LEO CARILLO
STATE PARK THAT MAKES US
VULNERABLE. TO THINGS LIKE --
EROSION AND THE SLIDING OF
DEBRIS FROM THE HILL SIDE I WAS
THERE TWO WEEKS AGO -- AND YOU
KNOW SIX MONTHS PRIOR YOU WERE
ABLE TO WALK UNDER A ROADWAY AND
NOW IT'S FILLED WITH DEBRIS AND
MUD SO WE ARE ALREADY IN THERE
WITH CREWS -- CLEANING THAT UP I
THINK THE FIRST THING WE DO IS
WE THINK ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY AND
WE WANT TO OPEN THE PARK BACK.
TO LEO CARILLO CURRENTLY IS
CLOSE WE ANTICIPATE RE OPENING
IT BY THE END OF MAY -- WE LOST --
ALL OF OUR HEAVY EQUIPMENT DOWN
IN THAT AREA WAS WERE BURNED AND
SO WE IMMEDIATELY -- SOLVE THAT
THROUGH KIND OF REDISTRIBUTING.
HEAVY EQUIPMENT THROUGHOUT OUR
OWN STATE DEPARTMENT -- BUT WHAT
I EXPECT YOU'RE GOING TO SEE IN
THE LIST TOMORROW IS A REAL
FOCUS ON PLANNING AND TAKING A
LOOK AT ALL OF THE FACILITIES
AND SO I THINK PUBLIC SAFETY
COMES FIRST THE THINGS THAT
PREVENT US.
FROM BEING ABLE TO RE OPEN THE
PARK -- REST FACILITIES SO THOSE
THINGS THAT HAVE THE MOST DIRECT
IMPACT ON A VISITOR'S EXPERIENCE
BUT WE EXPECT THIS TO BE A MULTI
YEAR PHASED EFFORT.
ALEJO YOU HAVE A COMMENT ON THE
MALIBU CREEK OR LEO CARILLO
STATE PARKS.
SURE SO.
I THINK ARC ARE COMMENTS ON THIS
WHEN AND IT'S OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
BEEN DAMAGE THAT HAS HAPPENED I
AM AT STATE PARKS -- FROM FROM
THE WALL THE FIRE AND DAMAGE
FROM OTHER FIRES AS WELL AND AND
SO IT'S IT'S TOTALLY REASONABLE
FOR AND PARKS TO YOU NEED
RESOURCES TO REPAIR.
THE DAMAGE AND ONE OF THE THE
CONCERNS THAT WE RAISED IS THAT
THAT PROPOSAL THAT WAS --
PROVIDED DOESN'T IDENTIFY
DETAILS ABOUT THE TYPES OF
PROJECTS I AM ARE UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT PART OF THIS FUNDING --
WOULD BE USED TO ACTUALLY DO A
MORE THOROUGH ASSESSMENT -- AND
THAT THERE'S ALSO SOME SORT OF
INITIAL EARLY IMPLEMENTATION
PROJECTS THAT HAVE A BIT BEEN
IDENTIFIED.
AND AND SO WE JUST THINK THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE AND THAT
INFORMATION ON HOW MUCH OF THE
FINDINGS GOING TO GO TO THE
ASSESSMENT.
HOW MUCH WILL GO TO PROJECTS AND
WHICH PROJECTS AND ESPECIALLY
SINCE THIS IS GOING TO BE A
MULTI YEAR EFFORT AND THIS IS
JUST THE FIRST SLICE OF IT?
AND AND IN ORDER MAKE SURE THAT
THAT PROJECTS THAT THEY'RE
PROPOSING A LINE IT WITH AND
WITH WHAT THE LEGISLATURE'S
PRIORITIES ARE WITH WHAT.
MEMBERS IN THAT DISTRICT ARE
HEARING AND THE PRIORITIES ARE
AND AND THAT YOU CAN REALLY HOLD
PARKS ACCOUNTABLE FOR ACHIEVING
AND THIS PIECE OF THAT REPAIR
AND RESTORATION BEFORE THEY COME
BACK REQUESTING MORE FUNDING IN
THE FUTURE.
THAT NUMBER US.
UP FOR US THE MISTER CHAIR I
BELIEVE THAT THE LIST THAT
YOU'LL BE RECEIVING THE LA --
WILL BE RECEIVING TOMORROW WILL
ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO MEET AND TALK WITH THEM
OKAY LET'S OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARINGS AFRICAN NATIONS TO
PROVE AS PROPOSED IN
[inaudible]
REQUEST THEM.
SUB MODEL REPORTING WHICH
ACTUALLY WILL COME IN
[inaudible]
TOMORROW.
GREAT.
LET'S CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING --
THERE'S A MOTION [inaudible]
TO APPROVED.
ALL RIGHT PLEASE CULTURAL.
WHITE HOUSE BY JONES MCGUIRE
MONNING.
STERN.
WE'LL KEEP THAT MATTER OPEN FOR
THOSE ABSENT MEMBERS LET'S MOVE
TWO HARBORS IN WILD WATER CRAFT
THE REVOLVING FUND SURE THIS IS
ISSUE THIRTY TWO AND THIS IS A
STABILIZATION PROPOSAL. FOR TWO
OF US OUR SPECIAL FUNDS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION IS.
ANTICIPATED APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN INCREASED ON
GOING REVENUES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO THE PASSAGE OF SB.
ONE HOWEVER THIS ESTIMATE IS NOW
LOWER DO IT A REFINEMENT OF THE
FORMULA USED BY CONTROL AGENCIES
TO CALCULATE THE FUEL TAX
REVENUES.
AVAILABLE FOR OUR PROGRAMS --
THIS PROPOSAL HERE BEFORE YOU
PROVIDES GENERAL FUND SUPPORT --
TO PREVENTING THE COMMITMENT TO
THE FIX OUR PARKS PROPOSAL
APPROVED BY THE LEGISLATURE LAST
YEAR -- BY WAY OF A LITTLE MORE
DETAIL PROVIDES THIRTY FIVE
MILLION POINT SEVEN MIL POINT
SEVEN AND ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
AND NINE POINT SEVEN MILLION ON
GOING GENERAL FUND TO ADDRESS.
THE STATE PARKS AND RECREATION
FUND SHORTFALL HAND A REVERSION
OF TWENTY THREE MILLION IN ON
COMMITTED PRIOR YOUR HARBORS AND
WATERCRAFT FUNDS TO ADDRESS THE
HARBORS MARKUP FUND SHORTFALL --
ALSO PART OF THIS PACKAGE IS
PROPOSED BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WILL CLARIFY EFFECTUATE
THESE CHANGES [inaudible]
YEAH.
YEAH LA OF YOUR COMMENTS ON SAID
IT IS A VERY UNFORTUNATE
SITUATION ADMIT THAT THIS LEAVES
YOUR PARKS IS REALLY UNFORTUNATE.
THE AND THAT SEE PARKS
RECREATION FENDER SPUR FRIEND
HAD THAT AND HAD IT'S TIME TO
FIND A BALANCE CONCERNS OVER THE
YEARS WITH THE PASSAGE OF SB
WENDY COMPREHEND COMPREHENSIVE
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING PACKAGE.
ON THAT ALSO HAD A SMALL AMOUNT
OF MANY AND THAT WAS GOING TO
PARKS AND IT REALLY SORT OF
SHORT UP THIS BIRTH AND PROVIDED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
AND THE FOR THAT THE FIX OUR
PARKS INITIATIVE AS WAS ALLUDED
TALE.
AND THE ISSUE HERE IS THAT IN
THE VARIOUS AND TRANSFERS AND
CALCULATIONS ATTY WAS BASICALLY
OVER ESTIMATED HOW MUCH MONEY
WAS GOING TO BE COMING FROM SB
WHEN. TO ASK FOR IF AS WELL AS
THE HARBORS AND WATERCRAFT
REVOLVING FIND AND AND THROUGH
THE COURSE AS I DECIDING HOW TO
SPEND THEIR TO SHOW SB WHEN
FRIENDS.
I IN THE CURRENT YEAR BASICALLY
THESE ACCOUNTS FOR OVER
COMMITTED ARE BASED ON THE
REVENUES ARE ACTUALLY COMING AND
AND SO THE PROPOSAL HERE IS SORT
OF ADDRESSING AND IT'S THE ISSUE
IS BIGGER IN NINETEEN TWENTY
BECAUSE YOU HAVE A COUPLE YEARS
WORTH OF REVENUE THAT HAVE BEEN
COMING.
IN LOWER THAN ESTIMATED -- AND
SO ADDRESSING THAT BUT IT'S ALSO
I'M PROPOSING FOR THIS FIRST
ANYWAYS TO HAVE AN ONGOING AND
NINE POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND BACK FELL.
AND THE WE WOULD JUST SORT OF
NOTE GIVEN HOW RECENTLY AS SOME
OF THESE AUGMENTATIONS WERE PUT
INTO PLACE FOR PARKS.
AND ME JUST BEING IN THE CURRENT
YEAR THAT THE LEGISLATURE ALWAYS
WHEN YOU'RE DEALING WITH A FIND.
IN IMBALANCE ISSUE WHERE YOU'RE-EXPENDITURES ARE OUTPACING YOUR
REVENUES.
AND YOU KNOW YOU CAN USE GENERAL
FUND TO BACK FILL IT YOU CAN
ALSO BRING YOUR EXPENDITURES
DOWN AND GIVEN HOW RECENTLY.
THESE AUGMENTATIONS WERE MADE
AND WE DID THINK THAT IT MIGHT
BE A ONE APPROACH FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER IT'S AN OPTION -- TO
MAYBE MODERATE SOME OF THOSE
AUGMENTATIONS IN ORDER TO BRING --
THAT THE FIX OUR PARKS FOR PULLS
ALL MORE IN LINE WITH THE ACTUAL
REVENUES ON THE HARBORS AND
WATERCRAFT SIDE I WOULD JUST TO
NOTE THAT.
ON THE THE PROPOSAL HERE IS A
ONE TIME SOLUTION AND SO -- WE
WOULD EXPECT TO SEE THAT THE
MINISTRATION WOULD BRING FOR AN
ONGOING SOLUTION TO THAT PROBLEM --
SOMETIME NEXT YEAR AND THAT
FRIEND HAS A SIXTEEN AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLAR SHORTFALL ON TO
EVEN LARGER THAN THIS.
FOR SHORTFALL AND AND NOT WILL
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED AND SO TO
THE EXTENT THAT THAT IS ALSO
ADDRESSED WITH I AM ON ONGOING
GENERAL FUND COMMITMENT THAT
WOULD BE ANOTHER SIXTEEN AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS.
I THAT THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
THE MINISTRATION WILL BE LOOKING
AT AND COMING BACK OUR NEXT YEAR
YEAH BECAUSE THERE'S A BREAKDOWN
BETWEEN THE TAX.
THE TAX OF MONEY TO COME INTO
THE BOAT FOLKS AND I GUESS THE
TAX MONEY COMES INTO THE THE
PARK PEOPLE MAGAZINE SOME PARKS
OF BOATS BUT THOSE ARE.
THAT'S IT.
EASILY SEPARATED A CALCULATION
WHICH SOMEBODY'LL GET RIGHT THIS
YEAR -- OKAY THE I GUESS THE
QUESTION ALEJO HE SAID NO THIS
IS NOT THE FIRST TIME WE'VE HAD
WE'VE WITH ROCKET I DON'T WANT
TO OPEN IT UP ON THE BACKLOG OF
PARK.
YOU KNOW REPAIRS THAT NEED TO BE
DONE IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S I
REMEMBER THE BE NUMBER COMING UP
AND HAVE.
A BILLIONS OF MONEY THAT NEEDS
TO BE VERSUS A YOU KNOW A STATE
GENERAL FUND.
CONTRIBUTION SOMETHING SOUTH OF
TEN MILLION SO I THINK THAT THAT
TEN IN THE BIGGER PICTURE LEAST
PREVIOUS HEARINGS THAT WE'VE HAD.
THE PROBLEM IS GIGANTIC AND IN
THIS IS.
I GUESS WE'VE MADE MISTAKES SO
GONNA FIX THE MISTAKE AND THEN.
KEEP PAN I'M GOING ONE WAY LOOK
AT IT -- ALL RIGHT.
LET'S THIS IS THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS APPROVED AS
PROPOSE LET'S HOPE UP PUBLIC
HEARING ON THIS [inaudible]
OKAY.
YOU GET LUCKY THIS TIME KNOWN AS
KIDNEY CAM K<c.cyan> THIS KIDDING.</c>
MAY RIVERS MAKING THAT FOR POLL
OF WHO'S EVER MAKING THOSE SB
ONE CALCULATIONS ON THE FUEL TAX.
SHARPEN THE PENCIL -- ALL RIGHT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE CASKEY HI JONES MCGUIRE.
MINING.
STERN.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE THREE VOTES
LET'S KEEP THAT MATTER OPEN FOR
THE AFTER MEMBERS AND THAT'S IT.
FOR PARKS AND RECREATION.
LET'S CALL OF SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY.
AND THE FRIEND PAVLEY MEADOW THE
THE SEVENTY YEAR AS OWSKI LAST
VERGE JANICE.
HARRY HAD HE VERY HEINOUS
VIRGINIA VIRGIN ASSESS VIRGINIS.
HIGHLAND PARK IN MANY OTHER
PRIORITY LOCATIONS.
I'M BRING CASH IN WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY HERE
REPRESENTING THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU IS FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ONE
TIME.
INTO POSITIONS -- WITH FIVE
YEARS OF SPENDING.
AUTHORITY -- TO COVER THE COSTS
THE STATE COSTS OF THE FIRE
DAMAGE -- DONE BY THE WILL SEE
FIRE -- THE CONSERVANCY HAD TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF ACRES THAT WERE
AFFECTED IN LOTS OF FACILITIES
SO THIS FUNDING WILL BE THE
STATE FUNDING TOWARDS ACTUALLY
REPEAT MAKING THOSE REPAIRS AND
DOING THE RESTORATION WORK
NEEDED.
SIMILAR TO PARKS THE CONSERVANCY
IS GOING TO PRIORITIZE SAFETY
FIRST.
AND THEN MOVE ON TO OPENING UP
THE PARKS IN ALLOWING PEOPLE TO
GET BACK ON THE TRAILS AS YOU
MENTIONED.
WE'RE NOT NAIVE TO THINK THAT
FIFTEEN MILLION WILL COVER
EVERYTHING WE JUST REALIZED THIS
IS THIS BUDGET REQUEST AND AS WE
LOOK AT THIS -- DIFFERENT
AMENITIES ALEJO.
WE DIDN'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS AT
THIS PROPOSAL AND THAT THE FIFTY
MILLION OUR UNDERSTANDING IS
SUPPOSED TO BE THE EXTENT OF
THEIR REQUEST AND THE PROPOSAL
DID HAVE A LOT MORE DETAIL CAM --
THEN THE PARKS PROPOSAL DID IN
TERMS OF HOW THE FUNDS TO BE
SPENT -- AND WHERE AND HOUSES
AND EVEN OUTLINED IN YOUR AGENDA
HERE WHAT AND WHAT WORK NEEDS TO
BE DONE AND AND HOW WOULD BE
PRIORITIZED IN SO WE DIDN'T HAVE
ANY CONCERNS ABOUT NEEDING HAD
LEGISLATURE NEEDING ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION.
AND OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE A MULTI
YEAR AND THAT THIS WOULD BE THE
EXTENT OF THE PROPOSAL.
AND AND SO WE WE FELT
INFORMATION HERE IS SUFFICIENT.
RIGHT TO SEPARATE CONDITIONS TO
PROVE HIS PROPOSED LET'S OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC HEARING ANYBODY.
ON THE SANTA MONICA [inaudible]
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY.
ONCE I REQUEST.
CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING BRING IT
BACK.
THERE'S IN MOTION BY CENTERS
TERM PLEASE CALL THE ROLL LAKE
CASKEY HIGH.
JONES REQUIRE MONEY [inaudible]
TURN [inaudible]
WE OKAY THANK YOU ARE THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES IS
ISSUE NUMBER -- THIRTY FOUR AND
ISSUE NUMBER.
THIRTY FIVE IN ISSUE NUMBER.
THIRTY SIX D. W. R. GOOD
AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS OUR CO COME
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR FLOOD
MANAGEMENT DAM SAFETY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF RESOURCES.
I WILL BE ADDRESSING THE NEXT
THREE ITEMS -- WITH SOME EXPERT
THAT I BROUGHT ALONG WITH ME.
WELL THE FIRST ISSUES DELIVERS
REQUEST WAR SICKENING POSITIONS
OF ONE POINT SIX TWO FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS OF ONGOING
FUNDING FROM THE DAM SAFETY FUND.
GIVEN THIS OF THE REMAINING
THREE YEARS OF THE ONE POINT
SIXTY FIVE MILLION ANNUAL
FEEDBACK OF THE GENERAL FUND
LOAN MADE IN -- TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TO INCORPORATE RISK INFORMED
DECISION MAKING INTO THE
CALIFORNIA DAM SAFETY PROGRAM.
AS RECOMMENDED BY THE TECHNICAL
ADVISORY PANEL PROCESS SPELLED
OUT IN -- OR AB.
EIGHT TWELVE SEVENTY SO WITH
THAT.
WHAT'S THE FIRST.
ONE AB SEVEN YEAH.
WHEN YOU GET HERE?
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO BRING UP
CHAIR AND HAPPIER TO DISCUSS THE
ISSUE FURTHER WITH YOU WE GET A
LITTLE BIT OUT OF WHACK THERE ON
OUR SCHEDULE.
CAMEOS ANXIOUS TO GO SO WITH
THAT SHARED HAPPY AS SHE IS THE
CHIEF OF THE DIVISION OF SAFETY
OF DAMS -- AND HAS THE DETAILS
OF THIS PROPOSAL.
I GET AFTERNOON -- AS ERIC SAID --
I'M THE CHIEF OF THE DIVISION A
SAFETY DAM.
DANCE AND WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE OVERSIGHT OF THE CALIFORNIA
DAM SAFETY PROGRAM.
AND THAT PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED
NINETY YEARS AGO THIS YEAR AFTER
THAT CATASTROPHIC FAILURE OF THE
SAINT FRANCIS DAM.
WE HAVE REGULATORY OVERSIGHT OF
APPROXIMATELY TWELVE HUNDRED
FIFTY NINE FEDERAL DAMS ACROSS
THE STATE.
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED FIFTY OF THOSE
DAMS ARE CONSIDERED HIGH OR
EXTREMELY HIGH HAZARD.
IN THAT MEANS IF.
THERE IS A FAILURE OUT ONE OF
THOSE DAMS IT WOULD HAVE AT
LEAST ONE LOSS OF LIFE.
AND THAT'S BY THE FEDERAL
DEFINITION -- SINCE HAZARD
POTENTIAL DOESN'T REALLY --
INDICATE.
AS THE SAFETY OF THE DAM WE
CONDUCT BOTH -- FIELD
INSPECTIONS IN RE EVALUATIONS TO
ASSESS THE SAFETY OF THE DAM.
TRADITIONALLY WE'VE BEEN DOING
THIS ACTUALLY SINCE -- THE
FAILURE OF THIS -- BALDWIN HILLS
DAM THAT OCCURRED IN THE SIXTIES
THAT'S WHEN OUR PROGRAM FIRST
STARTED READ LOOKING AT DAMS.
BECAUSE BY THEN THOSE DAMS WORD
NEARLY AGING FIFTY YEARS AT THAT
TIME RIGHT.
AND CONDITIONS HAD CHANGED
BECAUSE OF DOWNSTREAM POPULATION
INCREASE.
IN SO WITH THAT IF YOU MOVE
AHEAD INTO THE EARLY SEVENTIES
WE HAD THE SAN FERNANDO
EARTHQUAKE.
THAT NEARLY I WILL FAILED THE
UPSTREAM OF LOWER SAN FERNANDO
DAM.
AND ABOUT EIGHTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
WERE EVACUATED IN THAT REALLY
TRIGGERED THE ONSET OF
UNDERSTANDING SEISMIC IN THE
STATE.
AND SINCE THAT TIME SEISMIC
EVALUATIONS HAS BEEN A BIG FOCUS
OF THE PROGRAM BUT IT'S BEEN A
VERY FOCUSED -- EVALUATION
APPROACH IN A VERY TRADITIONAL
APPROACH SO WE WOULD LOOK AT
WHAT'S THE HIGHEST RISK FOR
DANCING IN CALIFORNIA GIVEN OUR
OUR COMPLEX GEOLOGY IN OUR
SEISMIC ACTIVITY IT'S IT'S BEEN
SEISMIC.
AND SO WITH THAT WE FOCUSED ON
SIZE MAKING WE'VE ALSO FOCUSED --
AS INCIDENTS OCCUR SO WE HAVE
THAT A FULSOME GATE FILL YOUR
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE SO WE DID A
SPECIAL STUDY OF RADIO GATES.
IN THE STATE -- AND SO WITH THAT
APPROACH WE'RE ALWAYS LOOKING AT
PARTICULAR FAILURE MODES.
A YOU KNOW A SINGLE TYPE OF
FAILURE MODE FOR AS A DAM AND WE
WOULD BE LOOKING AT DOES IT DOES.
HOW DOES THE DEMAND IN THE
CAPACITY RELATE TO EACH OTHER
AND WE WOULD COME UP LIKE WITH
THE FACTOR OF SAFETY?
I AM GOING FORWARD SO THAT
METHOD HAD HAD PROVEN PROVEN OUT
WELL WE WERE YOU KNOW WITH THE
STANDARDS AT THE TIME -- BUT
THAT'S A VERY.
LABOR INTENSIVE WAY TO DO RE
EVALUATIONS AND SO WE ONLY GET
THROUGH ABOUT TEN TO TWENTY DAMS
A YEAR WITH THAT APPROACH.
AND AGAIN WE'RE ONLY LOOKING AT
ONE FAILURE MODE SO IF THEY DARE
MEETS THE SEISMIC FAILURE MODE
WE MOVE ON TO THE NEXT DOWN. FOR
SEISMIC WE DON'T SIT THERE AND
LOOK AT EVERY SINGLE PIECE OF
THE DAM COMPREHENSIVELY AND LOOK
AT HOW ELSE COULD THIS DIEM FAIL.
NO COULD HAVE FAILED THROUGH THE
OUTLET PIPE COULD FAIL THROUGH
THE SPILL WAY WHAT OTHER MEANS
WOULD BECAUSE THE FAILURE.
SO -- WITH THAT WE HAVE AB
TWELVE SEVENTY THAT WAS ENACTED
JUST LAST YEAR.
AND NOW IS ACTUALLY ENACTED
UNDER EMERGENCY CLAUSE.
IN IT REQUIRED OUR PROGRAMS TO
HAVE.
A A PEER REVIEW. TO A CONVENE A
PANEL OF INDEPENDENT EXPERTS OF
DAM SAFETY FROM NATIONAL DAM
SAFETY ORGANIZATIONS.
AND IN PARTICULAR THE LANGUAGE
IN THE LEGISLATION STATED WE
ALSO HAD TO HAVE RISK MANAGEMENT.
INCORPORATED INTO OUR PROTOCOLS.
IN SO WELL WITH THAT DIRECTIVE
LAST YEAR WE CONVENED A PANEL OF
HIGHLY RECOGNIZED EXPERTS IN DAM
SAFETY.
WE HAD FOURTEEN MEMBERS AND WE
HAD REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
ASSOCIATION A STATE DAM SAFETY
OFFICIALS.
WE HAD THE US SOCIETY ON DAMS.
AND WE HAD THE ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS AS SPECIALLY FOR THEIR
EXPERTISE AND RISK.
AND WE ALSO HAD THE U. S. BUREAU
OF RECLAMATION AGAIN FOR THEIR
EXPERTISE AND RISK.
SO WE HAD A VERY COMPREHENSIVE
PANEL WE ALSO HAD OTHER STATE
REGULATORS ON THE PANEL WE HAD --
A FEW DAM OWNERS -- TENNESSEE
VALLEY AUTHORITY WAS ANOTHER
MEMBER OF THE PANEL AND WE HAD
SOME CONSULTANTS.
ON THE PANEL SO IT WAS A REALLY.
IT WAS A REALLY GOOD PANEL AND
SO WE MET AT THREE TIMES LAST
YEAR IN IN PERSON THEY ALL CAME
TO SACRAMENTO WE PRESENTED OUR
PROGRAM TO THEM.
AND THEY'RE THEY'RE PRETTY MUCH
THEIR SOUL RECOMMENDATION IS
CALIFORNIA YOU NEED TO BE DOING
RISK.
WHICH IS WHICH IS.
NO WE WEREN'T SURPRISED -- THE
INTERSTATE HE HAD ADVANCED QUITE
A BIT PROBABLY IN THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS.
IN TERMS OF RISK MANAGEMENT AND
DAM SAFETY AND THAT WAS
SOMETHING WE HAD NOT YET --
STARTED DOING WE DID IT AND
FORMALLY WE CONSIDERED RISK
OBVIOUSLY WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT
EARTHQUAKES WERE LOOKING AT THE
PROBABILITY OF THE EARTHQUAKE.
BUT NOT TO THE FORMALIZED
METHODOLOGIES THAT THE ARMY
CORPS AND THE BUREAU OF
RECLAMATION DO FOR THEIR DAMS.
AND THEY THOUGHT BASED ON THE
SIZE OF OUR PROGRAM AND BEING
THE LARGEST STAMP SAFETY PROGRAM
IN THE NATION WE REALLY NEEDED
TO IMPLEMENT RISK MANAGEMENT
INTO OUR PROGRAM.
AND SO THAT'S THE PROPOSAL
THAT'S IN THE B. C. P. IT'S FOR
SIX POSITIONS.
AND AT A COST OF ONE POINT SIX
TWO FIVE MILLION.
WE'VE RECENTLY INCREASED OUR OUR
DAM FEES.
AND OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS ARE
DAM FEES HAVE GONE UP ABOUT 55%.
AND SO THE PROPOSAL IN THE B. C.
P. IS TO ACTUALLY -- HAVE A LOAN
FORGIVENESS FOR THE NEXT THREE
YEARS OF PAYMENT OF OUR GENERAL
FUND LOAN THAT WE RECEIVED IN.
TWO YEARS AGO.
AND THAT WOULD M. COMPLETELY
OFFSET ANY FEE INCREASES THAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED FOR THIS
PROPOSAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SO.
THESE ARE PRIVATELY OWNED DAMS.
THAT THE STATE IS INSPECTING FOR
THE RISK ANALYSIS AND THE SAFETY.
CORRECT SO WE HAVE -- WE HAVE.
S. ABOUT SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY
NINE DAM OWNERS.
AND IT'S COMPRISED OF MULTIPLE
TYPE OF OWNERS YOU GOT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AS AN OWNER YOU
HAVE COUNTIES.
YOU OF WATER DISTRICTS YOU HAVE
IRRIGATION DISTRICTS.
YOU HAVE PRIVATE CITIZENS
FARMERS AND RANCHERS YOU HAVE
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS.
A IS SO IT'S A IT'S ACROSS THE
GAMUT OF THE TYPE OF OWNERSHIP.
MUST BE FROM WHEN YOU GUYS ALL
GET TOGETHER SO -- AND SOME OF
THESE DAMS WERE BUILT OBVIOUSLY
AT DIFFERENT TIMES WERE RISK
ANALYSIS WAS.
HOCUS POCUS PEOPLE YEAH YOU
BUILT YOUR YOU OFFER YOU YOU HAD
TO USE THAT YOU HAD BUT THERE
WAS NO STATE.
RISK MANAGEMENT CROWD COMING
INTO TO LOOK TO LOOK AT YOUR
YOUR DAM -- SO.
I'M TRYING TO EVALUATE I GET THE
ONE POINT SIX MILLION AND I GET
DE DE.
GRACE PERIOD ONE TWO OR THREE
YEARS THAT YOU WANT TO NOT HAVE
THESE LOANS PAID BACK TO THE
STATE SO THAT THE OR FORGIVE THE
LOANS SO THAT THE DAM OWNERS.
WILL.
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PAY THE
HIGHER FEES SHE GONE UP 55% GET
IT I GET IT I GUESS THE QUESTION
IS BIGGER PICTURE [inaudible]
IS THAT.
IF WE DON'T OWN THAT ADVOCATE
SOME OF THE STATE TAKE THE STATE
DAMS OUT IF THESE ARE OWNED BY
OTHER PEOPLE OR OTHER ENTITIES
AND THEY CREATE A RISK.
NOT TODAY WE THOUGHT IT WAS
GONNA BE REST WHEN THEY BUILT IT
BUT THERE'S REST NOW -- AND NOW
WE'RE GOING TO GET. SIX MORE
PEOPLE OUT THERE DOING THE SUPER
DUPER RISK MANAGEMENT ON DAMS
NOT JUST EARTHQUAKE OR NOT JUST
SPILL WAY BECAUSE I GET.
YOU KNOW WE TEN THE OVER
OVERSIMPLIFICATION RESPOND TO
HERE'S A CATASTROPHE PLEASE HELP
MY DISTRICT OUT HELP THIS AND
AND NOW DO THIS GET THESE PEOPLE
TO INSPECTED THEY'RE NOT OUR
DAMS I MEAN I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
THEY'RE PART OF OUR SYSTEM AND
WE WANT TO PROTECT LIFE AND LIMB.
LIFE AND ALL THAT SO WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT IT BUT HOW DO WE
OKAY SAID THE SAID THERE'S A
JUSTIFICATION THAT WE'RE THE
FACT -- SUBSIDIZING THE PRIVATE
OWNERS IF THEY'RE NOT PAYING
BACK THE LOANS THAT THEY OWN --
BUT BUT IS THE IS THE IDEA THAT.
IN THREE YEARS THEY'RE GOING TO
JUST HAVE TO PASS ON RATES TO
WATER USERS OR DO WHATEVER THEY
NEED TO DO TO GET THEIR
FINANCIAL HOUSE.
IN ORDER TO PAY FOR THAT.
NOT ONLY JUST THE ANALYSIS OF
YOU YOUR FOLKS TO SAY THIS IS
WRONG THIS IS WRONG BUT FIX IT.
YOU KNOW DO WAY WOULD NEED TO BE
DONE IS THAT.
THE PLAY HERE.
WELL SO I THINK WE'VE ALWAYS
DONE RISK MANAGEMENT IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE GO WHAT WE WANT TO
CONCENTRATE A WE GO OUT TO
REVIEW DAM SAFETY OKAY WE
REQUIRED REVIEW THE DAMS
ANNUALLY.
SO WE MAY BE LOOKING AT
SPILLWAYS A MAY BE LOOKING AT
THE DAM STRUCTURES ITSELF.
WHAT THIS WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
IS TO INCORPORATE THIS RISK OF
FOR MANAGEMENT THIS IS A
PROCESSES USED BY THE CORPS OF
ENGINEERS?
AND AND THE US BUREAU INTO OUR
THINKING AS TO HOW WE AS
REGULATORS IN CALIFORNIA OF
THESE DAMS CAN MORE QUICKLY ZERO
IN ON THOSE TO HAVE SERIOUS
PROBLEMS.
AND THEN WORK WITH THOSE OWNERS
TO MAKE SURE THE CORRECT THOSE
PROBLEMS SO IT'S KIND OF A A UGH.
MOVING INTO THE THE STATED THE
PRACTICE IF YOU WILL IN TERMS OF
HOW WE APPROACH WHAT ARE JOBS
ARE IN REGARDS -- TO MANAGING --
DETERMINING WHAT THAT RISK OF
THOSE DAMS ARE OUT THERE BUT I
GOT TO BELIEVE THAT SOME OF
THESE DAMS WERE BUILT FIFTY
SIXTY YEARS AGO WITH NOT.
EVEN WHEN THEY WERE BUILT THEY
WERE NOT TOPLINE DAMS IF YOU
COULD IF I COULD SAY THAT YOU
KNOW THE WHATEVER THEY WERE JUST
BUILT BECAUSE HE NEEDED AN
IRRIGATION SYSTEM OR WHATEVER
WHEREVER PEOPLE WERE DOING AND
NOW WE'VE GOT.
PEOPLE LIVE IN IN THE IN THE
AREA SOME PEOPLE LIVE IN THEIR
NATIVE DID THERE'S BEEN.
OTHER DECISIONS NOT THE STATE'S
DECISIONS OTHER LOCAL DECISIONS
THAT HAVE PT PEOPLE IN HARM'S
WAY -- THAT YOU GUYS ARE
EVALUATING TAT.
HE BUT YOU WANT TO DO IT ANYWAY
NO I GUESS NOT.
WHAT TO DO THE EVALUATION TO SEE
WHO THE IT'S PART OF WHAT WE DO
I MEAN THAT'S FINE?
WHAT WE DO IN TERMS THAT'S WHO
WE ARE IT'S WHAT WE ARE IN TERMS
OF REGULATION OF DAMS YES AND
SAFETY AND IS BITING FOR THAT
SAFETY A DOWNSTREAM AND YOU'RE
CORRECT OVER THE YEARS OVER THE
DECADES?
THERE THAT SAFETY CONCERN HAS
GROWN BECAUSE PEOPLE MOVED INTO
THE BOTTOM NEXT TO THEM SO HOLD
ON TO MAKE SURE THOSE DAMS ARE
AS SAFE AS POSSIBLE AND THIS IS
A METHODOLOGY A WAY OF THINKING.
OF HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET THERE
SO WHAT POWER DOES THE STATE
HAVE TO TELL A DAM OWNER
[inaudible] TWO TAKE DOWN YOUR
IT'S NOT SAFE FOR OR JUST
THERE'S NO THERE'S NO REPAIR
WORK THIS COULD GO ON HERE GIVEN
THE NEW ANALYSIS THAT ARE
[inaudible] SIX INFORMED WRIST.
DECISION MAKING DAM SAFETY.
FOLKS ARE GOING TO DO. THIRTY
EIGHT DEMENTORS STATE THEY HAVE
A LOT OF RESPONSIBILITY HAM
LIABILITY SO YOU KNOW THEY'RE
OBVIOUSLY RESPONSIBLE THEY FULLY
FOUNDER PROGRAM AS IT IS RIGHT
NOW.
THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE THEY'VE
BEEN RESPONSIBLE FOR AND
DEVELOPING THEIR INUNDATION MAPS.
THE LEGISLATION AS BE NINETY TWO
THEY'RE EA PEAS WE'VE HAD --
QUITE A FEW OF THEM GO OUT AND
DO CONDITION ASSESSMENTS ON
THEIR SPILLWAYS GET DATA.
AND WHENEVER WE COME UP WITH A
DEFICIENCY.
THEY HAVE TO GO OUT AND GET A
CONSULTING ENGINEER THEY HAVE TO
ALSO ANALYZE IT THEY HAVE TO
COME UP WITH A PLAN TO FIX IT
AND THEY HAVE TO FIND THE
FUNDING TO FIX IT.
AND SO ULTIMATELY THE DAY BEAR
THAT BIG TICKET COST ON DAM
OWNERSHIP AND WHAT THIS DOES IS
ALLOW US TO GET THREE WHERE I
MENTIONED WE DO TEND TO TWENTY A
YEAR.
THE GOAL WITH THIS IS A SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY HIGH HAZARD
DAMS WE WOULD BE EVALUATING THEM
ABOUT EVERY FIFTEEN YEARS.
RIGHT.
ALL OF THEM NOT TEN TO TWENTY A
YEAR WHICH WOULD TAKE IS. THREE
DECADES TO GET HER AND HENCE
WE'RE GONNA FIND GIVE YOU THIS
LITTLE LOAN BALANCE WILL FORGIVE
THAT OVER THE NEXT THREE YEARS
AND THE BIG THE BIG CHALLENGES
THE BIG -- TICKET ITEMS PRICE
TICKET ITEMS ARE GOING TO BE
THERE.
ELLIE -- AND THEN SENT.
THE FEES THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS
CHARGING THE DEMOS HAVE ALREADY
BEEN RAISED SO THEY WERE RAISED.
35% IN THE CURRENT YEAR AND THEY
WILL BE REYES 20% AGAIN IN THE
BUDGET YEAR TO COVER THE COSTS
OF SOME OF THE PREVIOUS
INCREASED ACTIVITIES THE
DEPARTMENT'S REQUIRING SO THE
INUNDATION MAPS AND THE
EMERGENCY ACTION PLANS. FOR
THOSE THOSE COSTS ARE ALREADY
THOSE FEES ARE ALREADY INCREASED
ON THE DAM OWNERS AND WOOD AND
WILL BE TO COVER THOSE -- IF.
AND THEN ONCE THEY TAKE CARE OF
THOSE ONE TIME ACTIVITIES THEN
THOSE HIGHER FEES THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN INCREASED WILL
START TO COVER THE SIX NEW
POSITIONS SO I THINK THE
PROPOSAL THE FROM THE DEPARTMENT
IS TO AVOID.
AND A DIVISIONAL INCREASE FOR
THESE NEW POSITIONS OVER THE
NEXT THREE YEARS SO IT'S NOT
AVOIDING.
THEM INCREASING NOW THEY THEY
ARE FACING INCREASES NOW IS JUST
BE KIND OF THE DOUBLE WHAMMY
ABOVE THAT 55% FOR THREE YEARS.
SO IN IN OUR AN ANALYSIS IT IS
YOU KNOW IT IS A LITTLE BIT
INCONSISTENT WITH OUR
BENEFICIARY PAYS.
PRACTICE THAT WE USUALLY HAVE
FOR THE DAM OWNERS BUT GIVEN
IT'S A RELATIVELY MODERATE
AMOUNT OF GENERAL FUND FOUR
POINT NINE MILLION AND IT IS
BEEN A LOT OF INCREASED COSTS
AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
IN A RELATIVELY SHORT TIME
PERIOD ON THESE OWNERS WE THINK
IT'S REASONABLE CEREMONY OF
QUESTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO
[inaudible]
I'M.
I'M OLD ENOUGH TO REMEMBER THE
BALDWIN HILLS.
FAILURE AND WATCHING THAT ON
TELEVISION.
WAS ONE OF THE FIRST REAL TIME
DISASTERS I THINK ON TV.
MORE RECENTLY WE PARTICIPATED
WITH YOUR DIVISION IN THE
REMOVAL OF THE SAME CALL MANY
DAM IN THE UPPER CARMEL RIVER
WHICH WAS ONE OF THE LARGEST DAM
REOVAL PROJECTS.
PERHAPS ANYWHERE CERTAINLY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT MY QUESTION -- SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY DAMS CURRENTLY CLASSIFIED
AS HIGH OR EXTREMELY HIGH HAZARD --
WITH THESE NEW POSITIONS OR WITH
CURRENT PLANNING.
ARE YOU DOING ANY.
EVALUATION I'M WITH AMONG THOSE.
SIX HUNDRED FIFTY DO YOU HAVE
ANY RANKING AMONG THOSE OF ONES
THAT POSE A GREATER RISK THAN
OTHERS IN TERMS OF PROXIMITY TO
POPULATION.
CENTERS OR NEW POPULATION
CENTERS OR LIKELIHOOD OF FAILURE
VERSES.
SIZE MAKE SOME SEISMIC ISSUES
BUT NOT AN EVALUATION OF LIKELY
FAILURE -- CORRECT CORRECT -- AS
WE'VE BEEN DOING OUR SEISMIC
REVALUATION PROGRAM OVER THE
LAST TEN TWENTY YEARS THAT'S WE
WE ALWAYS START OFF WITH THE
SCREENING ASSESSMENT.
AND WE WOULD LOOK AT THE AGE OF
THE DAM HOW IT WAS CONSTRUCTED
BECAUSE THAT PLAYS INTO HOW.
HOW WELL IT CAN WITHSTAND AN
EARTHQUAKE AND THEN THE
PROXIMITY TO THE CLOSEST
EARTHQUAKE IN WHAT THE?
SHAKING WOULD BE AT THAT DAM
SITE AND SO WE HAD A WE HAVE A
LIST OF FACTORS IN WE WOULD DO
AN INITIAL SCREENING.
BUT THAT WAS REALLY SOLELY
FOCUSED ON SEISMIC IT WASN'T
LOOKING AT ALL THE OTHER FIFTEEN
PLUS WAYS A CAN FAIL.
AND REALLY GETTING IN DEPTH INTO
IT AND AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
THIS RISK INFORMED DECISION
MAKING PROCESS WILL ALLOW US TO
DO IS LOOK AT ALL THOSE AT THE
WRISTS TOGETHER ALONG WITH.
THE HIGH POPULATION AREAS AND
THOSE HIGH RISK MY DAMAGED AREAS
DOWNSTREAM IF YOU WILL AND THEN
PRIORITIZE THEM BASED ON THAT%
THAT'S THE WHOLE GOAL OVER
TRYING TO DO [inaudible]
IN.
SHARE WITH ME AGAIN WITH WITH
THIS ALLOCATION.
AGAIN WITH A TOTAL OF TWELVE
HUNDRED FIFTY DAM SOME SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY RATED HIGH RISK OR
EXTREMELY HIGH HAZARD.
HOW OFTEN WILL YOU WILL THERE BE
AN ANNUAL -- ASSESSMENT OF EACH
OF THESE STAMPS.
THE LETTER CURRENTLY YET
CURRENTLY WE GET THROUGH ABOUT.
ACTUALLY FOR CLOSE TO A DOZEN A
YEAR YOU KNOW I SAY TEN TO
TWENTY BUT IT REALLY DEPENDS ON
THE OTHER WORK LET IT'S GOING ON
WITH THE OWNERS THAT HAVE PLANS
AND SPECS WHO WANT TO GET OUT
THERE AND DO THEIR REPAIRS.
AND SO LET'S JUST SAY WE DO A
DOZEN A YEAR WITH THIS THE GOAL
WOULD BE TO DO THE SCREENING AND
TO PRIORITIZE SEIZE THE FAILURE
MODES.
ABOUT ONE OF ON A BASIS OF ABOUT
EVERY FIFTEEN YEARS FOR THE
ENTIRE INVENTORY.
IN ITS USING A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT APPROACH AND IT'S A
DIFFERENT IT'S IT SHIPPED IN
CULTURE TO IT'S IT'S RISK
INFORMED DECISION MAKING AND SO
YOU'RE THINKING YEARS CHANGING
HOW YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE THING
AND WHEN IT'S A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM THAT'S NEEDED
TO DO IT.
IT'S CERTAINLY A HUGE
IMPROVEMENT IN A NEW METHODOLOGY.
BEGIN GETTING THROUGH THE MALL
ONCE EVERY FIFTEEN YEARS STILL
CREATES.
QUITE A GAP OF POTENTIAL LACK OF
SURVEILLANCE TO I KNOW IT IT
ACTUALLY DOESN'T BECAUSE IN THE
ENGINEERING INDUSTRY.
TECHNOLOGY AND AND ADVANCES IN
ENGINEERING OCCUR ABOUT EVERY
TEN TO TWENTY YEARS SO WE'RE
GONNA BE RIGHT AT THAT POINT
WHERE THERE ARE CHANGES
OCCURRING LIKE -- NOW I'LL GO
BACK TO SAN FERNANDO NOW WE KNOW
SAM'S LIQUEFY OKAY SO ONCE YOU
START LEARNING NEW YOU KNOW NEW
SEAT RESEARCH.
DEVELOPS YOU'RE GONNA BE
APPLYING THAT EVERY FIFTEEN
YEARS AS YOU GO THROUGH THAT
CYCLE.
IT'S IT'S A MUCH BETTER WAY OF
DOING IT AND IT ALSO REMEMBER.
ANNUALLY WE INSPECT EVERY THAT'S
OUT THERE SO THANK YOU ARE AT
REAL TWENTY AND THAT'S THAT
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
THAT PARTICULAR DAMP FROM THE
SURFACE SIDE OF IT AND THIS IS
ALL ABOUT LOOKING.
BEYOND THAT INTO THESE OTHER
FACTORS THAT CAN CAUSE THEM.
THANK YOU THAT'S A LITTLE MORE
REASSURING YES THIS IS FOR THE
RE EVALUATION PORTION CAN
PRIMARY SHE THE WORKING ON DO
YOU THINK YOU THIS IS ISSUE
NUMBER THIRTY FOUR LET'S OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC HEARING ON THE RE
EVALUATION OF THE THE DEEP
SEARCH ON DAM SAFETY.
OKAY CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING
THERE'S A MOTION TO APPROVE AS
PROPOSED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ASKING HI JONES [inaudible]
REQUIRE [inaudible]
MONEY [inaudible]
STERN.
WE'LL KEEP THAT MATTER OPEN THAT
HAS FOUR VOTES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT.
LITTLE.
THE S. SESSION LET'S GO TO
TRANSPARENT AND OPEN WATER DATA
ACT OF NINE NINE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN GOOD AFTERNOON SURE WORK
OWSKI.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF.
I'M COMEY ARGUE VEGGIE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES.
I OVERSEE.
INTEGRATED STATEWIDE WATER
MANAGEMENT AND AM IN CHARGE OF
IMPLEMENTING DEED OF YOURS PART
SEVENTEEN FIFTY FIVE OTHER
REQUEST BEFORE YOU IS FOR OF AN
ADDITIONAL ONE MILLION FIFTY
EIGHT THOUSAND A YEAR FOR FOUR
YEARS.
OF FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL
LICENSE PLATE FUND THAT
PHILANTHROPIC COMMUNITY LET YOU
DOWN.
HI YES I AND YOU YOU'RE REALLY
CUT TO THE CHASE CHAIR -- IN THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BUDGET
ACT WE WERE AUTHORIZED OF IT IN
A NEW FUND WAS ESTABLISHED THE
WATER DATED MINISTRATION FIND
AND WE WERE AUTHORIZED THE
FUNDING.
AND SCOPE OF WORK TO IMPLEMENT
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY FIVE AT THAT
TIME D. W. R. WAS GIVEN FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND FROM
THE E. L. F. P..
ON AS A BASELINE FUNDING.
AND IT WAS ANTICIPATED THAT THE
BALANCE OF OUR ONE POINT SIX
MILLION REQUEST WOULD BE.
VOLUNTARILY WOULD BE THROUGH
VOLUNTARY DONATIONS TO THIS FUND.
THAT HAS NOT HAPPENED AND THE
REQUESTBEFORE YOU IS NOT
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN A CHANGE IN
THE SCOPE OF WORK OR NEW WORK IT
IS TO FILL THAT BUDGET GAP.
OF WE HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT --
ACCOMPLISHMENTS WE FINISH THE
STRATEGIC PLAN THE INITIAL
PROTOCOLS -- WE ACTUALLY WERE
ABLE TO LEVERAGE TO EXISTING
OPEN DATA PLATFORMS AT THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY AND
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS.
AND FEDERATING OR LINKING THEM
TOGETHER RATHER THAN GOING OUT
AND CREATING A WHOLE NEW I. T.
PROJECT SO WE WE HAVE SAY OF THE
STATE QUITE A BIT OF MONEY BY
LEVERAGING PAST WORK.
WE'RE NOW AT A CRITICAL JUNCTURE
TO ACTUALLY BEGIN PUTTING DATA
SETS ON THIS OPEN DATA PLATFORM.
AND THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING THAT
WERE REQUESTING WOULD ENABLE US
TO MEET STATUTORY DEADLINES THIS
YEAR NEXT YEAR ALL AND THEN SET
THE STAGE FOR THAT FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND ALLOWING
ONGOING MAINTENANCE.
IT'S A FIRST FOR ME THAT WE HAVE
AN I. T. PROGRAM THAT'S EARLY
AND INTEL.
CHEAP.
FLA OF WHAT.
DO YOU HAVE A COMMENT ON THE THE
WATER DATA ACT.
JUST IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT THE
ANA ANTICIPATED NON STATE
FUNDING SOURCES DID MATERIALIZE
BUT IT IS A HIGH PRIORITY FOR
THE STATE AND BEYOND FORTUNATE
TO LOSE THAT PROGRESS WE'VE MADE
AND THE BENEFITS IT WOULD YIELD
SO SEEMS THIS FUNDING IS
NECESSARY.
I HAD THAT SAME EXPERIENCE WHEN
I WAS A CHILD ON CHRISTMAS
MORNING JUSTIN FORTUNE SANTA
DIDN'T.
ANSWER THAT LESS LET'S OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC HEARING THIS IS ISSUE
NUMBER. THIRTY FIVE FOR THE OPEN
AND TRANSPARENT WATER DATA ACT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ADAM ROBIN
WITH THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WATER ASSOCIATION PROJECT
UP.
WE SUPPORT THIS ITEM WE SUPPORT
STAFF RECOMMENDATION CURVES YOU
TO APPROVE THIS ITEM AS PROPOSED
THANK YOU.
THERE'S A MOTION.
SO MOVED BY CENTER STERN PLEASE
CALL ROLL CASKEY HI JONES
[inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
MORNING THANK STERN.
WE'LL KEEP THE PROPOSAL.
TO OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AND LET'S GO TO THE URBAN FLOOD
RISK REDUCTION ACT WITH HER
[inaudible]
LITTLE.
CHART HERE -- FOR THE ORVILLE
WILDLIFE AREA YES I CHECKED YES --
COKE AGAIN -- DEAL BUT DVRS
REQUESTING TO MAKE CHANGES TO
WHAT WE'RE REGIONAL REQUESTED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF INCREASED COSTS.
ON ONE OF OUR PROJECT THAT
PROJECT BEING -- THE ORAL
WILDLIFE AREA WE REGIONAL
REQUESTED TWENTY FIVE MILLION.
A PROP SIXTY FOR FIVE TO
PROJECTS IN TOTAL HOWEVER THE
COSTS -- ADORABLE RIGHT WELL LET
PROJECT OF INCREASED -- DUE TO
UNANTICIPATED BAR MENTAL
PERMITTING REQUIREMENTS HIGHER
CONSTRUCTION COST AND SCOPE
INCREASES TO ADDRESS HYDRAULIC
ELEMENTS.
THAT WILL ULTIMATELY RESULT.
IN MAKING THIS A BETTER PROJECT --
JUST THE SO YOU KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO THE OTHER PROJECTS --
THE BUSHY LAKE AND WOULD LIKE
PROJECTS -- IN THE REGION
REQUEST ARE ARE NOW PART.
OF IN WILL BE FUNDED BY THE
UNITED STATES ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS -- AS FOR THE FOR
FOOTBALL MIDDLE FUNDING THAT WAS
RECEIVED LATE LAST YEAR -- IN
THE MAIL SHIFTED FROM THE RT
SEVENTY PROJECT IS A RELATIVELY
MINOR AMOUNT IN COMPARISON TO
THE PROJECT OVERALL PROJECT
COSTS.
THE PROJECT IS STILL IN THE
SCOPING FEES AND SO THIS TIME WE
DO NOT BELIEVE.
THAT THIS PROJECT WILL BE
ADVERSELY AFFECTED MOVING
FORWARD.
THE REQUESTED TO SHIP FIVE POINT
ONE EIGHT MILLION OF THE
ORIGINAL REQUEST FROM THE THREE
OF OF THE PROJECT OVER WILDLIFE
AREA PROJECT.
BRINGING THE TOTAL COST FOR THE
ORAL PROJECT TO EIGHT POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS.
HELLO YOU HAVE A OF FILE ON THIS
FEATHER RIVER CONNECTIVITY
ACTIVE -- PROPOSAL NO CONCERNS.
LET'S SEE THIS IS THE PROOF.
THIS IS. TWENTY FIVE MILLION OF
FROM UP PROP.
SIX A SIXTY EIGHT RE DIRECTED.
STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS APPROVED
HIS PROPOSALS OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARING ROOMS AT THE GREATER
ORVILLE FEATHER RIVER COMMUNITY
HERE.
CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING MOTION IS
TO APPROVE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CASKEY HI JONES STERN
[inaudible]
THEY'LL KEEP.
A REAL LOOKING FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS IN THIS CALL UP THE AIR
RESOURCE BOARD WE HAVE
EVALUATION AND APPROVAL OF
INNOVATIVE FREE TECHNOLOGY SEVEN
POSITIONS [inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
EXTENSIVE EVALUATION
[inaudible]
ATTENTION.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT AFTERNOON.
THE GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MY
CASKET MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I AM ET CHIANG ON THE DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE OFFICER AT THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD.
I'M WE HAVE TO MAY REVISED
PROPOSALS THAT YOU'LL BE HEARING
TODAY BOTH OF THESE ADDRESS
DIESEL POLLUTION.
WHICH IS THE NUMBER ONE SOURCE
OF AIR TOXICS IN THE STATE AND
BOTH OF THEM ALSO INCLUDE FEET
COMPONENTS TO ENSURE.
THAT AS WE IMPLEMENT -- PROGRAMS
WERE DOING SO AND I FISCALLY
SUSTAINABLE AND PRUDENT MANNER.
SO THIS THE FIRST BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL WERE REQUESTING ONE
POINT THREE TO SIX MILLION
DOLLARS.
FROM THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
FUNDED FOR SEVEN FULL TIME
POSITIONS TO PERFORM APPROVALS
OF NEW TECHNOLOGIES. TO MEET
COMMITMENTS WITHIN THE FREIGHT
SECTOR -- OUR EXISTING
REGULATIONS OUR INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS REQUIRED THAT WE
APPROVE THE ZERO EMISSION AND
OTHER INNOVATIVE CONTROL
TECHNOLOGIES PRIOR TO DEPLOYMENT
QUITE FRANKLY WE JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THEY WORK BEFORE WE PROVIDE
MONEY OR REQUIRE THEM.
SO THIS -- APPROVAL IS REQUIRED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
TECHNOLOGIES ARE SOUND AND TO
PROVIDE COMPLIANCE OPTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES.
NOW HISTORICALLY ALMOST ALL OF
THE EQUIPMENT THAT WE THAT WE
CERTIFY THEIR COMBUSTION ENGINES
TO THEIR COMBUSTION ENGINES FOR
CARS FOR TRUCKS FOR OFF ROAD
EQUIPMENT.
BUT THE TECHNOLOGY AND THE
REQUIREMENTS ARE PROGRAMS HAVE
SHIFTED AND WE'RE STARTING TO
SEE MORE ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES AND MORE INNOVATIVE
TECHNOLOGIES.
AND THIS IS WHAT WE REALLY WANT
TO SUPPORT OUR COMMITMENT TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS AND PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND WITHIN THE FREIGHT SECTOR
WERE REALLY EXCITED THAT WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE SOME OF THESE
NEW TECHNOLOGIES FOR SHIPS
LOCOMOTIVES HARBOR CRAFT CARGO
HANDLING EQUIPMENT.
AND TRANSPORTATION REFRIGERATION
UNITS.
BUT THERE ARE NO ESTABLISH
APPROVAL PROCEDURES FOR THESE
TYPES OF EQUIPMENT.
SO THIS B. C. P. IS GOING TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES TO DEVELOP.
EXCUSE ME NEW APPROVAL
PROCEDURES I'M TO SCREENING
PROCESS APPLICATIONS FOR NEW
TECHNOLOGIES MONITOR THERE AND
USE IMPROVE PERFORMANCE.
AND ALSO LOOK AT CHARGING AND
REFUELING INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
THIS IS BECOMING A REALLY BIG
DEAL FOR ZERO MISSION --
EQUIPMENT.
THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL FUND
WOULD INITIALLY FUND THE
POSITIONS UNTIL FEES CAN BE
COLLECTED FROM TECHNOLOGY
DEVELOPERS TO PROVIDE ONGOING
SUPPORT.
I'M WE'RE GONNA BE PROPOSING A
REGULATION ESTABLISHING FEES IN
SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY WHICH IS
BASED ON NEW WITH FORTY GRANTED
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN THROUGH
SENATE BILL.
EIGHT FIVE FOUR AM WORK
REQUESTING THE DISPOSITIONS TO
BEGIN IN FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHT USING THE AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL FIND.
BECAUSE THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE OF
APPROVAL PROCEDURES IS GOING TO
TAKE A WHILE SEVERAL MONTHS TO A
YEAR OR EVEN MORE.
I'M WE NEED TO BEGIN APPROVING
pINNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGIES AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE I'M WITH THE RIGHT.
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS AND
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
UNDER WAY WE APPRECIATE THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION TO APPROVE
IS BUDGETED AND I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
LET ME ASK LET ME THINK BY
UNDERSTAND THIS WE'RE GOING TO
SET FEES [inaudible]
ON THE TECHNOLOGY THE THE TECH
THE INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGIES ARE
COMING OR IS IT COULD BE THE THE
FREIGHT.
OWNERS THIS WOULD BE THESE ARE
CERTIFICATION FEES.
THE WEIGHT SO THE WAY THIS WORKS
AND THERE BE OF RALPH RELATED
CONVERSATION FOR THE NEXT A B.
C. P..
IS SO FOR SOMEONE WHO WANTS US
TO SAY YOU KNOW TO SORT OF GIVE
US THEIR STAMP.
GIVE US GIVE THEM OUR STAMP OF
APPROVAL.
THEY WILL.
IT REQUIRES A FAIR AMOUNT OF
WORK ON OUR PART TO THE IDEA
WOULD BE THAT FOLKS THAT ARE
CERTIFYING THESE TECHNOLOGIES
WOULD COVER THOSE COSTS.
OKAY AND SO I UNDERSTAND THE
PROCESS.
THERE'S I GOT THIS NEW IDEA I
GET THIS.
THIS GIZMO I THINK IT'S GONNA
REDUCE RIGHT AFTER MARVIN BAH
BAH BAH BAH BAH AND I COME TO
YOU GUYS AND LET'S JUST SAY FOR
PURPOSES OF THIS IT WORKS IT
REALLY DEBT DOES BUT YOU YOU
WANNA TESTED IN INNOVATIVE THEY
DON'T PAY.
THE CERTIFICATION FEE AT THAT
TIME RIGHT WELL SO THE WAY THAT
IT WORKS RIGHT NOW THEY DON'T
PAY A FEE AT ALL RIGHT NOW SO IN
THE FREIGHT SECTOR FOR OFFERED
EQUIPMENT.
THERE WAS NO UNTIL THAT
LEGISLATION WAS PASSED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THERE IS NO AUTHORITY
FOR US TO CHARGE FEES TO CERTIFY
FOR OFF ROAD EQUIPMENT.
SO WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IS IN OUR
REGULATION WE SAY OKAY YOU CAN
USE THESE INNOVATIVE TECHNIQUES
BUT YOU HAVE TO YOU KNOW A OR B.
HAS TO SAY THAT THEY WORK BEFORE
YOU CAN USE IT RIGHT THAT KIND
OF MAKES SENSE.
AND SO WE'VE BEEN DOING THAT BUT
WE'VE BEEN ABSORBING THOSE COSTS
ARE DIVERTING RESOURCES FROM
OTHER PLACES.
THAT'S THAT'S HOW THEY WORK.
HELLO.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THE BUDGET REQUEST TO MIMIC WE
DID JUST ONE A FLAG ON THE FEE
ISSUE IN THIS SHOWS UP IN YOUR
NEXT AGENDA ITEM BUT JUST TO
KIND OF OF ADDRESS IT NOW I MEAN
IT IT IS.
IT DOES KIND OF REMOVE A ACCOUNT
RIGHT NOW AND THE AMOUNT OF
REVENUE THAT CAN BE COLLECTED
FROM FEES AND AND THAT THAT
APPLIES TO JUST CERTIFICATION.
FOR A LOT OF DIFFERENT SOURCES
NOT JUST THE SPECIFIC ONES WERE
TALKING RIGHT HERE I MEAN IN
GENERAL WE WE DO THINK THAT IT
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE TO ASSESS
FEES ON THE REGULATED ENTITIES.
TO COVER THE REGULATORY
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE BEING
COVERED I WOULD JUST WANNA SORT
OF FLAG AT THIS IS.
A PRETTY SUBSTANTIAL CHANGES NOT
QUITE CLEAR KIND OF EXACTLY HOW
MUCH REVENUE WOULD BE NEEDED TO
RAISE TO COVER KIND OF ALL THE
CERTIFICATION COSTS WITHIN A R.
B. AND SO.
THE COMMITTEE MIGHT WANT TO KIND
OF ASK YOU WHAT WHAT CARD KNOWS
ABOUT WHAT THOSE COSTS MIGHT BE
IN THERE FOR KIND OF WHAT THE
AMOUNT OF THE FEE MIGHT BE AND
IF THEY DON'T QUITE KNOW AT THIS
POINT A WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
MIGHT.
MIGHT BE ABLE TO KIND OF EXPECT
TO HAVE THAT TYPE OF INFORMATION
AVAILABLE OKAY WHAT TYPE OF FEE
WILL THIS. ONE WE KNOW ABOUT IT.
SO -- LE I JUST I WANT TO
CLARIFY IT SO THE FEES THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THAT ARE
RELATED TO THIS PARTICULAR BCP
THEY WERE AUTHORIZED -- IN
LEGISLATION THAT WAS PASSED IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO AS I
MENTIONED WE'RE IN THE PROCESS
OF GOING THROUGH AND DOING SORT
OF A MULTI SOURCE HE REGULATION
AND THEN FOR THE FREIGHT SECTOR
WE HAVE SIX DIFFERENT
REGULATIONS THAT ARE COMING UP
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS.
AND AS WE GO THROUGH THAT
REGULATORY PROCESS WE'RE GOING
TO BE -- DEVELOPING A FEE
STRUCTURE AS WE GO THROUGH THAT
RULE MAKING SO IT'S AN OPEN
PUBLIC PROCESS AS PART OF THE
RULE MAKING IT WE'RE STARTING TO
DO THE ASSESSMENTS TO LOOK A
WHAT THE RESOURCES THAT WE NEED
TO DO.
WHAT WE WHAT WE WOULD NEED TO DO
SO IT IT IS SOMETHING THAT WILL
BE DEVELOPED AS WE GO ALONG AND
AS WE GET TO THE NEXT B. C. P.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT THE?
REMOVAL OF THE CAP.
ALRIGHT LET'S OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARING THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER --
THIRTY SEVEN ONE POINT.
THREE TWO SIX FOUR INNOVATIVE
FREIGHT TECHNOLOGIES.
EVALUATION APPROVAL CLOSE PUBLIC
HEARING.
IS THERE A MOTION TO APPROVE THE
BUDGET REQUESTS MOTION BY CENTER
STERN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I CASKEY BY [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
MONNING NAY STERN RIGHT THEY
WILL KEEP THE OUR ROLES OPEN FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS NOW LET'S GO.
TO THE HEAVY DUTY FACE TO
GREENHOUSE GAS IMPLEMENTATION
AND AUDIT PROGRAM.
OKAY BUT A TRAILER LANGUAGE IN
THIS P. C. P. WERE REQUESTING
ONE POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
FUNDS.
AND TEN POSITIONS THAT PHASE IN
OVER THREE YEARS AND THESE
POSITIONS ARE TO REVIEW AND
CERTIFIED MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
ENGINES AND VEHICLES AND
TRAILERS -- TO THE NEWLY ADOPTED
CALIFORNIA PHASE TWO GREENHOUSE
GAS REGULATIONS SO THESE ARE AS
YOU MIGHT EXPECT THE SECOND
PHASE OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS STANDARDS THAT WE
ADOPTED IN COORDINATION WITH THE
US EPA.
THESE ARE GONNA REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS FROM
HEAVY AND MEDIUM DUTY ENGINES BY
ABOUT A THIRD OF BY.
TWENTY FIFTY SAID THERE'S TWO
MAIN REASONS THAT WE NEED
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO
IMPLEMENT THIS REGULATION.
THE ENGINES THAT ARE MEETING THE
STANDARD ARE A LOT MORE COMPLEX
THAN ENGINES MEETING THE PHASE
ONE STANDARD.
AND THE DATA AND DOCUMENTATION
REQUIRED IS MUCH GREATER THAN WE
PREVIOUSLY REQUIRED AND I'M JUST
GONNA SAY FOLKS WAGON WE'RE
TRYING TO GET A BETTER HANDLE
THEY WERE REQUIRING MORE
INFORMATION.
SO THE WORKLOAD TO PROCESS THE
CERTIFICATIONS IS GOING TO BE
MUCH HIGHER -- THESE FACE TO
REGULATIONS ALSO INCLUDE FOR THE
FIRST TIME WE HAVE GREENHOUSE
GAS EFFICIENCY STANDARDS FOR
TRAILERS.
AND SO WE ACTUALLY HAVE TO
DEVELOP A WHOLE NEW PROCESS
WE'VE NEVER CERTIFIED TRAILERS
BEFORE AND SO WE NEED TO DEVELOP
AND IMPLEMENT PROCEDURES FOR
OVER A HUNDRED NEW TRAILER
CERTIFICATIONS EVERY YEAR.
WHAT TYPE OF THE MISSIONS COULD
DISK SUBCOMMITTEE EXPECT OFFER
THE TRAILERS WELL THIS THAT WHAT
THIS IS IS BY HAVING A MORE
EFFICIENT TRAILER YOUR REDUCING
THE AMOUNT OF FUEL THAT THE
TRUCK THE TRACTOR NEEDS TO PULL
IT?
OKAY THANK IS THAT OKAY.
SO AND ACTUALLY I ASKED THEM TO
THIS QUESTION -- THEY'RE LOOKING
AT THINGS LIKE TIRE PRESSURE
MONITORING SYSTEMS AERODYNAMICS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT ON THE
TRAILERS -- SO THE SECOND REASON
THAT WE DIDN'T NEED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES IS I'M FOR THE PHASE
ONE STANDARDS WE BASICALLY SAID
IF U. S. E. P. A.'S CERTIFIED
YOU TO MEET THE STANDARDS THAN
YOU WERE DEEMS TO COMPLY WITH
CALIFORNIA STANDARDS.
I'M WE'RE TAKING A MORE ACTIVE
ROLE IN IMPLEMENTING THE PHASE
TWO STANDARDS AND SO WE ARE
GOING TO BE DOING.
ON THE REVIEW OF THOSE
APPLICATIONS AND DELVING INTO
THEM WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS.
REGULATION IS IMPLEMENTED
PROPERLY.
I'M OLDER DIESEL ENGINES ARE
RELATIVELY SMALL CONTRIBUTED STE
CONTRIBUTOR TO THE STATE'S
CLIMATE CHANGE PROBLEM PROBLEM.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO GET
REDUCTIONS FROM EVERY SOURCE I
THINK WE'VE TALKED TO THIS
COMMITTEE BEFORE ABOUT HOW
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS FOR
TRANSPORTATION ARE INCREASING.
SO WE WANT TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN.
AND IN ADDITION IMPLEMENTATION
OF PHASE TWO ENGINES IS ALSO
GOING TO HELP PRODUCE SMOG
FORMING AND TOXIC EMISSIONS FROM
THESE ENGINES.
NOW WE ALREADY TALKED ABOUT AN
IMPORTANT ELEMENT OF THIS VCP IS
THIS PURPOSE HOSE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
RIGHT NOW THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
FINES THAT WE CAN COLLECT FOR
OUR ON ROAD CERTIFICATION
ACTIVITIES SO THAT'S CARS AND
TRUCKS.
IS CAPPED AT NINE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHAT THE TRAILER
BILL DOES IS IT REMOVES THE CAP.
IT ALLOWS FEE ASSESSMENT FOR THE
CERTIFICATION OF TRAILERS AND
THAT DIRAC'S THE CERTIFICATION
FEES TO A NEW FINDS CALL THE
CERTIFICATION AND COMPLIANCE
FUND.
SO IF THIS TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
IS APPROVED WE WILL BEGIN THE
PROCESS TO ESTABLISH FEES TO
COVER THE FACE TO GREENHOUSE GAS
PROGRAM.
AND OUR OTHER ON RED
CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS ON ALL OF
THESE RULE MAKING AS WE GO
THROUGH OUR NORMAL PUBLIC
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS.
AND WE WOULD EXPECT THAT THE
TOTAL AMOUNT OF FEES COLLECTED
TO BE COMMENSURATE WITH WHAT U.
S. EPA'S COLLECTING FOR THEIR
CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS.
HIS NINE POINT SIX MILLION OR SO
WHAT USEPA COLLECTS RIGHTNOW
BASED ON OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
THEM AND THIS IS FOR ALL OF
THEIR CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS FOR
ON ROAD OFF ROAD LOCOMOTIVES
EVERYTHING THAT THEY CERTIFY.
IS ABOUT TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR.
WHAT'S THE SIZE THAT FEE COULD
BE.
YOU KNOW SO IT IT REALLY DEPENDS
COVERS THE COST NATURALLY YEAH I
KNOW IT'S IN IT'S INTENDED TO
COVER THE COSTS AND I I THINK
THAT.
YOU THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT THE
BEST WAY TO ASSESS THAT FEE AND
HOW DO YOU.
HOW DO YOU ASSIGN THAT FEATURE
THE DIFFERENT FOLKS THAT ARE
APPLYING FOR CERTIFICATION AND
SOME OF THE -- SOME OF THE
SOURCES ARE GONNA BE QUITE SMALL
SO PEOPLE WHO ARE MAKING.
BY PEOPLE WHO ARE CERTIFYING
LIKE AFTERMARKET PARTS THEY
MIGHT BE MKING ONLY A FEW
HUNDRED OF THEM -- FOLKS THAT
ARE -- CERTIFYING ENGINES FOR
CARS ARE AN ENGINE FAMILY FOR
CARS MIGHT BE SELLING MILLIONS
OF THEM AND SO I THINK ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES AS WE GO THROUGH
THAT PUBLIC RULE MAKING PROCESS
IS TO SET UP.
A STRUCTURE FOR THE RULE THAT
MAKES SENSE AND WORKS SO THAT'S
I THINK PART OF THE PUBLIC
PROCESS -- IF THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IS APPROVED ALLEY ARE
YOU SATISFIED WITH THAT.
YEAH I MEAN I I THINK THEY'RE
STILL YOU KNOW IT SEEMS LIKE
THERE'S STILL QUITE A QUITE A
BIT OF UNCERTAINTY AROUND KIND
OF EGGMAN THE EXACT COSTS BUT
IT'S NICE TO HAVE KIND OF A
GENERAL RANGE FOR WHAT THEY
EXPECT.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE BUDGET
DOLLAR RANGE YEAH EXACTLY WHEN
IT COMES TO THE BUDGET PROPOSAL
IN THE REQUESTED RESOURCES WE
THINK THE THE RESOURCES REQUEST
IS REASONABLE GIVEN THE THEY
IDENTIFIED WORKLOAD?
ALRIGHT THIS IS SAID.
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS. TO
PROVE HIS PROPOSED LET'S OPEN
THE PUBLIC HEARING ON THIS.
CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING THERE'S A
MOTION BY CENTER MINING PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
CASKEY HI JONES [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MORNING [inaudible]
STERN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
GOOD LUCK.
ALL THE THINGS I BROUGHT UP A
ALL LETTERS I KEEP READING GUYS
THAT'S LET'S MOVE -- TO DGSE.
THIS IS COST RECOVERY MANAGE.
MEN SYSTEM INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY PROJECT.
SPLITTING THE MONEY BETWEEN THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL ACCOUNT
AND THE TAXES SUBSTANCE CONTROL
AND IMPROVING THE SITUATION.
HELLO THIS IS.
THIRTY NINE SO -- THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION [inaudible]
WHICH IS. TO BE MORE CLEAR OF
WHAT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS
TO PROVIDE PROOF APPROVALS
PROPOSED AND ADOPT THE B. B. L..
AT THAT WOULD MAKE.
THE RELEASE OF TWO MILLION TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF THE REQUESTED FUNDING
CONTINGENT ON ONE APPROVAL OF
STAGE FOR PAL DOCUMENTS BUYS AS
CDT.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND TO WRITTEN NOTIFICATION TO
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
THAT THE PROJECT HAS RECEIVED.
THAT THESE APPROVAL SO IT'S
RELEASING SOME HOLDING BACK.
OTHERS.
THAT'S THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD UPPER VACATION GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR I CASKEY AND AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HI MEREDITH
WILLIAMS ACTING DIRECTOR FOR DTS
SEE.
AND OF OUR CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FRANCESCA NEGRI WILL PRESENT
THIS PARTICULAR.
SO THANK YOU -- FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY AND WE AS YOU
KNOW WE'RE REQUESTING NO ONE ONE
TIME AUGMENTATION OF TWO POINT
SIX MILLION SPLIT BETWEEN AGE TO
BE SEEING TOSCA -- FOR THE COST
RECOVERY MANAGEMENT IT PLATFORM
UPGRADE PROJECT -- UPGRADING OF
THIS PLATFORM IS CRUCIAL BECAUSE
THE EXISTING SYSTEM THE DTS HE
USES FOR ITS COST RECOVERY
ACTIVITIES IS NO LONGER
SUPPORTED CANNOT BE UPGRADED TO
ME TO CHANGE IN THE STATUTES AND
IS SUBJECT TO SECURITY THREATS.
DID YOU SEE RECOVERS MILLIONS
AND RESPONSE COSTS ANNUALLY FROM
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES AND
PERMITTED HAZARDOUS WASTE
FACILITIES AND THE COST RECOVERY
BILLING SYSTEM SUPPORTS THESE
ACTIVITIES.
WE'VE CHOSEN A A SOLUTION THAT
PROVIDES A COST EFFECTIVE KNOWN
STRATEGY MEETS LEGISLATIVE COST
RECOVERY INTEREST RATE MNDATES
OF AB TWO SEVENTY THREE AND
ALIGNS WITH CALLIE PEES
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY STRATEGIC
PLAN TO LEVERAGE EXISTING
TECHNOLOGY.
AND SOLUTIONS.
THE PLANNING PHASE WHICH IS
STAGE FOR THE PROJECT APPROVAL
LYSAGHT CYCLE WHICH IS PAL IS
ESTIMATED TO BE COMPLETED BY
AUGUST OF TWENTY NINETEEN SO IN
A FEW MONTHS.
PROJECT TIMELINES INCLUDE
EXECUTING A CONTRACT IN AUGUST
TWENTY NINETEEN TO BEGIN
UPGRADING THE TECHNOLOGY
PLATFORM.
WE APPRECIATE THE RECOMMENDATION
TO PROVE AS PROPOSED AND ADOPT
THE BILL BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD MAKE THE RELEASE OF
FUNDS CONTINGENT UPON TO POP TO
PARTNER AFTER TECHNOLOGY AND
FINANCE APPROVAL.
BUT WOULD ASK THAT TWO HUNDRED
NINETY FOUR THOUSAND BE
IMMEDIATELY APPROVED FOR THE
COMPLETION OF STAGE.
FOR WHICH IS ESTIMATED TO BE
COMPLETED IN AUGUST.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO US I WOULD
REALLY LIKE IT IF IT WAS MAY OF
TWO THOUSAND NINE THAT YOU WERE
COMING BEFORE US BURKE.
ALEJO WE LIKED YOUR LANGUAGE ON
YOUR RECOMMENDATION.
IF YOU HEARD I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR SUMMER WITH LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WHERE YOU READ
EARLIER IMPLEMENTS THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
RECOMMENDATION.
OKAY WE THINK WERE TAKEN I GOT
BIG PLANS FOR PTSD.
NOT ON THIS THIS IS LOOKING AT
THIS ISSUE [inaudible]
OUTSIDE ARM.
THIS IS SUDDEN.
YOU HEARD THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION NOT TO READ IT
AGAIN LET'S OPEN PUBLIC HEARING.
COST RECOVERY MANAGEMENT.
CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING THERE SIR.
RECOMMENDATION AS AMENDED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MY COUNTY HI JONES [inaudible]
REQUIRE [inaudible]
MONEY.
ALL RIGHT ISSUE NUMBER FORTY IS.
WE ARE FIX IT.
BASED FUNDING TO MAINTAIN OUR
OPERATIONS THIRTY SEVEN AND A
HALF MILLION BUCKS TO MAINTAIN
THE EXISTING OPERATIONS
[inaudible]
AND IS YOUR BASE FUNDING WE'RE
GOING TO ADD TO THE MOTION SO
THE MOTION.
IS.
APPROVE -- AS PROPOSED WITH
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE SECRETIVE FEET TASK
FORCE AND IMPLEMENT OTHER
CHANGES TO THE DEPARTMENT.
AND WE WILL.
CLARIFY THAT WE'RE GOING TO
APPROVE TWENTY SEVEN POINT FIVE
TO BACK FILL THE HAZARDOUS WASTE
CONTROL ACT.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AND
TWENTY AND ADOPT THE PLACEHOLDER.
TO CREATE A TASK FORCE.
AT FEET TASK FORCE ANOTHER
CHANGES TO IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY DEPARTMENT
EVERY JACK. EIGHTEEN AND A HALF
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO COME BACK NEXT YEAR.
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
[inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
OKAY I WANT TO FIRST AND
FOREMOST THANK THE LEGISLATURE
FOR SUPPORT FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
THE FUNDING SUPPORT AND
OVERSIGHT BY THE INDEPENDENT
REVIEW PANEL HAS ENABLED US TO
AND IDENTIFY SOME OF OUR BIGGEST
CHALLENGES AND MAKE INROADS INTO
ADDRESSING THEM.
WITH THE LOAN TO SUPPORT THE X.
I. CLEAN UP WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
CLEAN UP ALMOST EIGHT HUNDRED
HOMES AND PROPERTIES.
THE FINDINGS OF THE INDEPENDENT
REVIEW PANEL HELP TO SHAPE OUR
STRATEGY FOR THE UPCOMING YEARS.
AND THE FIND THE FUNDING TO
IMPROVE PERMITTING PROCESSES HAS
ENABLED US TO MAKE MORE TIMELY
AND ENFORCEABLE PERMITTING
DECISIONS.
AND I COULD GO ON BUT I'LL GET
TO THE POINT WHICH IS
UNFORTUNATELY THE DEPARTMENT'S
LONG STANDING STRUCTURAL DEFICIT
HAS REACHED A POINT WHERE WE
MUST RELY ON GENERAL FUND MONIES.
THE TWENTY SEVEN POINT FIVE MEN
GENERAL. TWENTY SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND BACK
FILL FOR FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN
TWENTY AND THE REQUESTED
EIGHTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION IN
EACH OF THE FOLLOWING TWO FISCAL
YEARS.
WOULD GIVE US TIME TO WORK WITH
YOU THE GOVERNOR AND OUR
STAKEHOLDERS TO IDENTIFY A
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING SOLUTIONS.
THISREQUEST ALSO ENABLES US TO
ACHIEVE GREATER BUDGET
TRANSPARENCY AND INCLUDES THE
ELIMINATION OF THE GENERAL FUND
LOAN REPAID PAYMENT.
FROM THE LEAD ACID BATTERY
CONTROL FUND.
FREEING THOSE REVENUES TO BE
USED FOR CLEANING CONTAMINATED
SITES AROUND THE FORMER LEAD
ACID BATTERY FACILITIES.
WHEN WE WERE BEFORE YOU IN
JANUARY WE UPDATED YOU ON OUR
EFFORTS TO GET OUR FINANCIAL
HOUSE IN ORDER?
WE DISCUSSED THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING ACCURATE INFORMATION ON
BUDGET AND WORKLOAD WHICH UP
UNTIL THAT POINT HAD PROVED
ELUSIVE. TO ENSURE THE INTEGRITY
OF ANY FEE REFORMS.
I'M SORRY TO TO RICHARD ENSURE
THE INTEGRITY OF ANY FEE REFORMS
WE'VE MADE FURTHER PROGRESS ON
OUR FISCAL GOVERNANCE WE'RE
WORKING WITH OUR PARTNERS
INCLUDING FIST GALLON STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE TO STAY ON
TRACK FOR AN ON TIME HEARING
CLOSING.
AND OUR ACCOUNTING PROCEDURES
AUDIT IS UNDER WAY.
WE'RE CONTINUE OUR WORK WORKLOAD
STUDY AND WILL SOON RELEASE A
STRATEGIC PLAN WITH PERFORMANCE
METRICS FOR EACH OF THE
DEPARTMENTS PROGRAMS.
COLLECTIVELY THESE EFFORTS WILL
PROVIDE THE INFORMATION NEEDED
TO DETERMINE THE LEVEL OF
FUNDING REQUIRED TO DELIVER OUR
MISSION.
THIS INFORMATION WILL BE
FOUNDATIONAL. TO THE WORK OF A
FEW TASK FOR FORCE PER THE
STAFF'S RECOMMENDATION.
WE ARE COMPUTER COLLABORATING
WITH THE NEW ADMINISTRATION AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
DETERMINE WHAT ORGANIZATIONAL
AND FISCAL REFORMS ARE NECESSARY
TO ENSURE THE DEPARTMENT
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY
PROVIDES ADEQUATE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AGAINST
TOXIC SUBSTANCES.
LA -- YOUR COMMENT ON THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION.
WE AGREE WITH THE STAFF
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE PER
THE REQUEST FOR TWENTY SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION. FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR BUT REJECT THAT THE
REQUEST FOR EIGHTEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO MINUTES IN
RECENT YEARS TEACHES HIS BEEN
THE FOCUS OF A LOT OF
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT IN HEARING.
TO DO THAT FISCAL AN OPERATIONAL
ISSUES -- WE THINK APPROVING
ONLY ONE YEAR OF THE GENERAL
FUND BACK FAN WILL REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT COME BACK NEXT YEAR
AND ASK FOR DEBT TIONAL FUND.
AND THAT WILL ENSURE ON GOING
CONTINUE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
OF THE DEPARTMENT.
THIS OPEN THE PUBLIC HEARING
THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER. THIRTY NO
FORTY ON THE BASE FUNDING.
AT TO MAINTAIN OPERATIONS IF THE
TSC PLEASE COME FORWARD.
HI MORGAN CAM BEHALF OF THE
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS IN SUPPORT OF THIS ITEM
THANK YOU.
CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING.
THERE'S A MOTION BY SENATE
MCGUIRE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WE CASTING HI JONES [inaudible]
REQUIRE [inaudible]
MONEY.
WE'LL SEE YOU NEXT TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE DEPARTMENT.
THIS IS CATASTROPHIC LIVESTOCK
DISEASE.
VERY -- VERLOREN.
NEW CASTLE THE TEAS V. N. D..
OUTBREAKS IN SAN BERNARDINO AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTIES.
PLEASE GOOD AFTERNOON SURE WHITE
HOUSE CAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KEVIN MáS WHO ARE A
DEPUTY SECRETARY OVER CDFA AND
WITH ME IS DOCTOR JONES.
WHO IS ACCESSORIZED BALLS IN THE
V. AND D. OUTBREAK -- AS YOU CAN
SEE FROM THE BACKGROUND
INFORMATION IT'S VERY FAST
MOVING IN A VERY DEVASTATING
DISEASE OF POULTRY IT AFFECTS
BROILERS AN EGG LAYERS.
RIGHT NOW IT'S PRIMARILY AND
BACKYARD FLOCKS AND A WHAT YOU
CALL SAID SEMI RESIDENTIAL AREAS
RATCHETS IN AREAS LIKE THAT.
BUT IT HAS MOVED INTO A SMALL
LAYING FLOCKS IMPOLITE RANCHES
DOWN IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
HOW WE KEEP OUR FINGERS CROSSED
WE HAVE HAD?
FIND AFTER NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
BUT IT WAS ISOLATED IN IT DIDN'T
SPREAD TO THE BROILER INDUSTRY.
WERE ASKING FOR THREE POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN THREE
POINT TWO ONE GOING IN TWENTY
THREE POSITIONS.
SO THAT WE CAN BETTER -- PUT
TOGETHER A TEAM TO WORK ON
PREVENTION OF FUTURE DISEASE
OUTBREAKS AND A MORE RAPID IN
ROBUST RESPONSE WHEN THESE
DISEASE OUTBREAKS TO HAPPEN SO
THAT WE CAN CONTAIN THEM FAR
QUICKER.
AND ALSO CONTAINED WITHIN THIS
PROPOSAL IS SOME STAFF WHO DO
SIMILAR FUNCTIONS BUT THEN THEY
WILL BE FOCUSED ON ANIMAL CARE
ISSUES DURING CATASTROPHIC
EMERGENCY EVENTS.
SUCH AS WHAT WE EXPERIENCED
DURING THE RECENT CAMPFIRE --
BUT IN TWO YEARS AGO AS WELL IN
CINEMA COUNTY CENTER MCGUIRE.
WITH ANIMAL CARE ISSUES THAT
COME UP WITH PEOPLE HAVING TO
EVACUATE MOVE THOSE ANIMALS AND
THEN BEING DISPLACED ON A LONG
TERM BASIS.
AND ONE OF THE REASONS WE PUT
THAT IN THIS PROPOSAL IS SOME OF
THE SAME SKILL SETS ARE
FUNCTIONAL TO BOTH TYPES OF
OPERATIONS.
AND SO WE FELT IT WAS A GOOD USE
OF RESOURCES TO PUT THESE TEAMS
TOGETHER TRAIN THEM UP IN
PREVENTION TRAINING WORKING WITH
LOCALS ON PLANTS.
AND ALSO TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND
BUT TO SET THE BASIC CORE
UNDERSTAND ANIMAL CARE ISSUES.
IN AND THAT WAY WE HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO DEPLOY THESE
PEOPLE DURING DISEASE OUTBREAKS
AS WELL AS EMERGENCY OUTBREAKS.
QUITE A FEW OF THE MEMBERS OF
THE TEAMS ARE INSPECTORS SO I
SEE LET'S JUST PICK THE
EUTHANASIA TEAM THE YOU'VE GOT.
A SENIOR LIVESTOCK INSPECTOR IN
FOR LIVESTOCK INSPECTORS AND
THEN ONE VETERINARIAN AYE I
THINK I GET WITH THE
VETERINARIAN DOES SO YOU'VE GOT
THESE FIVE ON THE TEAM.
BUT THE OTHER THE FIELD
REIMBURSEMENT [inaudible]
SPECIALIST HAS. ONE OF THE
QUARANTINE ENFORCEMENT HAS.
OF INSPECTORS THE DISEASE
DETECTION HAS INSPECTORS THOSE
INSPECTORS.
THEY JUST STAY ON THE EUTHANASIA
CHAMBER TODAY ARE THEY ABLE OF A
ORTABLE TO THESE OTHER
QUARANTINE INVESTIGATIONS.
YOU KNOW THESE OTHER.
FUNCTIONS I'M ALL I CAN ADDRESS
I AM SO I MATCH I'M GLAD YOU
ASKED THAT QUESTION BECAUSE IT
KIND OF GETS TO IT ONE OF THE
KEY PRINCIPLES ON HOW WE
PREPARED TO RESPOND.
WE USE THE MODEL THAT A LOT OF
THAT -- YES USES A LOT OF FIRE
FIRE POLICE AND WE TRYING TO BE
MORE OF AN ALL HAZARDS
ORGANIZATION BUT WITHIN THAT WE
HAVE TO IN BED SPECIALTIES.
SO WHAT WHAT WE SEE IS THAT WE
HAVE A GAP WHERE WE REALLY NEED
TO AND AND ESPECIALLY WHERE
THERE'S NO WEATHER WILL OTHER
AGENTS HERE OTHER RESOURCE THAT
HAS THAT SPECIALTY.
SO WE WOULD EXPECT THOSE STAFF
LIKE THE ONES THAT YOU JUST
DESCRIBED TO BE OUR STATE
EXPERTS IN THOSE AREAS AND PART
OF THEIR JOB WAS TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL OF OUR STAFF HAS A
LEVEL PURSE PROFICIENCY IN THOSE
AREAS.
SO THAT WE CAN MIX AND MATCH AND
MOVE AT PEOPLE TO WHERE THEY'RE
THEY'RE NEEDED BECAUSE YOU
REALLY HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD
THERE IS NO RESPONSE IS EXACTLY
THE SAME FROM LOCATION EQUATION
DISEASE THE DISEASE DISASTER TO
DISASTER -- BUT THOSE WERE JUST
CLEAR GAPS THAT WE BECAME
UNFORTUNATELY A PAINFULLY AWARE
OF OVER THE PAST YEAR SO YOU
ANTICIPATE DOCTOR THAT THE THAT
THAT INSPECTOR.
HE GOT A VERY LEARNED.
NEWCASTLE DISEASE OUTBREAKS THEY
WOULD BE THAT THE INSPECTOR
WOULD BE ABLE TO SAY I NEED TO
GET THE QUARANTINE TEAM MANNER I
NEED.
TO TAKE A TO TAKE THESE ACTIONS
OR WE NEED TO EUTHANIZE THIS
THIS IS THIS IS WHATEVER THE
STATUS IS RIGHT RIGHT SO THEY
WOULD PROVIDE THE LEADERSHIP
THAT WE WOULD NEED.
TO WHEN AS WE BRING OTHER PEOPLE
ON BOARD SO FOR EXAMPLE ON OUR
CURRENT OUTBREAK WE USE A LOT OF
TEMPORARY HIRES OR OR OF PEOPLE
FROM OTHER AGENCIES THAT DON'T
HAVE THOSE EXPERTISE SO WE WOULD
ACTUALLY.
PROBABLY THAT TEAM WOULDN'T
FUNCTION EXACTLY AS A TEAM IS
DESCRIBED BUT RATHER THEY'D BE
BROKEN UP IN BE PROVIDE
LEADERSHIP ROLES -- AS WE BRING
NEW PEOPLE WANT TO MAKE SURE I
MEAN YOU YOU MENTIONED
EUTHANASIA THAT'S PROBABLY THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING THAT WE DO
CORRECTLY.
AND HAS THE WEB BASED TRACKER AT
THAT I KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THE
END.
DE AND TRACKING BUT IS THAT THE
YOU ANTICIPATE THAT SOMETIME
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO KNOW.
I'M IN SAN BERNADINO AND THEN IT
GOES UP WHAT'S MORE THE SAN
BERNADINO KNOWS RIGHT SAN
JOAQUIN.
AS IT GOES THROUGH THESE
COUNTIES IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE.
THAT THAT DATA THAT INFORMATION
SO THE THE CHICKEN.
FARMER AS A FARMER OR RANCHER
WHATEVER THEY ARE [inaudible]
SO.
ADLER GET TO KNOW ABOUT IT.
THESE OUTBREAKS THERE ARE --
VERY DATA INTENSIVE AND DATA
DRIVEN JUST LIKE WHEN OUR HUMAN
COUNTERPARTS ARE DEALING WITH
YOU KNOW HUMAN OUTBREAKS OF
VARIOUS DISEASES SO -- WE WE DO
USE A FAIRLY ROBUST DATABASE
THAT TO TRACK -- YOU KNOW
DIFFERENT INFORMATION WE USE
THAT TO MAKE COUNTERMEASURE
DECISIONS -- WE WE DO A LOT OF
SURVEILLANCE SO WHICH IF IF
THAT'S WHAT YOU WERE LOOKING FOR
AS FAR AS TRACKING THE STATUS OF
DISEASE -- SO THERE'S A LOT OF
DIAGNOSTICS AND TESTING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE HAVE
STAFF STAFF ACTUALLY INVENTED --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE MOST OF OUR
STAFF OUR FIELD STAFF BECAUSE
THIS EXPERTISE DOESN'T EXIST AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL YOU KNOW FOR THE
MOST PART SO THEY'RE EMBEDDED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO ENSURE.
WE DON'T HAVE AND IT'S NOT JUST
THIS ONE DISEASE OR SEVERAL
DISEASES TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVEN'T GOTTEN DISEASE
INCURSIONS.
AND FINALLY ON THE I'M FROM TAKE
IN THE BACKYARD.
OKAY ALL WHO HAVE THREE OR FOUR
CHICKENS OR TWO I GUESS WHATEVER
IT IS IS THE IS THIS OUT OF
REACH.
PER CENTER THAT'S GONNA GO IN
HOW WHAT A SECOND LOOK LIKE WHAT
DO YOU ENVISION THAT THAT IT
LOOKING LIKE RIGHT ANOTHER GOOD
QUESTION AND THEN THE
DEMOGRAPHICS FOR PEOPLE THAT
REYES WHAT.
WERE ONCE CONSIDERED FARM
ANIMALS IS CERTAINLY SHIFTING
WHICH IS KIND OF A GOOD THING I
THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE LIKE A
EXISTING.
BUT SO REACHING THEM IS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT AND WE USE A LOT
OF DIFFERENT TECHNIQUES AND KIND
OF BECAUSE EVEN YOU CAN SELL YOU
CAN TELL THE RESOURCES REQUEST
HERE IS PROBABLY NOT ADEQUATE TO
REACH EVERY.
POULTRY OWNER IN THE STATE SO
WHAT WE WE USE A SYSTEM OF
LEVERAGING OTHER RESOURCES SO
FEED STORES ARE ONE GREAT
EXAMPLE OF OF PLACES WE TRY AND
LEVERAGE THE MESSAGE.
OF THAT PRIVATE VETERINARIANS
ARE REALLY OUR EYES AND EARS SO
WE DO A LOT OF INTEGRATION WITH
THEM COOPERATIVE EXTENSION.
OF DIFFERENT BIRD CLUBS THAT
TYPE OF THING.
ALL TO QUESTION.
DO I HAVE A TRANSYLVANIAN A
CONNECTS AND POST OP AT SO IT'S
GOOD STUFF ACCORDING TO BE
VISITING.
UP BUT HATE AT IT'S TRUE -- A
FEW QUESTIONS ON ISSUES A
DISASTER WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO FOCUS IN ON SO -- THANK YOU
FOR RESPONDING BECAUSE I THINK
THIS IS.
PRIOR TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WE
NEVER THOUGHT.
HOW MANY HAD A LIVESTOCK
ACTUALLY COMING OUT DURING A
THESE WILDFIRE VETS WERE TALKING
THOUSANDS?
OF WHETHER THEIR HORSES BACK YOU
IN CATTLE SHEEP EXEDRA -- AND IN
MANY THESE RURAL COUNTIES YOU TO
BE PROPPED UP.
I AND HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
ABLE TO BE ON SITE.
AND WORK WITH LOCALS IS THAT HOW
YOU IN TENNESSEE DUE. TO MOVE
ESPECIALLY DURING TIMES OF
DISASTER OR DO YOU.
BRING. FOR THE TEAM MEMBERS AND
TO BE ABLE TO BE THERE AND STAFF
CAN YOU WALK US THROUGH THE YEAH
THE CORE MODEL IS IS TO HAVE THE
APPARATUS IN PLACE SO THAT WE
HAVE THE CAPABILITY FOR TRAINING.
BUT ALSO WHEN WE'RE NOT IN IN A
CATASTROPHIC EVENT THAT WE'RE
WORKING WITH LOCALS PERFORMING
YEAH REACH DUTIES TO FORM THE
RELATIONSHIPS AND HELP THEM TO
DEVELOP THEIR PLANS.
UPDATE THEIR PLANS MAKE SURE
THEY HAVE UPDATED RESOURCE LIST
SO THAT EVERYTHING'S READY TO GO
IN IN TRAINING IS A KEY
COMPONENT SO THE LOCAL SINCE ARE
ALREADY THERE CAN REACT VERY
QUICKLY.
AND THEN THE IDEA IS IS OUR
PEOPLE CAN COME IN AND SIMILARLY
TO WHAT DOCTOR JONES DESCRIBED
IN AN ANIMAL DISEASE OF BAD
WHERE YOU HAVE KEY PEOPLE WHO
ARE TRAINED UP WITH THE SKILL
SETS.
THEN THEY CAN QUICKLY ASSUME
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS AND TRAIN
LOCALS ARE VOLUNTEERS OR OTHER
PEOPLE FROM SAY OUR DEPARTMENT
OR OTHER DEPARTMENTS WHO ARE
READY TO GO BUT THEY NEED THAT
SPECIALIZED TRAINING TO TELL
THEM AND DIRECT THEM ON WHAT TO
DO SO IT'S LEVERAGING ALL OF
THOSE DIFFERENT RESOURCES.
WITH THE CORE TEAM.
THEY ADD TO THEIR AB IN ANOTHER
A BIG DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THIS
AND THE DISASTERS THAT ACTOR
USES SIZE I AGREE THE SAME SKILL
SETS IS.
OF FOR DISASTERS THERE'S A A
REALLY WONDERFUL NETWORK OF
VOLUNTEER ORGANIZATIONS WITH
VERY HIGH LEVELS OF SKILL.
BUT A LOT OF THE TIMES THE
PROBLEM IS THE GAP IS ACTUALLY
COORDINATING THEM WITH THE LOCAL
FIRST RESPONDERS WHEN
EVERYBODY'S PRESSED YOU KNOW TO
SAVE LIVES SO WHAT WE WOULD
ANTICIPATED ARE.
THOSE FEW THAT WE HAVE A FEW
LEADERS WITHIN THAT PROGRAM THAT
THEIR NUMBER ONE JOB WOULD BE TO
PULL TOGETHER THESE -- DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE GREAT
RESOURCES THAT COULD BE APPLIED
DURING A DISASTER SO THEY WOULD
MAINTAIN THOSE RELATIONSHIPS AS
RESOURCE WE HAVE LESS MAYBE WORK
ON MUTUAL AID WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES.
AND THEN DURING A DISASTER THEY
WOULD GO INTO THOSE COORDINATION
ROLES THAT YOU KIND OF REFERRED
TO AND THEY WOULD TAP IN TO BOTH
OUR DEPARTMENT FOR OUR RESOURCES
AS WELL AS ALL OF THESE NON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS AND
OTHERS BUT IN THOSE NON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
JUST BEEN GUIDES.
AND RIGHT AT THE NAY -- YEAH BUT
THERE IS A GAP OF THREE TO FIVE
DAYS -- WHERE IS COMPLETE CHAOS
RIGHT UP FOLKS LEAVE AND THEN
THEY'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO GET BACK TO BE ABLE TO FEED I
MEAN THERE'S JUST?
A VARIETY OF COMPLICATIONS.
AND WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING AT
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS TO BE ABLE TO
ADVANCE THE BUDGET THIS YEAR BUT
AT CITY OF PHASE RT ON IT AND
JUST WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
SAY.
THANK YOU TO THE SECRETARY UP
FOR ALL THE WORK ON THIS I ALSO
THINK THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ARE BRING THIS FOR NATO CAROLING
THIS HERE -- AS SEEN THIS
FIRSTHAND AS WELL AND I'M SURE
AS WE TALK ON THIS BUT HE'S VERY
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THIS IS THIS
IS. ONE OF THE BIGGEST GAPS THAT
WE HAVE WHEN IT COMES A DISASTER
AND IT QUICKLY OVERWHELMS A
SMALL COUNTY -- AND WE'RE NOT
EVEN TALKING ABOUT HOUSE PETS
RIGHT WHICH IS ALSO ANOTHER
CHALLENGE THAT WE NEED.
TO HAVE FOR THE COMPETITION FROM
THE LIVESTOCK IT HAS BEEN HUGE
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHERE
TO GET THE FEET FROM THE BILL TO
FEED AS WE SAW DURING THE FIRE.
AT THE VALLEY FIRE SEVEN FIFTY
HORSES -- THAT WERE ALL
EVACUATED IN THAT WAS -- HI MISS.
SO THIS WAS A THANK YOU.
LET'S OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING
THIS IS A ISSUE NUMBER FORTY ONE
THE DEPARTMENT OF OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE'S CATASTROPHIC
LIVESTOCK.
DISEASE PREVENTION EMERGENCY
RESPONSE GO AHEAD.
MATTIE MUNSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA POULTRY FEDERATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
FUNDING THANK YOU.
KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ANIMAL OF HER
CESSATIONS REPRESENTS ALL THE
PUBLIC PRIVATE SHELTERS IN
CALIFORNIA A TO CENTER MAGUIRE'S
POINT.
OF VIEW COUNTY IT WAS IT WAS A
TREMENDOUS OF AND AND IT REALLY
OF BURN SOME OF MY MEMBERS THAT.
AND SO WE WOULD -- THINK CDFA SO
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR INCLUDING IT.
IN ORDER PRIVILEGED THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU.
THE MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JENNIFER FEARING ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO SPCA IN THE
SAN DIEGO HUMANE SOCIETY SOCIETY
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THAT THE CARE
SPENDING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING.
THERE'S A MOTION BY SENATOR --
THE MINING TWO PROOFS.
OF THE RECOMMENDATION AS
PROPOSED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ASKING HI JONES.
REQUIRE.
MONEY.
STERN.
KELLY THE VOTES CLOSE ROLL THE
EYES HAVE A FIVE ZERO ISSUE
NUMBER.
FORTY TWO PRODUCE SAFETY
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
YEAH THE DEPARTMENTS ARE
PROPOSING SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND FOR
NINETEEN TWENTY AN ON GOING IN
ONE POSITION. TO DEVELOP OF
PRODUCE SAFETY TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE AND EDUCATION TO
ASSIST CALIFORNIA'S PRODUCE
FARMERS.
AND THAT IS SO THAT THEY CAN
BETTER COMPLY WITH THE FOOD
SAFETY MODERNIZATION ACT WHICH
IS CARRIED OUT AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL -- THE RESOURCES THAT WILL
USE WILL BE A SENIOR
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENTISTS THAT
WILL WORK OUT OF THE DEPARTMENT
BUT WILL WORK CLOSELY WITH THE
UC COOPERATIVE EXTENSION. TO
LEVERAGE THAT NETWORK TO GET OUT
THERE AND PROVIDE THESE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SERVICES
DIRECTLY TO THE GROWERS.
A MEASURE WHERE FOOD SAFETY
WE'VE HD QUITE A FEW HIGH
PROFILE INCIDENTS IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS SOME OF THEM GARNER A
LOT OF PROGRESS.
ON THAT ACTUALLY THERE'S ALWAYS
SOMETHING GOING ON SOME OF THEM
JUST DON'T RISE TO THE LEVEL
WHERE WE GET A LOT OF PRESS.
BUT IT DOES POINT TO THE ISSUE
THAT -- FARM PRODUCTS DO NEED --
HIGH LEVEL OF SOPHISTICATION
WHEN IT COMES TO HOW THEY'RE
HANDLED PRODUCED AND ENTERED
INTO THE MARKETING CHANNELS SO
THAT WE CAN ENSURE FOOD SAFETY.
AND WE RECENTLY STARTED DOING
OUR ON FARM VISITS WITH FTA AS
PART OF THE PRODUCE A FIFTY RULE
IMPLEMENTATION.
IN AS YOU'RE PROBABLY AWARE
CALIFORNIA HAS A MYRIAD OF
DIFFERENT SIZE AND
SOPHISTICATION LEVELS OF FARM
SIZES AND A DIFFERENT TYPES OF
CROPS AND COMMODITY GROUNDS IN
EACH ONE PROVIDES.
A VERY UNIQUE CHALLENGES ON HOW
DO YOU MAXIMIZE FOOD SAFETY WITH
YOUR PRACTICES.
AND SO THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
WE'VE BEEN HEARING BACK FROM A
LOT OF DIFFERENT SOURCES THAT
THERE'S A BIG NEED FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
SO THAT THESE GROWERS CAN BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE COMPLIANCE ISSUE
BUT THIS REALLY ISN'T JUST ABOUT
SAYING OKAY GOING TO HELP YOU
COMPLY SO YOU STAY OUT OF
ROUBLE.
IT'S ABOUT HELPING YOU COMPLY SO
THAT WE CAN ENSURE A SAFE FOOD
SYSTEM AND SUSTAIN THAT SAFETY
THROUGH THEIR PRACTICES.
YOU EXPECT TO WORK BETWEEN WITH
THE COUNTY -- ADMINISTRATORS ON
AHEAD ON THIS OR YOU GET A DO
SITE VISITS TO SEE THIS COULD BE
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SO THAT.
YOU KNOW UP THE CROP BOB OF
EXTENSION WORKS LOCALLY WITH
GROWERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA ON
A LOT OF DIFFERENT PRODUCTION
TYPE ISSUES AND HELPS THEM SO
THIS WOULD PROVIDE THAT'S WHY WE
WOULD WANT TO GO INTO THAT
NETWORKING GIVE OUT -- CONTRACT
MONEY FOR THEM TO DEVELOP
EXPERTISE IN A SPECIFIC AREAS IN
AND THEY WOULD BE THE BOOTS ON
THE GROUND BUT WE STILL WOULD
HAVE THE SCIENTISTS THAT I
MENTIONED EARLIER AT THE
DEPARTMENT. TO PROVIDE THAT
COORDINATION AND THAT STATE
LEVEL PERSPECTIVE AND TO BE THAT
CLEARING HOUSE OF ALL THE
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT ARE GOING
ON IN AN IMPORTANT BRIDGE
BETWEEN -- FDA AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL AND COMING INTO CALIFORNIA
WITH US BUT ALSO A DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH IS ALSO A PARTNER
IN THIS EFFORT.
TO SO IT'S KIND OF A MULTI
PRONGED EFFORT HERE.
I SHOULD KNOW THIS BUT I DON'T
IS THERE SOME NEWSLETTER THAT
YOU GUYS PUT OUT THAT SAYS YOU
KNOW.
ALMOND GROWERS HERE'S THE LATEST.
FOOD SAFETY DEAL YOU GUYS GIVE
OUT NEWSLETTERS AT TIMES ARE NOW.
GET SAID MAY PUT ALERTS HAVE
NATALIE DO WE DO NOW -- NATALIE
CRAP GRANBERG OF INSPECTION
SERVICES SO ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE DO HAVE ON OUR PRODUCE
SAFETY PROGRAM AS A BLOG SITE
AND SO WE DO PUSH OUT
INFORMATION RELATIVE TO UPDATES --
BUT WHAT WE HAVE DONE IS
PARTNERED WITH OUR VARIOUS
COMMODITY GROUPS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THEY'VE HELPED US
REACH THEIR MEMBERSHIP UP AND
DOWN THE STATE.
THAT'S A RATHER THAN THE
EMERGENCY L. ELLIE -- YOU HAVE A
FOOD SAFETY.
WE HAVE NO ISSUES WITH THIS
PROPOSAL GOTCHA.
OKAY -- THIS IS STEP FOR
CONDITIONS TO APPROVE IS A
PROPOSED.
LET'S OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING.
CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING THIS IN
MOTION BY SENATOR STERN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ASKING HI JONES [inaudible]
REQUIRE.
YEP BUT MONEY THANK [inaudible]
STERN.
OKAY IN OUR LAST BUT NOT LEAST
LET'S HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATIONS JOIN THAT
[inaudible]
FOOD IN.
AGRICULTURE DEPARTMENT FOR THIS.
JOINT EFFORT AT TRANSITIONING TO
SAFER MORE SUSTAINABLE PEST
MANAGEMENT SOLUTIONS
[inaudible]
PARDON -- YES.
TELL US ABOUT EXECUTIVE ORDER
SHOULD THE THE NUMBER.
NOW GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY I'M THERESA MARKS IN
THE ACTING DIRECTOR AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION.
THE DEPARTMENT PESTICIDE
REGULATIONS MISSION IS TO
PROTECT HUMAN HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT BY REGULATING
PESTICIDES SALES AND YOU SAY MY
FOSTERING REDUCE RISK PEST
MANAGEMENT.
I DPR ALONG WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE REQUEST RESOURCES TO
ASSIST WITH THE TRANSITION TO
SAFER MORE SUSTAINABLE.
PEST MANAGEMENT SOLUTIONS THE
CIVIC WE DPR REQUESTS TWO
MILLION TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND ONE TIME
MANY TO CONTRIBUTE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO THE PEST MANAGEMENT
RESEARCH GRANT PROGRAM AND TO
FACILITATE ACROSS SECTOR WORK
GROUP.
THAT WILL IDENTIFY VALUE WHITE
AND DEVELOP SAFER PRACTICAL MORE
SUSTAINABLE ALTERNATIVE PEST
MANAGEMENT TOOLS FOR CALIFORNIA
GROWERS.
LAST WEEK AS YOUR PROBABLY AWARE
TO PROTECT WORKERS PUBLIC HEALTH
AND THE ENVIRONMENT WE ANNOUNCED
THAT CALIFORNIA'S BANNING OR
GOING TO INITIATE PROCEDURES TO
BANGOR PEER FOSS. FOR PURPOSES
OF PESTICIDE USE TO CONTROL A
VARIETY OF INSECTS ON MORE THAN
SIXTY CROPS.
AS CALIFORNIA MOVES TO IN THE
USE OF CORE PAIR FOSS WE'RE
TAKING A COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH
TO SUPPORT THE TRANSITION TO
SAFER MORE PRACTICAL AND
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT
SOLUTIONS.
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND OF THE FUNDING WILL
HELP CREATE A CROSS SECTOR
WORKING GROUP TO EVALUATE
RECOMMEND AND ACCELERATE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF ALTERNATIVES.
INCLUDING THE USE OF BIOLOGICAL
CONTROLS AND OTHER INTEGRATED
PEST MANAGEMENT PRACTICES.
THE P. R. REQUEST TWO POINT ONE
MILLION GENERAL FUND ONE TIME
MANY TO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
PROJECTS THAT DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES.
THAT REDUCE PESTICIDE RISK TO
HUMAN HEALTH AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDS WILL BE
USED TO SEEK ALTERNATIVES TO
CORPORATE FAUCET ADVANCE CYBER
MORE SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT
SOLUTIONS.
THIS APPROACH WILL HELP IDENTIFY
ALTERNATIVES THAT CAN BE
PRACTICALLY IMPLEMENTED IN THE
SHORT TERM ALSO DEVELOPING LONG
TERM SOLUTIONS FOR FURTHER
DEVELOPMENT.
AND I'LL LET CDFA ADDRESS.
THEIR PART OF THE PROGRAM AND I
HAVE A CLARIFICATION IS THE FIVE
POINT SEVEN AND CHANGE.
IS THAT JUST FOR PEST MANAGEMENT
ALTERNATIVES TO SIMPLY CORPORATE.
FOR CLICK HERE AEROPRESS FOSS.
OR IS IT ALL PEST MANAGEMENT --
ALTERNATIVES IT'S KIND OF A DUAL
PROCESS WHAT WE INTEND TO DO
WHEN WE BEGIN THIS THE THE AS
TASK FORCE WILL BE LOOKING AT
ALTERNATIVES TO CORPORATE FALSE.
AND THAT'S GOING TO BE OUR FIRST
ROUND -- SO THE THE ALTERNATIVE
IS THE RESEARCH ALTERNATIVES
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT FUNDING WE
WILL BE AT DPR DEVOTING THOSE
TWO ALTERNATIVES TO CORPORATE
FOSS.
SO WE'LL BE LOOKING AT MAYBE FOR
THAT WHY NOW WE'RE HOPING THIS
IS GOING TO BE A SUCCESSFUL
PROJECT.
AND IT WILL BE ABLE TO PERHAPS
COME AGAIN NEXT YEAR AND TALK
ABOUT CONTINUING SOME OF THE
WORK OF THIS WORKGROUP TO LOOK
AT THE OTHER MORE TOXIC
ALTERNATIVES AND HOW WE MIGHT GO
ABOUT DEVELOPING.
SAFER MORE MANAGEABLE
ALTERNATIVES CAM [inaudible]
OKAY.
WITH DRUG WE GOT WE GOT THE BAN
ON CLERK -- FOSS NOW WE HAVE.
ALTERNATIVE MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS
YEAH AND OUR COMPONENT IN THEIR
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION IN ONE
TIME WILL ACTUALLY AUGMENT FIVE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
THAT WAS APPROVED IN GENERAL
FUND FOR THIS YEAR ON GOING.
AND THEN ALSO WE DO HAVE A
REQUEST IN FOR BUDGET YEAR FOR
AG FUND A SORTIE FOR ANOTHER --
SLIGHTLY MORE THAN ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN A GOES TO IS CALLED I
ARE FOR WHICH IS ADMINISTERED BY
THE USDA.
AND WITH THAT PROGRAM DOES IT
LOOKS TO FIND ALTERNATIVE
PESTICIDES FOR SPECIALTY CROP
GROWERS TO REPLACE SOME OF THESE
ONES LIKE CHLORPYRIFOS.
THAT ARE EITHER BEING DE
REGISTERED OR FOR WHATEVER
REASON BECOMING SO ESTRICTIVE
TO USE WITH PERMIT CONDITIONS
THAT IT'S NOT A VIABLE
ALTERNATIVE FOR THE SPECIALLY
CROP GROWERS.
I JUST A QUICK OVERVIEW
SPECIALLY CROP SOMETIMES DON'T
GARNER THE ATTENTION FOR
MANUFACTURERS OF SOME OF THESE
ALTERNATIVE MATERIALS THERE LESS.
TOXIC IN THE ENVIRONMENT LESS
IMPACTFUL TO WORKERS AND OTHERS
THAT COME IN CONTACT WITH THEM.
SIMPLY BECAUSE OF NUMBERS
BECAUSE OF LOW AMOUNT OF ACREAGE
AND WEARS CORN AND SOYBEANS IN
THE MIDWEST GETS THEIR ATTENTION
BECAUSE IT'S A IT'S A NUMBERS
GAME.
AND SO THE HIGHER FOR PROGRAM --
TAKES ON PROJECTS ANNUALLY AND
THEY TAKE ABOUT THREE TO FOUR
YEARS TO COME TO FRUITION TO DO
THE REQUIREMENTS SO THAT THESE
LABELS CAN ADD SOME OF THESE NEW
SPECIALTY CROPS AND TRANSITION
THEM TO SOME OF THESE OTHER
MATERIALS THAT ARE CONSIDERED
LESS TOXIC AND SAFER AND BETTER
ALTERNATIVES. TO SOME OF THESE
OLDER MATERIALS SO THAT'S THE
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION PART OF
THAT.
OF THE TWO MILLION PART OF THAT
IS FOR BIOLOGICALLY INTEGRATED
FARMING SYSTEMS ARE WHAT WE CALL
BATHS.
AND THAT'S ACTUALLY.
SORT OF RESURRECTING IF YOU WILL
THIS PROGRAM EXISTED OVER A
DECADE AGO IN IT WAS A
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT FOCUSED TO
COME UP WITH BIOLOGICALLY
INTEGRATED FARMING SYSTEMS ARE
TO USE.
EXISTING BODY OF KNOWLEDGE IN
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT ON
DEMONSTRATION PLOT SO THE
GROWERS COULD SEE FOR INSTANCE
MAYBE THEIR NEIGHBOR ACROSS THE
ROADS GROWING THE EXACT SAME
TYPE OF CROP SO YOU KNOW THE
LOCAL CONDITIONS EXIST THAT ARE
PRETTY MUCH THE SAME.
YET THEY'RE DOCUMENTING A LOWER
AMOUNT OF INPUTS AND ADOPTING
PRACTICES LIKE ENHANCED SCOUTING
AND WITHHOLDING TREATMENT UNTIL
KNOWN ECONOMIC THRESHOLDS ARE
MET SO THAT THEY CAN REDUCE
PESTICIDE USAGE.
THERE'S ALSO A COMPONENT THAT
ALSO HELPS THEM TO MANAGE
FERTILIZER USAGE WITHOUT
SUFFERING YOUR LOSS OR QUALITY
LOSS.
AND SO IT'S REALLY JUST THAT
TAKING THAT WHOLE INTEGRATED
PEST MANAGEMENT BUT BIOLOGICALLY
INTEGRATED APPROACH TO FARMING
PUTTING IT OUT THERE.
IN A VENUE LIKE DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS WHERE GROWERS CAN SEE
FIRSTHAND AND BUILD THAT TRUST
LEVEL THAT THESE TECHNIQUES ARE
ACTUALLY EFFECTIVE AND WILL WORK.
IN IN THE OUTCOME OBVIOUSLY AS
THEY ADOPT THOSE TECHNIQUES AND
WE HAVE LESS OF THOSE MATERIALS
BEING USED.
IN A DIFFERENT APPROACH TO
FARMING WE KINDA SHIFT THE
PARADIGM IF YOU WILL OVER TIME
WHERE THEY'RE USING TECHNIQUES
LIKE THAT.
DO YOU FIND THEM OR DO THEY FIND
YOU DO YOU ON THIS INTEGRATED.
YOU KNOW.
IN A GREAT FARMING SYSTEM TO GO
OUT AND SAY HEY FARMER JONES
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TRY THIS --
ALTERNATIVE FARMING METHOD OR DO
THEY COME TO YOU AND SAY.
HEY I'VE GOT THIS ALTERNATE
FARMING METHOD THAT LIKE THE TO
THE USE IT AS A DEMONSTRATION
PROJECT AND HAVE YOU.
THE CORRECT THE UNIVERSITY HAS A
BIG LARGE BODY OF KNOWLEDGE AND
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE A VERY
AVAILABLE TO GROWERS YOU OTHER
WEBSITES PRETTY ROBUST THAT YOU
CAN.
SEARCH THE ROAD BY WHATEVER
COMMODITY YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
AND WHAT PART OF THE STATE
YOU'RE IN. FOR A LOT OF
INFORMATION OUT THERE BUT WHAT'S
REALLY MORE EFFECTIVE IS WHAT I
MENTIONED DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS
OUR VISION OF THIS.
IS TO GIVE OUT GRANTS OR
CONTRACTS IS THE THERE AGAIN
THREE WILL UC COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION BECAUSE THEY WORK WITH
GROWERS ON ALL THESE DIFFERENT
ISSUES.
AND SO THIS COULD ADD TO THEIR
PORTFOLIO OF IDENTIFYING GROWERS
SO TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION MORE
DIRECTLY I GUESS.
I SEE THIS AS MORE OF PUTTING
THAT OUT TO GROWERS TO SAY HERE
SOME TECHNIQUES THAT WE FEEL ARE
VERY EFFECTIVE IN THIS AREA THAT
WE CAN DEMONSTRATE FOR YOU AND
HAVE THEM PARTICIPATE.
LA -- PEST MANAGEMENT SOLUTIONS.
WE DIDN'T RAISE ANY ISSUES WITH
THIS PROPOSAL [inaudible]
CENTER MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WANT TO THANK BOTH DEPARTMENTS
IN PARTICULAR THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE FOR THE LEADERSHIP AND
MOVING FORWARD IN [inaudible]
WELL CHLORPYRIFOS IS FACING
CANCELLATION.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S MATCHING
THAT WITH THIS COMMITMENT.
TO EXPLORING ALTERNATIVES IN
THIS I THINK AS YOU POINTED OUT.
FOR PURPOSES NOT THE FIRST
CHEMICAL THAT SPIN.
DE REGISTERED AND THERE HAVE
BEEN RESOURCES IN THE PAST ON
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT ON
GOING WORK WITH COOP EXTENSION.
UNIVERSITY USDA CDFA OM SO I
THINK OVER TIME THERE'S BEEN.
A POSITIVE MOOD TOWARDS GREATER
RELIANCE ON INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT SUPPORTED BY
AGRICULTURE -- IN FINDING THAT
BALANCE BUT WE KNOW THE HISTORY
WITH CORP HERE FOR US.
THE USEPA HAD.
CONCLUDED THAT IT WAS NOT SAFE
ON A AND THEN THAT WAS A
DECISION THAT WAS REVERSED.
IN THIS IS PICKING UP ON THAT
BODY OF EVIDENCE AS WELL SO NOT
REALLY A QUESTION BUT JUST TO
APPLAUD.
THE DEPARTMENTS IN THE AGENCY IN
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR FOR ITS
COMMITMENT TO MOVE FORWARD IN A
REASONABLE MANNER IN A MANNER
THAT LOOKS TO THAN ONGOING NEEDS
OF AGRICULTURE SO THANK YOU.
SO I'M GONNA OPEN THE PUBLIC
HEARING WE'RE NOT GONNA TALK
ABOUT.
THE BAN ON CLERK FEAR FOSS WE'RE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE GRANT
PROGRAM IN THE PESTICIDE
ALTERNATIVE -- GRANT PROGRAM
THAT WE HAVE UP HOPEFULLY.
GO AHEAD HI AGAIN MISTER CHAIR
JENNIFER FEARING HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CENTER FOR FOOD SAFETY
AND PESTICIDE ACTION NETWORK AND
WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PROPOSED CHANGES IN TRANSITION.
TO SAFER MORE SUSTAINABLE PEST
MANAGEMENT SOLUTIONS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR FARMERS AND
PROPOSED PEST MANAGEMENT
RESEARCH GRANTS.
A COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH AND THE
PROPOSED CROSS SECTOR WORK GROUP
ARE ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY TO
DEVELOP SHORT AND LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS TO THE USE OF
PESTICIDES THAT ARE HARMFUL TO
PEOPLE.
WATER AIR AND WILDLIFE WE
APPLIED THE PROPOSALS OUTLINED
IN THE BUDGET TO DEVELOP AND
FUND ECOLOGICAL ALTERNATIVES
RECOGNIZING THAT THESE EFFORTS
ARE NEEDED TO AVOID REGRETTABLE
SUBSTITUTION. FOR CHLORPYRIFOS
AND OTHER HARMFUL PESTICIDES.
BOTH ORGANIZATIONS DO SUPPORT
THE PROPOSED CANCELLATION OF
PREPARE FOR US AND WE UNDERSTAND
AND SEE THAT THESE PROPOSED
BUDGET ACTIONS ARE PARALLEL AND
SUPPORTIVE OF THE CANCELLATION
BUT NOT CONTINGENT.
ON THE CANCELLATION OF CORPORATE
BOSSES JUSTIFIED BASED ON THE
DEMONSTRATED HARMS TO PEOPLE AND
THE ENVIRONMENT AND SHOULD
PROCEED SWIFTLY SO WE DEAR --
SUPPORT OF THIS BUDGET ITEM AND
THINK THAT DEPARTMENTS FOR
BRINGING IMPORTANT CERTAINLY
ECHO THIS OF GRATITUDE TO THE
GOVERNOR FOR TAKING ACTION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS NIKITA
CROWDED WITH A NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL ENERGIES HE'S
BEEN WORKING ON THE SCIENCE
BEHIND THE SPRING HARMING
PESTICIDE CLIPPER FOSS FOR
DECADES.
AND WE SUPPORT OF CANCELLATION
BY DPR SOON AS POSSIBLE I'M ON A
SEPARATE BUT PARALLEL TRACK WE
SUPPORT THIS BUDGET REQUEST IN --
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR THIS
TRANSITION TO SAFER AND MORE
SUSTAINABLE ALTERNATIVES WE DO
WANNA MAKE SURE THOUGH THAT THE
FUNDING -- IN THE ALTERNATIVES
THAT ARE IDENTIFIED THROUGH THIS
FUNDING IN THE IBM PROGRAMS THAT
WERE OUTLINED IN THE ME REVISED
DON'T SUPPORT ADDITIONAL TOXIC
CHEMICALS IN THIS IDEA OF
REGRETTABLE SUBSTITUTIONS --
WE'D LIKE TO SEE THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE FUNDING GO
TOWARDS ORGANIC COMPLIANT
HOLISTIC AND NON CHEMICAL PEST
MANAGEMENT SOLUTIONS A AND B.
THING FRANKLY THAT THIS IS
BENEFICIAL FOR FARMERS ACROSS
THE BOARD AND SO.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION -- ON THE
DESIGN AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
THESE PROGRAMS AND ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO EXTEND OUR GRATITUDE TO
THE GOVERNOR.
SECRETARIES RAWSON BLUMENFELD
I'M SENATOR DORADO IN THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOWER BROWN TODAY ON
BEHALF CALIFORNIA RICE
COMMISSION CALIFORNIA FRESH
FRUIT ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
CITRUS MUTUAL AND THE CALIFORNIA
COTTON.
GROWERS JENNER SOCIAIS XIN AS
WELL AS WESTERN AGRICULTURAL
PROCESSORS ASSOCIATION AND
HEARING TO THE CHAIRMAN'S --
INSTRUCTION I WILL NOT MENTION --
THE PRODUCT IN THE ACTION IT WAS
TAKEN EARLIER THIS WEEK -- BUT
DO WANT.
TO SORRY APPRECIATION TO THE
ADMINISTRATION. FOR COMING
FORWARD WITH THIS PROPOSAL THE
COMPREHENSIVE NATURE OF THE WORK
GROUP THAT OUTLINED IN -- YOUR
AGENDA IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
AND AND NECESSARY FOR US TO MOVE
FORWARD AND AND SEE MORE OF
THESE.
PRODUCTS MORE THESE PRACTICES BE
AVAILABLE HI THE REPRESENTATIVE
FROM CDFA HIT IT EXACTLY CORRECT
WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT THE NEED
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING FRYER.
FOR THERE'S SIGNIFICANT BACKLOG
THERE IS ALSO A SIGNIFICANT
DISINCENTIVE FOR MANUFACTURERS
TO BRING NEWER SAFER PRODUCTS TO
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF LESS
ACREAGE AND THE A ADDITIONAL
COSTS THAT IT TAKES TO BRING
THOSE PRODUCTS TO THE STATE SO.
THAT ADDITIONAL FUNDING WILL
DEFINITELY PROVIDE GREATER
ALTERNATIVES FOR FOR GROWERS
MOVING FORWARD HOW WE ASK THAT
YOU APPROVE -- THIS ITEM THANK
YOU.
OKAY WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING.
THERE'S A MOTION BY SENATOR
MINING.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CASKEY HI JONES. ONE EMMA CHOIR.
MONEY I STERN.
CLOSE ROLE TALLY VOTES THE I
SEVEN FOUR ZERO CONGRATULATIONS.
NOW LET'S OPEN THE ROLE ON ADRS
MEMBERS [inaudible]
I'LL GO [inaudible]
QUICKLY -- THE UNDER CAL PA.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE ON THE
PROCESS IMPROVEMENT POSITIONS
THE VOTE IS. THREE ONE YOUR
VOTING ON AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
STERN.
CLOSE ROLE TELL THE VOTE THE
AYES HAVE A FOR THE ONE ISSUE
NUMBER. TWENTY EIGHT THE STATE.
THE OFFICE OF THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL LIFE IN FIRE AND LIFE
SAFETY DIVISION THE VOTE IS FOUR
ZERO AT THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
PLEASE CALL THE UP TO MEMBERS
JONES [inaudible]
OF I CLOSE ROLE TELEVOTES THE I
SEVEN FOUR ONE THE OTHER NEXT ON
UNDER CAL FIRED -- THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL LICENSING AND
CERTIFICATION OF PROGRAM THIS IS
THE EXCEPT.
THE STAFF RECOMMEND OR THE
PROPOSAL.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
JONES.
CLOSE ROLE THE AYES HAVE IT.
FIVE TWO ZERO UNDER PARKS AND
RECREATION ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY
THIS IS PUBLIC SAFETY EMERGENCY
RESPONSE.
THE ROAD VOTE IS THREE ZERO WITH
THE CHAIR OTING I PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CANS [inaudible]
STERN.
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU VOTE THE
AYES HAVE A FIVE ZERO MATT IS
APPROVED.
PARKS AND RECREATION.
ISSUE NUMBER.
THIRTY ONE WHILE THOU REPAIR
WILDFIRE REPAIR AND
REIMBURSEMENT.
THE STAFF.
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE ARE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS PER THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION THE VOTE WAS TWO
ZERO ACT THAT YOU'RE VOTING HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
JONES [inaudible]
REQUIRE [inaudible]
STERN.
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU VOTE THE I
SEVEN FIVE ZERO AT THE WE'LL SEE
FIRE RESTORATION RECOVERY THIS
IS ISSUE NUMBER. THIRTY THREE
WITH THIS SANTA MONICA.
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY THE VOTE
IS THREE ZERO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS JONES
[inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU VOTE THE
AYES HAVE A THREE FIVE ZERO ON
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES DAM SAFETY RISK
MANAGEMENT THE VOTE IS.
FOUR ZERO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBER.
JONES.
THIS IS THE ITEM NUMBER --
THIRTY FOUR THE NOT VOTING CLOSE
ROLLED THE HE WAS A THAT'S ON
THE RIVER MCGUIRE DISTRACT.
AND THE STAFF 310-233-3430. FIVE
THREE SIX THREE SEVEN TWO THIRTY
THREE IT'LL STOP.
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY THREE DID I
CLOSE TO ROLL ON THAT.
NOW I DIDN'T EVEN OPEN THE ROLE
OKAY SO THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTY THREE THE WALLS THE FIRE.
RESTORATION RECOVERING VOTERS
THREE ZERO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS JONES.
MCGUIRE.
OKAY CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU THE
VOTE THE AYES HAVE IT FIVE ZERO
NOW THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES AND DAM SAFETY.
RISK MANAGEMENT I ACT ISSUE
NUMBER.
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CHOIR.
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU VOTE THE
AYES HAVE A FIVE ZERO DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES ISSUENUMBER
THIRTY FIVE OPEN AND TRANSPLANT.
WATER DATA ACT THE VOTE IS FOUR
ZERO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS INQUIRE.
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU VOTE THE I
SEVEN FIVE ZERO ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTY SIX WITH PARTNER WATER
RESOURCES THIS IS URBAN FLOOD
RISK REDUCTION.
THE VOTE IS THREE ZERO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS REQUIRE
[inaudible]
STERN.
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU VOTE THE
AYES HAVE A FIVE ZERO AND ISSUE
NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN WITH THE AIR
RESOURCE BOARD.
THIS IS THE EVALUATION APPROVAL
OF INNOVATIVE FREIGHT
TECHNOLOGIES TO VOTE IS THREE
ZERO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS REQUIRE.
IN TERMS OF VOTING CLOSE ROLE
IT'S FOUR ZERO HI I JUST HAVE
THIS.
ISSUE NUMBER.
TWELVE WELL AS FOR AND FORTY OR
FORTY IF WE DIDN'T.
IN A LIFE [inaudible]
OKAY. TO HAVE THE RIGHT.
OKAY LET'S GO TO THE BACK TO
PART.
PART A THE VOTE IS THREE TO ONE
THIS IS THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION LIFELINE -- PROGRAMS.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
HI.
CLOSE TO ROLL TALLY THE VOTE THE
VOTE I SEVEN FOUR TO ONE THAT
CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS. FOR
TUESDAY MAY TWENTY FOURTEENTH WE
WILL ADJOURN AND SEE YOU
TOMORROW AT